okay
m mro
you
m
that's
morning
anyone hello we're going to get
started all right so for for uh this
last day of the
workshop uh we'll focus on applications
and this day will be shared by Alex Alex
is a pdu here at Miller uh focusing on
scientific discovery and contributing a
lot to the jinet
development um so he will present the
the plan for today uh please give him a
round of
applause thank you Victor good morning
everybody uh uh welcome back for the
third and last day of the milet
workshop um I hope you woke up early and
review the material for today uh so the
idea for today like Victor already said
is uh to have more of
a u
applications uh
handson day in a way um you've been
exposed to to the theory we hope it
wasn't too too heavy but that that gave
you the the the base for for you know
have a a good understanding of the of
what we can do with gonet and we hope to
to continue this today so we're going to
start the day with a with a session
about gonets the use of gonet for
scientific discovery and it's going to
be like a a series of short relatively
short uh talks so you see a biological
sequence design molecular design
molecular and protein conformation
materials Discovery caal discovery
combinatory optimization language
Etc uh that's going to be in the in the
first part of the day we'll have a a
session by Emanuel about how we can
evaluate gfets which is not a a trivial
thing like most generative models in
machine learning and we'll have lunch
and the in the afternoon we'll do a live
coding
session and then we will finish today
with uh what we call a giet clinic so
I'll take this chance to to remind
everybody that what what we plan to do
in this session is to take the ideas
that you have submitted oh I'm working
on this and I thought maybe I can use
jlet for this problem so we will analyze
if these are problems that are well
suited for different or not so if you
have new ideas feel free
to uh come to us and let us know or just
spontaneously uh uh speak at the de
session and we will close the day with a
with another talk by by Professor yosua
venu so without further Ado I would like
to introduce the first Speaker uh Mo
Jane who has already talked a few times
so I won't
uh extend too much on the introduction
so welcome Mo with a an Applause and
Flor is
yours
thanks Alex uh hello everyone I'm in
person today so uh I'll just uh give a
I'll start with a brief introduction for
why GES for scientific discovery so sub
motivation and then focus on one
particular application on biological
sequences and how we can use uh gonets
there uh so
uh so we are we all know we all here
know that we are faces with uh we are
faced with a series of unprecedented
Global challenges
uh in the current times we have the Lumi
climate crisis uh and we
have a number of big public health
challenges uh so the question uh that we
ask here is uh what can machine learning
do to help in accelerating uh scientific
discovery for these problems now uh just
to be clear it's not implying here that
machine learning can solve all of these
problems these are very complex social
technical problems but uh uh a lot of uh
ways to tackle these challenges uh
involve coming up with new scientific
discoveries uh and by new scientific
discoveries I mean either better
understanding so in the case of the
climate crisis uh there is still a lot
more understanding required about the
immense impact that uh human
civilizations have on the climate
systems um and even in terms of coming
up with new discovering new things so
for example in the case of public health
challenges like if you have new diseases
how do you come up with new uh with uh
cures for these diseases as soon as
possible without much loss of life um
and we already have seen some amazing
successes of machine learning helping in
some of these discoveries so uh very
recently with the coid pandemic um of
course the drugs were not discovered
using uh machine learning but scientific
discovery like basic Sciences so the
development of mRNA vaccines contributed
a lot to the uh to the speed at which uh
these vaccines were developed so I think
we can all agree that there is some
potential for machine learning to help
at least in accelerating these
challenges uh sorry in accelerating
scientific discoveries to tackle these
challenges um so before uh before I move
on to anything more specific Let's uh
let's uh talk about Guinness so Guinness
is the famous uh beer brand um and uh
it's I guess an unexpected uh source of
like the beginning of systematic exper
experiments I would say uh so uh yeah so
GIS is a beer is a beer uh manufacturing
company so what they do is they go grow
barley uh they uh through some chemical
processes convert barley into nice beer
and this nice beer then makes them money
so uh this was their model uh the
business this is this has been their
business model for centuries so in the
early 1900s uh they started asking the
question uh due to several environmental
factors how can they improve the barley
yields to make the crop more robust to
soil and weather conditions so uh there
were uh there were some uh climate
anomalies uh that uh Guinness was
experiencing which was affecting the
supply of barley and the crop was
sometimes not as good so they couldn't
get good beer um so this was actually
one of the first instances where this
idea of systematic experiments sort of
came into picture uh all thanks to
William goset uh who was a statistician
who was working at GIS at the time uh
who was designing experimental design
approaches for systematically uh testing
experiments on barley in like very small
um like repeated experiments so you make
some uh uh modifications to the
environmental conditions to the crop uh
uh to uh like the uh General growing
process of the crop and then you see how
robust it is to weather conditions in
very uh controlled environments and
that's one of that like that's basically
where this whole sort of U uh topic of
experimental design uh uh sort of
started uh you might also know William
goset from this famous uh the student T
Test so he's student he couldn't publish
under his own name because he was
working at Guinness so he had to use the
word student he has to he had to use the
pseudonym of student
um so what did like over the years we
have much better systematic U sort of
representation of the discovery process
and it roughly goes as follows so the
first part is we accumulate observation
so we make observations we our dat
during under like specific conditions
things that we're interested in um and
then we analyze this data we try to fit
models on this data uh so this is a very
fundamental step of we assume some model
we check whether the model is correct we
try to analyze where it is incorrect and
so on uh we then come up with some
hypothesis to explain some phenomenas
that we observe so for instance in in
the case
of in the case of uh uh like a drug
Discovery for example uh if you see some
particular behavior of a virus we try to
explain what is causing that behavior so
one very basic and maybe technically
incorrect example is in the case of the
co uh uh uh the Corona virus the spike
proteins was identified uh uh to be the
one which sort of attacked the cells so
that was one hypothesis uh that we had
then the next thing which was done was
experimentally verifying this hypothesis
so how do we first of all make sure that
it is indeed the spike protein which is
a cause of the problem um or which is
like the attack Vector for example and
maybe then uh this experiment is
performed so we
designed some experiments to actually
understand whether it is indeed the
spike protein and based on the
experiment we'll have new measurements
and we can then use those measurements
to sort of Feed the cycle again so this
is this nice is virtual virtuous cycle
which uh is not always true uh like most
of the times the process is much
nonlinear it doesn't really go in this
nice Circle but it has this General is
structure um this process you can
actually divide into two sep categories
so one part is the experimentation where
we actually interface with the real
world and the other part is computation
where we sort of build computational
models and and they don't have to be on
computers but uh it's it's a general
formalism of computation um and these
two cycles have sort of fed into one
another so experiment improvements in
experimentation require improvements in
computation and vice versa if you have
better computational methods you also
need better experimentation but what we
have been seeing recently is that uh due
to advances in Natural Sciences in
robotics and so on uh there have been
there has been an explosion in the
quality of experiments that you can
perform and at the scale at which you
can perform these experiments uh so
think of things like hrut asses uh the
James web telescope or the large hydron
collider so experimentalist or sorry
experimentation has sort of Taken huge
leaps forward in terms of the scale at
which we can collect data and also uh
the the the quality of measurements so
you can now actually record a live cell
in a like a video which is pretty uh is
pretty cool uh but what this means is
computation has sort of flag uh be
lagged behind so what we need is
actually computational approaches which
can leverage these richer experimental
observations and also leverage the scale
at which we can perform experiments but
there are some challenges uh which uh
need some consideration so the the first
thing is that of reward misspecification
and under specification so the problem
which yosua Emanuel and a lot of others
alluded to yesterday is that there is
some reward underspecification or
misspecification that happens when we
try to do these uh things
computationally we cannot actually model
the true objective that we want so if
you want the truck to work in humans you
cannot actually build a model for that
which is very difficult so instead you
assume some proxy oh whether it binds
with the particular Target and even that
is not perfect because you have to
simulate the physics and you have to
make some approximations so ultimately
your oracles which you use for design
don't accurately ref reflect their
property of interest uh which makes
diversity a key component in in this
process of experimental design you
cannot actually put all your eggs in one
basket because that basket might be
incorrect
um the other thing is also the fact that
we can do experiments in parallel it is
a it's a paradigm shift so when you uh
when you can actually run 10,000
experiments at the same cost and same
time uh as a single experiment it
requires a rethinking of how of the
algorithms and like how these algorithms
actually interact with the world
so uh for example in in in material
design there is uh again a growing uh uh
uh growing presence of a high throughput
uh uh High throughput uh lb ABS
essentially uh and so so is the case in
drug Discovery as well
um uh yeah so uh the other thing is in
terms of modeling so uh like I said
initially we Tred to fit some models of
the world um one important aspect is you
can have multiple different explanations
for the same phenomena That You observe
and without uh further experiments you
cannot actually assume any of these
single models is correct so uh you uh
ideally what you would want to do is
reason over all these different uh
possible structural models uh which all
fit the data and in order to design
effective experiments and order to
actually get to the bottom of uh like
get a true understanding of what's going
on so uh hopefully I have sort of
convinced you that these are like very
important technical challenges in terms
of what sort of methods we would want
and of course we are at a gonet workshop
so
the point is that gonet can be a useful
tool for some of these challenges and at
least can be a helpful tool in some of
these challenges so specifically in
terms of data analysis and modeling
generating new hypothesis uh generating
new or designing experiments and some of
which will be covered in talks today
throughout the day but before we move on
to some of those topics I also wanted to
highlight some other uh applications of
gonets which are not covered today uh
but are still nonetheless very
interesting so you can have games uh
two-player games recently uh like
superum connect for bot uh if you want
if you would like to play with it uh is
on this papers uh uh you can find it in
this paper uh it can be used for inverse
problems it has been used for robust
scheduling uh problems which uh I guess
Salam mentioned as well yesterday it has
also been applied to neural architecture
search uh for latent variable modeling
for inferring philogenetic trees uh so
the applications are abundant uh and as
you'll also see uh throughout the day
to-day uh uh it's a very flexible and
very powerful modeling Tool uh which can
be uh applied to a variety of different
domains so let's come to biological
sequences uh so what biological what are
biological sequences and why am I
talking about about them so bi by
biological sequences I'm referring to
things like proteins DNA RNA uh
essentially large biomolecules which can
in most which can be represented as
which can have like sequence
representation so as a sequence of
tokens uh so proteins for example are
sequences of amino acids DNA is sequence
of uh the actg bases um and so and
similarly
RNA now a lot of these sequences have
like some fundamental roles in in human
biology so proteins are are basically
the the the the backbone on which
uh cells function and DNA and RNA sort
of control this flow of proteins um and
uh they are very important even from a
therapeutic point of view from uh
materials design point of view uh in the
case of DNA Optimas um and RNA I guess a
lot everyone here has probably heard of
or taken the MRNA vaccine so uh I I I
don't need to convince you about the
importance of these things and uh really
the problem that we uh wanted to study
was uh can we come up with computational
approaches to design diverse and novel
biological sequences to optimize certain
property of interest and in this case
this property of interest uh can be like
binding to a particular Target
functioning as an antibody functioning
as a antibiotics or in general whatever
property you're interested in or in the
case of for example DNA apers you can
have uh good electronic properties to be
used as a material um so this uh brings
us to the questions how uh of how do we
design sequences so a sequ like
sequences are just like a collection of
tokens ordered collection of tokens uh
you can have two ways or or I'll discuss
two ways in which you can actually do
this uh there could be other ways uh but
these two are the ones that we have
actually tried and uh each of them has
their own set of pros and cons so the
first one is the most naive one uh but
still extremely uh successful one uh of
of generating the sequence Auto
regressively from beginning to end so
you go from left to right generate one
to car at a time and
then and you decide when to stop or you
have some Maximum fixed length so in
this case uh so for example you first
add this W token then a then K one token
at a time very straightforward so here
your action space in the context of
gonets would be the vocabulary of
available tokens so in the case of
proteins it would be the 20 amino acids
in the case of D would be the four bases
and one stop
token uh the the distribution that you
want to sample from X would be complete
sequences so which have a stop token at
the end and your inter uh your set of
States all possible States will be uh
will be just like all possible
incomplete and complete
sequences uh so what is the Pro for this
uh so what is the advantage of this
particular approach uh it is that you
can it's very well suited for generating
completely inovo sequences so like very
new it's much easier to generate these
things um but the problem is like if you
have very long sequences so for example
in the context of uh RNA in the MRNA
vaccines the it is like a sequence
length of thousands so it's the RNA is
like, or 12 2,000 uh tokens long so in
this case the trajectories can be very
long and as we heard uh yesterday longer
trajectories uh are harder to train on
there are learning problems for
France uh what so what is the other
approach the other approach is more akin
to uh like evolutionary algorithms and
evolutionary um uh approaches so we
start from some given sequence and we
generate a sequence of mutations on that
sequence so what we do is we take the
sequence we pick some location on the
sequence to mutate and then we mutate it
with some uh some other token uh uh so
here your action space would be uh like
which location out of uh which location
on in the sequence should I mutate and
then you have the second action so you
can of decompose the action into two two
steps the first one would be picking the
location and the second one would be
picking the mutation uh to make at that
particular
location so uh here the uh it's it's
slightly weird here so here uh the
distribution that we'll be sampling from
is the distribution of like complete
mutation sequences and not just like uh
which have like stopped and your
intermediate sequences would be all
possible mutation sequences uh the pro
here is that these trajectories will be
shorter so learning in G Frets would be
nicer uh or easier um uh but the con is
uh the this sort of action space this
sort of mdp is more suited towards local
exploration around the starting sequence
rather than uh actually designing
completely new sequences so more like
lead optimization where you start with
one particular sequence and you want to
just make it as better as good as you
can um the the next uh important
question to ask here is what should be
the reward so as I alluded to earlier
you you always will rely have to rely on
some proxy but this proxy will have some
uh under specification or
misspecification uh but the nice part is
if uh under certain uh conditions this
lack of knowledge can be a good thing
you can actually use this lack of
knowledge to guide your design process
so uh what you can do is you can use uh
the uncertainty in your model uh if your
model can express it un its uncertainty
uh you can use this uncertainty to guide
your design process so you can uh sort
of generate more candidates uh which uh
would improve uh which would reduce the
uncertainty in the predictions of your
model uh so this is where we leverage
ban models uh so if you have a beian
model you can quantify the uncertainty
you have over let's say high reward
regions and you can use this uncertainty
as a guiding signal for generating
sequences with your G um and these ban
models can be instantiated through
approximate Bion methods like ensembles
Dropout or so on or if you want to be uh
bit adventurous like a full ban model uh
so uh this brings us to this this Active
Learning
Loop so what I mean by this Active
Learning Loop is Gen is just this sort
of inner outer loop sort of thing where
you have some Oracle which is like the
thing that you would actually like to
approximate but it is expensive to
evaluate so you have to uh rely on this
sort of more complicated uh setup where
you have this model uh yeah where you
have a model uh which approximates the
Oracle you have an acquisition function
which quantifies uh basically this
uncertainty thing that I mentioned
earlier your ESS so what is your
uncertainty about your predictions of
your model and how you can use it as uh
an Information Gain metric for your
generative policy which is the gfl net
here um so the way the loop goes is you
start with some data set let's say of
historical evaluations of this Oracle
you build a model using that data set
you use that model to generate a reward
for the gonet um uh or to define the
reward for a G flet you train the G flet
with that reward and then you select the
most ing candidates you evaluate them
with the Oracle and then you continue
this Loop um uh with like appropriate
choices of like acquisition functions
and models you can actually tackle a
variety of different scenarios so in in
reality you won't always have this nice
single Oracle that you would like to
optimize for you might have multiple
objectives that you would like to
optimize for so uh whether a drug is
effective and whether a drug is toxic to
humans uh so this becomes a
multiobjective uh optimization problem
or you could
have the same Oracle but at different
fidelities so uh let's say for measuring
how effective a drug is you can either
have like some in silic like some cheap
neural network approximation you can
have some actual physical physics
simulation or you can have like an an
invitro acid so like an actual live
experiment so you can also leverage like
different Fidelity
articles so just to give you like a
brief taste what uh what sort of tasks
that we have applied this to we have uh
single objective tasks for generating
antimicrobial peptides so antimicrobial
peptides are short sorry peptides are
short proteins um and we generate them
left to right and we get some good
results in
silico uh we can do multiobjective
optimization uh in the context of red
fuorescent proteins so the task here is
to design fluorescent proteins so here
the proteins are much longer so we rely
on this mutation based uh uh action
space that I described earlier so the
trajectories are fairly small even
though the actual protein is quite large
and we get good improvements in terms of
the hyper volume um and we can also do
multifidelity
optimization we all with so in this case
the example is of DNA optom so DNA
aptamers are DNA sequences which can
which have some uh use in uh material
design problems um and even here you can
like this graph is a bit hard to pass
but you can take a look at it later in
the paper uh but essentially uh you can
leverage these different Fidelity
oracles which have different costs
associated to them um uh while and get
better performance while uh uh using up
less of your budget but essentially uh
the just to paint a picture you can use
G flets uh for a variety of different uh
sequence design task in in conjunction
with other uh Bean machine learning uh
techniques in order to get like useful
uh uh biological sequence design uh we
get diverse and novel high scoring
candidates which we set out to uh before
I I will add a caveat that the all the
results I present here these are all in
silico so we we we are still in process
of doing like actual wet lab evaluations
of these and until then of course uh
there these results are to be taken with
a grain of salt but these are still
again promising results
a promising early
results um yeah that's
it thank you marks do we have questions
in the
room uh thank you for the very nice talk
I have a question for the all regressive
generation process so like if we do
naely the action space going to like
space State space going to explode in
Horizon right in the length of horizon
exponentially so like the did you use
just KN method or like you use more like
some like CIS stics or to like restrict
the state space um experiments so here
we do not restrict the state space so
the state space is like basically for
example in the left to right sequence
generation the state space is just
unrestricted it can anything uh but it
is possible to do that so you can have
for instance if you have some prior
knowledge about what sort of sequence
what sort of structures you might be
looking for uh you can actually uh
impose those prior so one one one other
way to think of it is for example
instead of adding one token you can
think of adding multiple tokens that way
you can sort of uh uh uh trade off
between the size of your state space
Size of Your Action space and try to
come up to a good sort of Middle Ground
uh uh but in all these results it was
not uh that was not used uh thank
you any other questions for
Mar right well if not thank you very
much again Mo that that is
great that sets the stage for the rest
of the day very nicely and next we have
Emmanuel Benjo who will talk about
molecular with gonets and you've been
introduced before so I let you go ahead
thanks
um
okay cool yeah so you know mo just
talked about some really big
molecules um there's many other
kinds uh materials biological molecules
other types of molecules I won't go into
um for this talk I'll be focusing on
small molecules it's what I work on the
most and they're usually kind of the the
focus of of drugs because they have many
nice properties like they can float
around in your blood really easily um
and there's lots of ways to go about
that
so molecules are physical objects um
that are sometimes hard to comprehend
and we have to represent them in a
computer somehow um and so that's a
challenge in itself um
and there's lots of approaches for that
of course I'm only listing some of them
here um the you know very classic one is
is like smile strings uh you just
represent your molecules as a series of
characters it's quite convenient because
chemists can read that uh language
models can read that it's just a
sequence of tokens um and you can use
you know language models something
similar to design them um the other
Paradigm which I work on the most is
just representing these molecules as
graphs so you know each atom is one node
each Edge is one Bond you can feed that
to grafal network Transformer
architecture of your choice of course
there's also a lot of kind of hand
design features uh for molecules W get
into that
today another
approach is to think about molecules as
uh graphs of fragments right so think of
Lego blocks that you plug together um
fragments are convenient because uh they
can be kind of pre-designed by a chemist
who knows what they're doing uh and then
the space that you end up with is kind
of always going to look nice whatever
Lego blocks you plug together um the
problem of course is that this is less
expressive in terms of the size of the
state space you're not reducing it
because the number of combinations you
can make it smaller um and of course the
question is how do you design those
fragments that's extremely hard uh
historically people design them by hand
and intuition um very common strategy is
you have a data set of molecule and you
just look at common subgraphs uh common
scaffolds stuff like that choose the
most common ones and call that your
fragment
Library uh another approach is more
related to how would we make these
molecules in the real world and to think
of your fragments as a collection of
synthetic blocks that you could actually
plug together in a real world in a
chemical synthesis lab um and of course
the the ultimate version of that is to
not even think of Designing molecules
but think of Designing a series of
reactions right so that's ultimately
what's going to happen in a lab when
someone actually makes the molecule why
not just start there right so um still
work in progress although there's lots
of papers already doing this um working
progress in in my research
um to to have agents Whose actions is
not like add this atom or add this
fragment but really like do this
chemical reaction between two things
um and of course this is a bit of a
weird kind of mdp weird environment to
live in but it has excellent constraints
and chemist typically love that because
it's very easy to think about what's
going on
um kind of reward functions do we use is
also complicated
um you know the the ultimate reward
function is like did we cure disease X
without killing the patient uh or making
the
worse um and there's not a lot of
samples Sy that word of course so you
have to use uh proxies of that you have
to use um things that you think
are are kind of related to how diseases
work um the very
classic thing to to look for in in drugs
is protein Inhibitors so something that
will attach to a protein in usually a
small pocket and kind of make it change
3D shape um and in that process kind of
deactivate it but there's all sorts of
uh types of drugs uh there's molecular
glues that kind of bring two proteins
together um protax which kind of bind to
molecule and tell your cell oh you
should really destroy that uh protein
and recycle it then there's the unknown
um if you know you've ever used aopen
parol for the Europeans here um we kind
of don't really know how they work and
that's true for many things uh if you go
on the Wikipedia page you'll see lots of
kind of uncertainty quantifiers about
the method of action of of of these
little drugs um so yeah it can be quite
hard and then of course you know there's
like the main effect you want to get
there's also side effects which you
don't usually want to get and then
there's uh pharmacokinetics which is
about how quickly know your liver
absorbs the drug and rejects it or
or clears it from your body um side
effects so maybe you target one protein
but um the small molecule you're
designing
affects other proteins that you don't
want to Target so quite complicated and
then of course if you design kind of in
silico something you know it might be
cute and it might make your reward
function go up but actually it might be
totally unfeasible or cost like large
amounts of money to make uh by the gram
so there's lots of source of kind of
signal of how a particular molecule
affects biology uh of course you can do
a lot of physical simulation there's
different kind of levels of uh how much
compute you're willing to pay for how
much Precision you're going to get
um don't want to spend too long here but
there's some some order of how expensive
it gets as I mentioned at the beginning
you know you can test the molecule on
humans but that's like the most
expensive and the thing you want to do
the least right you want to be really
sure before that that what you're going
to do in a human is going to work um and
uh it's a tough because all these these
models these systems kind of only
approximate uh the end system which is
the human um so back to gonets most
papers that if not all do small
molecules have been doing
fragments um and then using docking in
particular as the reward signal um and
typically what we do is we have like a
data set of dock molecules train some
machine learning model to regress to the
docking energy use that as a reward uh
and then we've been using a bunch of
heuristics U to kind of constrain the
space to to look nice uh which is a hard
question um generally every recursion
we've been doing more atom based stuff
um and then ml is similar we have a data
set of cell activities
stuff like that um that you know we can
throw at a large model find unit and get
some kind of reasonable estimate of of
utility of a a molecule plus of course a
whole bunch of heris stics um which can
always make a big difference um
so a fragment based environment is
relatively simple again think of them as
as Lego blocks that you kind of plug in
together the action space of the agent
here
um your mdp is going to be basically you
have some current graph of fragments you
can choose to attach a new block to it
uh sometimes fragments have like
different rotations so there's different
ways you can attach them together that
can also be an action um and then you've
heard about masking it's also very
important um here the masking is if it's
fairly straightforward typically you
don't want your molecule to get too big
so you kind of limit the number of
fragments and of course um
sometimes uh blocks have to be uh kind
of properly attached otherwise they
don't make sense uh and so you kind of
prevent the agent from stopping if it
has plugged two blocks together that it
hasn't properly attached
um atom based environments are a bit
trickier uh but also fairly
straightforward typically you kind of
build the atom graph atom by atom so
main action choice is going to be choose
some atom and some attachment point uh
and add a single bond between two atoms
um of course atoms can have a bunch of
properties
um charge Etc bonds can be uh single
Bond triple bonds stuff like that and
then uh the most Nal part is that you
kind of want to mask a lot of things to
prevent your agent from creating
molecules that don't make a lot of
sense
um one example of how we've applied this
with gonets that I particularly like is
the multiobjective paper actually papers
there's there's two now
um and here we're kind of you've heard
about conditional gonets yesterday right
so here we kind of condition a gonet on
a vector of preferences between multiple
objectives uh and and we train the gonet
to uh learn all the possible trade-offs
in some sense so here what you're seeing
is all is all these spto fronts in red
between different uh objectives that the
the model ends up learning and the four
objectives here are like how good the
molecule is how drug like does it look
how easy would it be to make and is it
not too heavy um and of course this
works better than baselines uh at least
as far as we've measured and in
particular again is Shine by their
diversity in what they
produce um and then with some open
questions in that domain I think we're
still not there in terms of like truly
scaling to really large State spaces
especially in the atom based uh domain
um the fragments libraries that we use
when we do fragments are kind of there
and and we haven't thought too deeply
about them but it would be really cool
to like find
those either train a model that that
proposes fragments and and kind of learn
that or even just dynamically uh with
kind of hierarchical
models uh I think this for the RL
Crow um kind of learn what are good sets
of fragments that go well together to
create molecules there's lots of weird
data
sets in chemistry and and biology um
disjointed from disjointed kind of
sources that all aren't always super
well aligned um but in some senses
there's lots of data um that is out
there ready to be used
um you know some other challenges
finding the right priors um right
architectures these are all non-trivial
things that the graph Network Community
is still working a lot
on um of course everything about action
space and of what are the choices we
give to the agents that's also really uh
impactful I want to say kind of design
Choice um and uh it matters a lot I
think in in molecular design
and of course usual which is we want TR
understand what we're doing uh it's not
not trivial but really useful to kind of
scale
better get better performance out of
models better interpretability out of
models um to understand how they
generalize how they kind of understand
these uh discontinuities in the reward
space uh how they act out of
distribution all that good
stuff um so yeah I think I'll stop here
thank
you Emanuel we have a few minutes for
questions ideally from the audience
instead of from me so don't don't be
shy um in the meantime so maybe maybe
one question um uh I'll try to ask
something that might be helpful for for
the
audience um so there's been a lot of
research in the last years on on on this
area like molecular design and
everything uh drug Discovery
Etc and there's a lot of research
directions with diffusion models uh you
know well you know you know more more
than me so I will start mentioning here
but I would like to hear from you so
what are the unique or special angles
the gonets
offer uh you know don't need to review
the whole
literature and compare but what what are
for you you work on this youve decided
to to put your time on this what are for
you this what's special yeah I think you
compare specifically to what works
really well which is the fusion um we're
kind of wasting less time playing with
noise when the action makes a the agent
makes a decision it's like uh making a
structured prediction in some sense um
and I think that
more kind of simple efficient and boost
from generalization better uh and I
think that's true for other things like
V molecular V and all that stuff uh
which in my opinion rely on noise in a
weird way
um but you know ultimately these are all
kind
of equivalent or not equivalent like
just as good I think a large part is of
course the ne Network that you're using
the the data set um so
but I think in scaling G have a better
chance we understand how to train them
better thank
you yeah go
ahead I have a related question like uh
I think the when in the previous slide
like you mentioned that there are
several representations for the
basically like the molecules right atom
fragment based or like atom models like
more smous notation something but like
do you do you think that how we can
combine like these representation at the
same time like what be the ideal ways
yeah of course so you can combine
fragments and atom based design right
you could start with a rough scaffold
rough draft that's fragment based and
then switch to a second phase where the
agent can add individual atoms um you
can probably seed something also with
reactions or constrained atom design by
reactions like there's all sorts of
mixes like uh as long as you're willing
to Cod it which is nontrivial uh there's
probably some interesting stuff to
do the reason why you're using fragment
Bas is now computation is more easier
yeah okay there there's a clear
trade-off right between uh fragments
where you make graphs of five to 10
nodes um and and you're kind of bi
design creating molecules that look
nice uh but you have maybe 10 to the 15
State space an atom base where you might
have 10 to the 100 State space uh but
then you have way more freedom the agent
can design whatever it
wants thank
you thanks for the questions oh we have
another one yeah that was I questions
right so when you have the 2D like
scaffold how do you typically account
for the flexibility of molecule when
binding and uh I mean it can fold in
different ways sorry the the what the
molec when you have the two D scale
folds and how do you account for because
it can be just rotating right different
ways yeah and and one other thing is
that because it's it's it kind
interacting just in the solvent do you
account for the solvent molecules like
water or other things when binding or
it's been thank you um well answer your
first question we kind of leave that up
to the reward in some sense
um I
think let's say a molecule has two
mirror images um you can imagine the
reward function being able to evaluate
both and say well the max is this
because one of the versions of that
molecule is useful um and that's fairly
straightforward um you can also Imagine
kind of a substep is generating a 3D
confirmer that's interesting for that
molecule um for The Binding in the do
specifically
uh I mean in terms of like the G
research we've been using the same
Oracle for a while it's not very
interesting probably to like a medicinal
chemist um what we use for example
recursion is nothing like docking it's
based on like pho mix data uh and like
activity ac50 predictions um I know that
there's lots of groups doing lots of
kind of in silico predictions and then
there's a lot of fine chaining you can
do with how you simulate the molecule
protein uh system but it's not something
I've been
working go ahead so uh from a drug
Discovery Point of View you would want
to like explore all the possible modes
so that would be like atom base and then
the first uh approach that you described
right so from what I understand the
limits right now is that computational
power but like how big is that limit and
is that something we could overcome or
will we be like will we be always
limited and this we'll have to rely on
fragment based and evolutionary
approach so I'm going to show you a
funny graph a bit later in my other talk
where uh you know we've changed G for
very long they always discover new stuff
because the state space is so massive um
and that's true for fragments that's
true for atoms uh so there's a big
question of exploration is cool but you
want to get to the high reward stuff
faster in some sense uh you will never
be able to enumerate all of your state
space
um so yeah I I don't have a good answer
unfortunately um
but one limit is I would say the
extrapolation capabilities of your model
like if it sees rewards from from 0 to
08 will be able to find the 081 rewards
and then the 0 82 uh that depends on
whether your model is is
capturing the the right uh factors
variation of the reward and if it's able
to also properly assign
probability to the other molecules that
have those
properties next it's an open question
thanks a lot
all right thank you very much for the
questions and thank you Manuel for the
nice
talk and we're going to stay for another
talk on the biology side of things
before we take a break and then change
uh gears towards other topics and for
the next for the next talk we have a
great Duo of students that will do a
we'll talk about molecular and protein
conformation which are related so we
have Alexandra vova and
thenine um you you have been introduced
as well okay so go ahead thank
you
uh hello everyone it's a pleasure to
present for you here today and uh yeah
we're going to talk about uh
confirmations of molecules and proteins
together with Lena and I will start with
thank you I will start with molecular
confirmations and uh I will present uh
the work which is a a product of work of
a big team of people uh and uh yeah this
is about molecular confirmation
with gonet so what is confirmation um
molecular confirmation uh and as you C
in the previous talk we are very
interested in generating molecules with
gonets and Emmanuel was talking about
generating molecular graphs and uh in in
this project we are focused on the
generating molecules in 3D so uh given
the molecular graph we want to predict
uh the 3D positions of the atoms uh
because um this uh like the shape of the
molecule is very important for its
properties and uh it in in different
drug Discovery procedures it can be uh
uh as like part of the drug Discovery
process when you generated like the 2D
graphs and after that you need to
predict molecule and 3D to measure its
its properties like how well it binds to
some Target protein for example so the
confirmation is the the term to call
this 3 shape of the molecule and uh it
can be uh described in different ways we
can describe it as 3D positions of each
atom uh and an alternative uh way to
describe it is to describe it in terms
of the internal coordinates so we can uh
tell for each Bond uh which length this
bond has and also for each pair of bonds
which planer angle they have between
them this I will call Bond lengths and
angles and apart from them we also need
U torsion torsion angles which are
angles between the planes composed by by
uh bones so by by bones so for example
here this
angle f it is the torsion angle between
This Plane of of three bonds of three
atoms and this plan of the atom so when
we change the molecule it um it rotates
uh
rotates along this Bond okay and the
interesting Insight from the chemistry
is that the most of the variance of the
confirmational space lies within the
torsion angles so Bond lengths and
angles can be predicted relatively well
using some some rule some chemical rule
based approaches uh but for torsion
angles it's uh like it's the most
challenging part in the prediction uh
confirmations and that's why in our
project we are focused on uh predicting
torion angles with the JL net and uh the
target distribution which we want to
sample from is the distribution given by
the energy of the molecule so we're
interested in predicting the most low
energy confirmations the most stable
ones uh these are the ones which are
defining the properties of of the
molecule and yeah that's why we have
this Bol SP distribution here where this
energy uh is the energy of the of the
given confirmation C of of the given
molecule and beta corresponds to reverse
temperature in physics but in our
approach we treat it as a um as a hyper
parameter uh and as I said we're using
these intrinsic coordinates where we uh
split coordinates to two things and we
um predict vet only the torsion
angles uh okay so in in our approach we
we take this um Bond lengths and angles
which I uh describe as uh L here we take
it from some chemical informatic tool
called rdkit and after that uh we train
gonet um to predict only adoran angles
and uh the the end goal of our project
is to be able to condition dlet on
different uh molecular graphs and
different Bond lengths and angles but so
far when not there yet right now we we
are training uh like we're training
individual defet for individual
molecule and uh yeah that's will be the
results which I will share with you so
the state space of the Janet uh is the
torsion angles of a given molecule and
uh we start um from some initial uh
initial positions and then we update uh
torsion angles so the actions of the
dlet uh is the updates for is is a
vector of updates for each tsion angle
and we also tried several energy
functions uh as I said we are targeting
like the the target target reward is uh
the uh the um the negative energy so to
predict the energy of the molecule we're
using several different energy Proxes
which are estimating the potential
energy of uh of the molecule and each of
them they have different Fidelity we do
not use Fidelity here in this project
but we were just interested to see how
well jlet can sample from different uh
energy functions so uh yeah the first
results which I share with you is uh
some uh some 2D experiments similar to
the ones which Salam presented yesterday
in the continuous defon paper that's
where like this project started from uh
so uh this is a similar task so we have
just two torsion angles and uh we have
some molecule which to which this tor
angles corresponds to and we can measure
energy of this molecule and here in the
first plot it is the the true reward
function um the so the First Column the
second column is the defet generated
samples uh to to be fair it is the
current dens estimation on the samples
from the jonet and the last column is
the density estimation on the samples
from from the mcmc
algorithm and uh yeah from these
experiments we can see that jonet uh can
capture quite well uh
different reward reward functions but in
the same time it doesn't really
outperform mcmc it performs quite
similarly um okay and after that we uh
decided to scale this small model and
see how it works with uh more than two
torsion angles and uh this plot is um
just uh uh just to give you a sense of
the data set we're working which we're
working with it is the uh most popular
open source data set for for um
confirmations of drug like molecules it
is Gom drug data set and uh this this
histogram is the corresponds to the
number of torsion angles in the
molecules in this data set uh so um they
lie within uh like within from zero to
250 and the most uh amount of the of the
molecules they have uh they have a
number of torion angles around uh around
eight I guess like between between five
and 10 let's say and that was the region
uh which we were targeting in our
experiments uh okay so now let me share
with you the results here um I um I show
two metrics uh which are popular in this
confirmation generation task uh in the
literature uh and it is coverage metric
and matching magic and uh they um they
obtained by comparing the samples from
uh from the model with uh some ground
through samples which are present in the
data set so we have data set in the data
set we have some confirmations we s
um with sample confirmations from the
model and then we compare them with the
data set so for the coverage is how well
our samples from the model cover the
data set and for the mention how close
they are to to each
other uh and uh here we have trionet and
we also compare it with mcmc u rdit
which is this chemical informatics to
and Rit plus Plastering which was a
recent paper which I performed many of
of the deep larning methods for uh for
Generation confirmations so it is quite
a strong
Baseline and uh we see that uh with the
small number of torsion angles jonet um
sorry just one more one more uh
important detail is that a coverance u
like sorry coverage metric is uh the
maximum value is one and closer the high
the better and for MA minimum is zero
and lower the better so we see that
jonet
outperforms for for the small amount of
torsion angles um the baselines like
mcmc Baseline and rdit and works compe
com uh competitively with rdit plus
cluster and Baseline uh but for higher
torion angles we see that all the models
struggle quite a lot and this is our
like future direction we would like to
improve the the jlet and um yeah uh and
try to scale it to m torsion angles and
the last plot which I want to show you
is this plot between of the correlation
between uh um rewards and uh probability
to sample um confirmation from the gonet
uh unfortunately we canot measure it for
the baselines it is a unique metric for
the jlet uh but it gives gives us a
sense how well jlet can actually sample
from the distribution so if this
correlation is equal to one It means
that gonet samples proportionally to
reward like exactly proportionate to
reward um so and here we see that uh for
uh even for high tortion angles it is it
is not that bad it is not fun but uh
still looks like defet is able to
capture uh something from from the
reward distribution and yeah we hope to
improve it in the future so yeah just to
conclude uh in the future we want to uh
improve results for higher amount of
torion angles and also we want to
condition dlet on the molecule such that
we do not need to train uh single jonet
for single molecule because in terms of
applications it's uh it is not
useful uh yeah and I think that's it and
I give L to
L than
you should I should questions take
questions
later okay
okay
sorry that's going to take one
minute
okay so thank you Sasha and continuing
on um on Sasha's talk now we're going to
focus on some specific kind of uh
proteins which are bu proteins which
loop on on themselves so it can be
either antibody Loops or cyclic peptides
and it's joint work with amen and with
um many people from both Mila and amen
sides so uh um in this talk we're not
going to focus on how to sample good
antibodies or good cyclic peptides
because we're not there yet but just how
to sample uh structures that loop on
themselves and that satisfy the
geometrical
constraints uh so before that what our
antibodies they are these y-shaped
proteins that are part of the immune
system um and they are determined by
many different variable regions that are
called the complementary determinant
regions and the one that We Care the
most about is the cdr3 region because
it's the one that has the most
variability and that um has the most
entropy in its structure and that is
most interesting uh in Therapeutics
applications so why antibodies um
antibodies bind to foreign substances
that are in our body and they are also
used for some very cool applications
like cancer treatment for example in IM
in
immunotherapy um and why do we care
about the Ensemble of antibod
confirmations so like Sasha already said
uh I think we like we care about it so
because it's more informative than just
having one stable
confirmation and it's also important for
molecular Dynamic simulation so these uh
systems are not rigid and they move all
the time um even when they buy to a
Target and it's important to understand
how this movement occur so to know um to
to have an information about how good it
is this antibody binding to a certain
Target um so the two project objectives
on the short term we want to use Chon
Nets to sample structures that satisfy
the geometrical constraints we're going
to see what that means right after and
in the long term what we actually care
about is to sample antibodies prop
antibody Loops proportionally to their
potential energy
surface okay so what do we mean by this
geometric Loop constraint um so this is
a 2d
um drawing but imagine that it's in 3D
and uh imagine that each XI here is an
atom or an amino
acid um and here we fix the bond lens
and the bond angles exactly like as in
in S A set and what is variable is this
torsion angles here so imagine that for
example here you have X4 that can rotate
around the axis of x3 and X2 and
similarly for X5 and for the rest and
and the thing is that these tortion
angles we cannot choose them randomly we
want to choose them such that uh the
this structure is going to form a loop
and is going and we're going to have a
specific distance between the last and
the first amino
acid um and so the question is given
fixed Bond length and bond angles which
are dist tortion angles that satisfy
these constraints and this is not
obvious uh and one idea would be to use
gonet to sample Distortion angles and uh
to use instead of of using this hard
Loop constraints we use an approximative
soft reward function to do
this um okay so now for the setting of
our gfl net um we TR we use a discrete
conditional G so in such a talk it was a
continuous one but here we're trying
with discret and we condition on the
bond length and the bond
angles uh we encode the cosine of each
torsion angle using this using gray code
so gray code is like
binary code but it's better because uh
it makes sure that uh if you have two
elements that have two rodes that have
just one bit that is different they are
like they are going to be neighbors
which is not the case for uh binary code
and yeah we use one additional bit to
determine the sign of the torsion angles
sign um so for the action space we have
for example here we have four torsion
angles and at each step we're going to
choose one bit for each torsion angle
and what value we want to assign to it
whether zero or one and in the end we
obtain the great code encodings we
convert back to the real values and we
obtain a
reward um so this is some results for um
very preliminary experiments so here we
set we set the distance between the
first and the last amino acid to be
equal to zero we it doesn't make sense
physically of course because you don't
want to have clashes between two amino
acids this is just to see if our gonet
works uh we use eight bits in our gray
code uh we use temperature anding for
the reward because why do we do this
because like in the uh optimally what we
want to do is to is to really have this
hard Loop constraint so the smaller the
temperature the
better um and we start with the high
temperature so that the G can explore at
the beginning and then starts exploiting
and also we use one of the trick that
was presented Yesterday by Jared which
is we store the best Loops in a replay
buffer and we we um we updated during
the training and with with the diversity
criteria and so this is these are the
results for different uh for different
numbers of torsion angles and we see
that this distance at the beginning uh
before training is uh higher than after
training so our Jal is learning
something but it's not it's still not as
good as we want it to be because uh
ideally we want this distance to become
zero so we're still working on on
improving this and also we can notice
that the more we increase the number of
torsion angles the harder it is to
really have a distance that is equal to
zero uh and the less diverse are our
sampled Loops so uh in other words the
more we have Toral angles the more hard
is this the the
setting and this is a plot that shows so
on the left you you can see the looks
that are sampled at the beginning of
training so this is a batch the Red Dot
represents the first amino acid and the
last dot represents the last so at the
beginning they're very far away from
each other but as we train they become
closer to each other so uh another thing
to notice here is that here we have a
lot of clashes between all of the
different um amino acids which which
doesn't make sense physically so we
should also change our reward function
to say that we want everything to like
the amino acids to be far away from each
other and that's it thank
you thank you very much can you hear
yeah thank you Lena and Alexandra uh do
we have questions from the
audience or you can come on stage no uh
yeah I hope a question for the first
presentation like in very naive
molecules also like there are many like
the invariance kind of geometric
structures right in terms of like
reflection or rotation like how did you
incorporate them or like basically you
didn't or looks not not
important yes so for now with the
experiments where we have like one jonet
for one molecule we do not need to take
care of
them okay uh so we do not need to take
care of this uh invariances because
jonet uh it takes as input just the
torsion angles and uh like outputs
updates to the torsion angles uh so yeah
we we do not like the model cannot uh it
will not change like the input will not
change if we rotate the molecule because
it's just torsion angles and so the
output also invariant to that but in the
future when we uh like when we
developing the conditional defet which
is conditioned on the graph itself we
need to uh to use uh like equivalent
neural networks as as the policy so
that's what we're working on now I see
that makes sense thank
you it's a question for you too Sasha um
I don't understand why G is better in
the graphs you showed so maybe there's
something I don't understand but in the
in both uh graphs that you showed for
the coverage and the matching um I
personally didn't see much difference so
so is there something that I that I
missed or yeah let me maybe share
again should I I don't but
I yes okay um okay so I was saying that
is better
than for example RIT which is like the
simple the simplest Baseline we have in
terms of ciance because ciance the
higher the better so the different is
this red thing and it has higher sorry
it's not ciance it's coverage coverage
yeah it it covers modes in the in the
training set in the test set better than
the than the arit for example but the
the vertical lines what because if this
is you know your um confidence LEL
something like you actually can't really
say anything
could you repe if I I don't know what
the vertical lines are but if it's a
confidence interval like it's you
actually can't say that right oh you
mean this lines this lines uh they
they're not confidence inter intervals
they are mean and Max uh uh yeah values
we get for for this experiment because
here we had just five molecules for each
number of torsion angles so we decided
that confidence intervals just do not
make much sense with such a small okay
amount of yeah of points thank
you um which mcmc algorithm did you use
as
Baseline uh the algorithm which Pablo
presented yesterday not not yesterday
like in in the first day yeah I think it
was it was HMC Pablo was here he could
confirm maybe yes
okay no it was not necess it was mcmc
yeah so that's more question for the
both of you so you did show that the
more T angles there are the more the
model struggles right from a biological
point of view you're only interested
into the functional confirmation like
not everything in a protein moves at all
time so I'm wondering like how difficult
would it be to integrate biological
information into your reward function on
top of the energy function to inform on
the number of T you look for so not
explore all the numbers like you don't
need to explore all the torsion angle
but have the re part of the reward
function exploring the right number of
torsion angle is that something that
would be
possible so I think Z who is I don't
know if he's here but he can yeah he can
he can give an answer this so so yeah
for proteins um you don't you actually
fix some torsion angles like you you
don't let all of them be variable
because otherwise it's going to be too
much so this this is already taken into
account in some experiments that has
been running for proteins so yeah
definitely because otherwise it would be
crazy but that's something you fix my
question is that like from the structure
is that something that you could
learn like to not explore all the
possible ones but at one point there are
ones that you fix and is that something
you could learn through the model you
mean to learn the fixed T angles you
mean to learn the fix tortion
angle uh that's to to only end up with
functional confirmation so not explore
all the confirmation with the best
energies but only explore the one that
also have like a biological
activity
yeah um
both like if you if you tell your model
that these tortion angles shouldn't move
then it's easier it's just like fix them
and your model is going to learn the
rest and that's what's done in practice
so that you yeah you make your problem
easier and like for some proteins you
have like very big number of torsion
angles so the more you fix the the
better and we already have problems for
scaling so for now we're starting with
this and maybe after we can add more
degrees of
freedom and in in a long term Direction
and just one last question uh so most of
the data we generate come from
crystallography that's how we get the 3D
confirmation and we get those special
coordinates uh no with Alpha fold we can
do prediction on that but most of the
time uh this is like something that's
fixed and we don't really know those
fixed um those fixed ter and goal to
start with so like how would you deal
when you're because the data I'm
guessing the data set you will be
working on are those fixed starting
confirmation
right so how do you know which one you
would need to
fix yeah so that's a good question so
your question is like we need to have an
ensemble of confirmations to know which
ones we should fix and which ones are
not this is an open question actually
for for antibodies we don't even have
the true data we don't know we don't
have data for like many different
confirmations of your antibody you can
have like the one with the low energy
but there this is also an open research
question for small molecules you do I
think like you have you have more
information on this but like for
proteins it's like alol is not good at
as giv you for for giving you
confirmation so yeah thanks a lot and
also just to add for small molecules we
we can make use of um of the energy
functions and we actually targeting at
sampling from this distribution and uh
yeah I think elen May confirm but it is
harder for the proteins because it's
harder to evaluate the energy function
itself uh yeah and in in the data set we
also we do not have like the
distribution we have just the samples
and for many applications it's important
to have samples from the distribution to
be able to imate some some integral some
measure property well and like so for
prots if you want to know the true
energy function you have to run quot
some calculations and you have like the
more you have atoms the more you have
electrons and you have to take into
account all of the interactions which is
just crazy and uh yeah it's it's it's a
an open research problem
so great thanks a lot for the discussion
I think this is going to make an amazing
uh conversation at the coffee break
right right um so it's time for the
break we're running a little bit late
but it is fine because probably we can
adjust uh later but I'm going to just
for everybody I'm going to suggest a
change so the now we we will do like a
10 minute break or so and in order to um
respect the time of the for the talks
that we gave the some of the speakers so
the next one would be me this is this is
me so I will leave it for later and then
we will start after the break with the
talk by by misu that's that's good and
then continue with uh Pink
f um Kia and then we'll finish with with
my talk because I'll be here so can just
okay enjoy the
break
now
like
yes
it's
girl
B
not
yeah
Perfect all
right let's try to go back to our places
slowly to continue the
session sorry to interrupt the
discussions coffee break chats thank you
very much right so like I said we were
making a little adjustment to the to the
program I hope you don't mind uh we're
going to
continue with a talk by Mizu nishikawa
toi uh about uh Cal Discovery Mizu is a
pH student at Mila supervised by Lauren
Shan and Danel sh and she focuses on
Active Learning Cal Discovery
uncertainty modeling yeah so yeah enjoy
it
all right
um
sorry Hi everyone uh thanks for the
intro so yeah I'm a third year PhD
student here at MAA um and I will be
talking about causal structure learning
uh using G
flets so um I'm interested in causality
and so first I will give a a short
introduction to causality and causal
structure learning um and then I will
talk about the the existing work uh
using G flet for causal structure
learning and then um our work extending
on this existing
framework so short background on
causality so as machine learning
researchers we're very used to working
with this statistical quantity um such
as py given X so uh this tells us uh
what does knowing X tell us about y so
uh for this example I just got some sort
of byari Gan distribution and if we
condition on some value of x we know
roughly what the value of y might be
because we've seen this sort of linear
pattern and so this is quite a passive
quantity and we observe something and we
try to predict something else and to
contrast we have this causal quantity py
given dox and this illustrates something
different which is how will the system
respond if I change something about it
so this has this element of actively
intervening on the system and changing X
and then observing um the outcome
why and so to really uh illustrate this
point um so I have this example here a
farmer is trying to increase uh his crop
yield and there are different uh coari
which are correlated with the cotfield
which is represented here why uh and so
uh
levels of sunlight is correlated with
the crop yeld yield so so is temperature
and so is the amount of water um but
what is causally uh something that is
going to affect the crop yield is
sunlight and water even though
temperature is is highly correlated with
the amount of sun it's not going to
causally determine your crop field yes
so perhaps if you have these extreme
temperatures it might you know uh
destroy your crop
but um in in this uh in this finite
range it's not going to um uh really
affect your crop yield and so how do we
find the causal covariates that really
affect crop yield you're going to have
to take some experiments do some
interventions for example uh keeping
temperature constant and increasing the
amount of sunlight or uh keeping those
the amount of sunlight constant and then
increasing the amount of temperature
this is the way that you can um find
these causal relations so unless we make
some assumptions on this probis
graphical model we're going to have to
do these interventions in order to find
causal
relations um so now I will talk a bit a
bit about uh causal structure learning
um and this is about finding these
causal edges in these uh ayli graphs so
usually the data is in this format we I
priority know the number of nodes uh in
the graph which we're trying to find the
edges for so we have a k columns with
end samples from the graph so we have
this uh these observations from the
graph and causal structure learning is
to uh determine these edges in the
graph and so I said previously that we
need to do these uh interventions these
experiments in order to find these
causal edges so what happens when we
just have observational data and we're
trying to do causal structure learning
then we can find not the exact graph but
we can find an equivalence class of
graphs so these are the mark of
equivalence classes for graphs of size
three nodes and uh they're separated out
and so you would with using just
observational data you would be able to
determine which of the mark of
equivalence classes the graph belongs to
but you wouldn't be able to determine
exactly which graph within uh each Mark
of equivalence class so when we are
trying to do causal structure learning
it's important that um it's important
that this uncertainty as a result of
marro equivalence classes is inbuilt
into the the design of the algorithm so
that the output can illustrate this this
uncertainty as a result of the
unidentifiability of the
graphs so how can we do this uh using
g-f Nets so first I'll will talk about
some existing work that was done by
Tristan um and so uh causal structure
Learning gflow Net using gflow Nets this
is largely a score based causal
structure learning method so what is
that uh we find a scoring function that
is able to score each graph and tell us
how likely it is that that graph uh was
the graph that generated the data and so
you score these different graphs and
then the the problem is that you need to
find uh the graph that corresponds to a
high score
and so we uh so Tristan and his
collaborators did this using G flow Nets
uh and so the score was a likelihood of
the graph uh times the prior so this was
used as the reward for the gflow net and
so after the goner is trained to
convergence you would be able to sample
proportionally to this reward which is
the unnormalized posterior so we have
this notion of uncertainty
quantification over graphs and so at the
end of the algorithm we have this
posterior distribution of graphs but the
thing that was lacking from this
algorithm was that we don't have any
information about the parent and the
relationship between the parent and
child knows the strength of the
relationship this information was lost
when this algorithm is being run because
they are marginalized out here and so we
wanted to extend on this method so that
we can find not only the posterior
distribution of grass but also the uh
strength of the relationship between the
parent and child knows since this is
very important in causal inference to
know if you manipulate one object how is
it going to affect the other Downstream
causal variables rather than whether
they are just
linked so uh this is a project that I
undertook with uh Tristan jit and um
Yoshua and
lauron and so we so the previous method
found the posterior distribution of
graphs now we want to find the joint
posterior of the graphs and these
strength of the connections in quity we
call them the mechanism so this Theta
represents the the functional uh the
parameters that parameterize these
functional uh mechanisms so how did we
do this uh so we used a a variational
inference to find this joint posterior
over graphs and parameters so um so now
um so what we did is that we POS an
approx proximate posterior over the
poster approximate posterior over the
graphs and the parameters and then we
use a gradient based approach to make
the each of the posterior close to the
true posterior as possible and now since
we're modeling two things the graphs and
the mechanism parameters we POS an
approximate posterior for both and make
this mean field
approximation so to get an idea of uh
how this was done and the steps involved
so um first we need to formulate the the
evidence um and then from there we can
compute the lower bound of the evidence
uh and so we derived uh the evidence
lower bound and so now um the this is
something that we can maximize using
gradient-based approaches and this is a
a function of the approximate posterior
of the graphs and approximate posterior
of the mechanisms and so just to remind
everyone maximizing the elbow is
equivalent to mixim minimizing the K
Divergence between the true posterior
and the approximate
posterior so focusing uh just on the
approximate posterior of the graphs for
now uh so we differentiate the evidence
low bound with respect to the
approximate posterior of graphs and then
we have a formula for the approximate
posterior that maximizes the oel and so
this is the formula you can see here at
the end and so this becomes the reward
for the gflow net and so we train the
gflow net to convergence using this
reward um and notice that in this in
this reward function um sorry yeah so we
we input the uh this this new reward
into the detail balance loss so this is
the form of the loss
function yeah and so I've been talking
about the approximate posterior over
graphs uh but but we also need to think
about the approximate posterior over the
the mechanism parameters um and so
notice that uh in this expression uh
there is a a sample the expectation is
taken over the mechanism parameters so
how the training procedure works is that
we compute uh this this reward uh for
that point in the training iteration for
the gflow net
uh using samples from the other
posterior the the approximate posterior
for the parameters so we sample those in
order to compute the reward and then we
train the G Net to convergence using uh
this reward function and then uh it's
similar with the approximate poster for
the mechanism parameters we need to
sample from the gonet in order to
calculate it so we have this alternating
procedure of training the gonet to
conversion uh updating the mechanism
parameters so so that we can calculate
the reward and then we go back to
training the gonet with with the new
reward and so yeah so there is this uh
this iterative procedure to both learn
more about the reward and more about
gonet so yeah we found that our method
works very well uh so on the on the left
we have the uh expected structural
Heming distance which Compares we have a
ground truth graph because we work with
simulat data and then we compare it to
the uh graph that we learned using G
flow Nets and our method which we call
variational based G flow net on the far
left has very good results on expected
structural hemming distance so this is a
distance between the ground truth graph
and the inferred graph and we compare
against many different um existing
basing structure learning methods and we
we see that it performs well and what
was really important to us was the
uncertainty estimates the quality of the
uncertainty estimates um of our method
and so for five node graphs we're able
to actually enumerate all of the graphs
in the the posterior and compare to the
estimated uh the posterior that we've
been able to model using the the the
dagonet um and so uh we compare uh the
mark of blanket of each node and in the
true posterior uh of graphs and then the
estimated posterior and so this graph on
the right is a sort of mean squared
error of these of the comparison of the
mark of blankets um so yeah and and we
we see that it performs well compared to
existing beian causal structure learning
methods uh so that's the end of my talk
the key takeaways are perhaps of
interest to this this group is that we
can train the gflow net whilst learning
more about the reward function using
this alternating procedure of training
the gonet to convergence updating the
reward so that it's closer to the true
reward and then going back and training
the gonet again uh and we saw that the
expected structural Heming distance is
is competitive with other methods uh
with this Cal structure learning method
it has good quality uncertainty
estimates with five no graphs uh and we
also demonstrated on real data uh and we
submitted this work to AI
stats so that's the end of my talk thank
you very
much you miss you do you we have
questions go ahead oh yeah I how about
question for the kind comparison I feel
there are many literature for like the
learning basan dark using variational
influence right sorry did you say Active
Learning oh no uh basian influence I
mean learning basan D yes or like
variational inference uh what is s main
difference like basically using G flet
to sample dog here yeah I think that the
main difference is that perhaps gonets
are able to learn some kind of
relationship between the nodes so if
there is a pattern um that arises as a
result of this something in the
structure of the data then gfets will be
able to sort of capture that data and
then to generate uh low um low
probability graphs better than maybe
some of these other methods
um let me
think not sure do you have anything to
add just
or so one of the one of the advantage of
G for this particular problem of causal
Discovery is that the the objects that
you're creating are very structured so
that's very good for gonets as we saw
the past few days also the the key thing
is that so it's a discrete object so if
you want to apply varal inference to
disc to sample discrete things usually
it's a little bit tricky but here it's
even worse because we have this ecity
constraint coming from the caal graph
and this aity constraint is very makes
things very very hard to model as a
using varal inference the only way you
can do it is just through some
continuous relaxations and so what you
end up at the end with the with varal
inference is getting something where is
not guaranteed to sample that are iclic
whereas in the G using jonet we can
actually incorporate these these
constraints directly in the structure of
how we are transitioning from one graph
to another and so we're guaranteed at
the end that will
obtain actual as
graphs thank you very much let's thank
again all right we're going to continue
with the talk by Dina who is
online
hopefully hi U can you hear
me can we check if we have dinai on the
zoom
call
hello uh can you hear
me in the meantime um yeah well I will
introduce
d uh while we find name dinga is a pH
student in in yenjo and Aron Corville
group and his research is at the
intersection of uh probabalistic
inference and scientific
discovery and he's contributed a lot as
well to the gonet
ecosystem and if we're lucky we will
haveen here
yeah hello dinai can you hear us yeah I
can hear you can you hear me we can hear
you well as well so yeah take it away
okay thank you Alex for the introduction
uh I also wonder can everyone see my
share
screen yeah looks good okay um how about
now even better thank you okay okay
thank you very
much uh hi everyone so um I'm going to
talk about an like an application of how
to
uh how to use gonet to solve this kind
of um graph combinatorial optimization
problems um which is a very important
topic in many um computer science
related applications so this work uh has
been received by newps 2023 at the
spotlight paper and it's a joint um
collaboration with many other um people
in in our
lab so um
let's
begin so uh um I think most of the
attendance have earn a lot about basics
of gonets in uh like previous days
lectures so I will just give a very
brief idea about um like Jet and not go
into very very
details so um as you um as we already
know like jet is a is a like U turning
the generation process of um discrete
compositional um data objectives into a
sequential decision making thing
so for example we can think about how to
construct a graph by um by designing a
set of uh generation rules and turning
and using a little bit abstraction to
turning the left sides generation rules
into the right hand sides uh like the
the flow Network in the right hand side
and try to learn these different flow
values inside this um Mion
process so um the idea of G Nets is to
sample um sample some objects with
probability proportional to some um
given reward function or to put it
another way the target of gonet is to do
sampling um with given unnormalized
density
function so um this is the capital x is
the space of this um complete objects
that we want to sample or complete
Solutions so sometimes in the jet
literature we also uh use terminating
States um to cause these complete
Solutions which marks at the square in
this
sides and um for gonets we can imagine
we have a initial agents as the szo
states and these agents um will go
through a series of incomplete solution
which is also referred to as um
intermedia states in the uh G
language and these agents might go
through a series of um there of a
sequential like decision making steps
and at some points these agents um can
choose to like take a terminating action
so here t means terminating and
ultimately um it end ups with some
complete solution or in or terminating
States so what we are going to learn Is
this different um water like flow
function in this figure and learning
signal is the um given reward function
where we can query uh this function with
some terminating States and uh we got
the reward value in
return so um this equation is like means
that um on the right hand side of this
equation is the reward value of some um
objects X and on the left hand side of
this equation it's like the um is a
summation of all the flows that goes
into X and we want the
um the summation of all the flow all the
trajectory flow values is just equal to
the uniz probability which is the reward
value of the of the object
X and
um similar to reinforcement learning and
Jet is also like a a set of algorithms
that's um wants to learn a policy inside
a market decision process so what's the
difference um because we know like in in
many um previous combinatory
optimization um um works there are also
many people uh proposed to use um
reinforcement learning algorithms to
solve combinatorial optimization um
problems so we can demonstrate their
difference with a simple
example so here is a very simple Market
decision process with two terminal stat
with equal rewards so if we want to do
reinforcement learning in this mdp or
Max NGP reinforcement learning then it
will do sampling in the trajectory level
and every trajectory will have equal
probability which gives the probability
of generating a to be a probability of
2/3 uh however if we want to use
beautifulness this means that we want
want to directly do sampling on the
terminating state level since there are
only two terminating States in this Mark
decision process and they have equal
rewards so naturally we want to um
generating A or B with 50/50 and like
equal
probability so as we can see even if we
haven't take a look at this algorithm
details we know that uh there are
difference in in the goals between G and
reinforcement learning and this
difference will lead to different uh
algorithm family in their um specific
implementations so for example um the um
the the algorithms that will be used in
our work called detail balance um is
something like this so we want to
amortize Global training to local
Transitions and to achieve this we um
need to parameterize two policy one is
for one is the forward policy as shown
in the blue and one is the backward
policy as shown in the
yellow and the detail balance condition
uh as have been um demonstrated in
yesterday's talk is like we want to
establish some balance between the
forward flow and the backward flow and
we can um parametrize the flow functions
and the policies to um minimize the the
discrepancy between the left hand side
and right hand right hand
side okay so um after some basic
introduction about gonets we can have a
look at the um one of the one of the
problems that we are going to solve in
the combinatorial
context so um this problems called
maximum independent sets is a very um
classical setup so imagine we are given
an undirected graph G like like this so
these two are the same graph structure
so what an independent set means so an
independent set is a set of vertices X
so where every pair of vertices are not
connected or to put it in another way
they are not
neighbors so um the red noes in the left
figure um itself forms an independent
set and on the right figures again all
the right sorry all the red nodes also
forms an independent set because every
pair of the red nodes are not
connected and the M problems which is
the maximum independent set problems is
just we want to find the largest
independent set X inside this given
graph G
okay so this is optimization problems
but under the jet framework we can um
first frame this optimization problems
as um a new Pro prob inference problems
so here is how we um do
this so in the example of Maximum
independent sets we can set this um
reward function the reward of x x is the
set of notes and G is the given graph
configuration so we can set this rewards
to be something related to the number of
vertices in
X so instead of maximize this rewards we
can train AET to sample proportional to
this temperatur um tempered
rewards so um how to um so before we use
a dness we need to design a mark
comption process to solve this problem
and notice that our gonet is actually a
conditional gonet um conditioning on the
graph structure
G so in this figure we're presenting um
a designing of the market process
so um this is an like industra of the
intermediate states where we can see
that the state space is basically we
want to assign value either zero or one
or unspecified value for each nodes and
here V is the set of all
nodes so here the black means one and
white means zero and green means
unspecified and for terminating States
everything is specified so every note is
either white or black and for
intermediate states there could be green
State uh green
notes so what is an action here each
action which is uh showed by a little
Hammer here it means that we turn an
unspecified nodes into specifies as the
black
nodes and after um this action we are
meaning that we want to um put these
black nodes into our independent sets so
because every pair in this um in this
independent sets is cannot be connected
so naturally all the neighbors of the
children black noes cannot be um
included in the independent sets so in
this transition um transition function
we design in the way that all the
neighbors of the black notes are
automatically set to White which means
it is excluded from this independent
sets and the reward value or the energy
is designed to be related to be directly
related to the number of black noes in
this
state so here is our design of um mdp
and as you can see it can this kind of
design can induce a a implicitly flow
Network in this very large lat space and
each termination noes on the right hand
sides which is the end of some
trajectories it's like a set of nodes uh
and it's also independent so both this
example and this example um in these
examples all the black noes are not
connected to each
other so um what about our training
algorithms so we can um use our previous
mentioned different kind of different
algorithms but uh in our work we find
that there are also some specifications
we need to make so one thing that's
because our we want to tackle really
large scale problems and we found that
if we want to put a like INB we we need
to put a trajectory of States into the
GPU and if the scale of the problems is
really large maybe the uh one GPU is not
enough
so sorry for interrupting um I just
wanted to tell you if if you could wrap
up in a couple of minutes because we're
already running time I'm going to wrap
up sorry for interrupting go
ahead yeah so um we can break this uh
gatri Level Training into two pieces by
using DB and put a replay buffer to
further uh increase
efficiency and also we can use the
forward looking technique proposed in
our previous SML work to increase the um
uh credit assignment
efficiency and here's a figure of
compation study in our
work and um at the results We compare
our work against classical methods and
other um either reinforcement learning
based or supervisor learning based deep
learning methods for doing uh
combinatorial optimization problems on
different uh small large or even larger
scale of um graphs and then we also
compare um like our in the efficiency or
the performance and we show some
advantage of our methods
and Beyond this independent set problems
we also provide some uh design of mdp
for other like maximum click or minimum
dominating set problems and we also do
uh different scales of problems in these
different like maximum click mean
dominance sets or maximum cards problems
um and um if you feel interested prefer
to P have a look at our
publication okay yeah thank you for the
list
and this is the end of the
presentation thank you very much s
perhaps one quick
question if there is
any no questions in the room well then
we'll we'll leave it here thank you very
much s for for your presentation yeah
also thank you for the host have a good
rest of the day and we're going to
continue Now with uh Kia who you have
met the previous two days and he's going
to to speak about gonet for language
applications okay um sorry I need to
connect to the zoom
call so we
will
and now I have to go back to
this no there's an
[Music]
echo sorry we can't continue like this
yes
is it really
no sounds
well
you system
issue we're back no we're not back yes
we are now we are back thank
you right um big models trained on a lot
of unstructured
information so for language like GPT and
LMA and T5 but also for other kinds of
data like DNA and other biological
sequences which are maybe equally
important for real
applications and we want to use these
models for whatever we want to do in the
world and that requires extracting the
useful information that these models
have learned so how do we do that well
the typical approach to that is to use
uh very clever prompts to get the model
to say what say the answer to what you
want to know sometimes by making it talk
to itself and kind of reason and then
finally produce the answer um but that
that is all great but models are very
sensitive to prompts and it's hard to
come up with the right one and get it to
give the information you want um on the
other hand very simple sampling problems
are actually
intractable for example we have a
distribution over sequences given by the
model think of it as distribution of
sentences or some short things um even
sampling from a tempered version of that
distribution so proportional to the
model likelihood raised to a power is
not
tractable so you can't get the
distribution of the next token under
this tempered
distribution now other other
interactable problems include sampling
text of a fixed length so conditioned on
the token after that being end of text
sampling text that's supposed to end
with a given phrase or is supposed to
contain some word or another or not
contain other words so all of these
problems are intractable to solve
exactly and so people use urtic methods
to to help for example people instead of
doing tempered s sampling they temper
the Distribution on the level of
individual token conditional
distributions so raising the
conditionals of the next word to a power
this only approximately solved this
problem sampling text with constraints
or with a given length can be solved you
can find approximately modes using beam
search but this isn't guaranteed to
actually find the best continuation or
to give you a diversity of
them so the idea of what we did in this
work is to think of a language model as
a policy of a g flet where each action
is appending a word to the end of the
sequence of tokens and then fine-tune
this language model to sample from a
desired
distribution so let me give the example
of infilling
so imagine we have a prefix like um an
past event the cat was hungry and we
have a suffix like now the cat is Sleepy
is I me they're sleepy all the time but
just for the sake of example and we want
to know what phrase is likely to go in
between for example maybe the cat ate a
mouse or complained until she was given
some food we can think of this as a
problem of inferring a latent variable
and we as usual in machine learning use
Zed to denote a lat variable so Z goes
between X and
Y so the latent variable here is the
text in between that we want to infill
to
infer so the posterior over the latent
variable Zed is given by Bas rule which
is written here and particular it's
proportional to the Joint likelihood of
x z y in that order which is something
we can compute with a language model
because we can score it left to right so
given X and Y inferring Zed is an
intractable inference problem on the
other hand we have something as
proportional
to so this already makes us think of jet
because that's that's an algorithm that
can help us sample from an un normalized
distribution by sequential decision-
making but before gonet I just want to
say that various other NLP or language
model reasoning problems can be uh can
be cast in the same framework for
example a common Paradigm of reasoning
with language models is called a Chain
of Thought recently proposed and the
idea here on the simple example of
classifying if a text is subjective or
objective is instead of asking the model
to directly say subjective or objective
is to first ask it to produce a
reasoning change like oh this review is
talking about the personal opinion of
the reviewer and after that say
subjective or objective and this is just
a very simple example this has been
applied to much more complicated NLP
problems so um usually the model is
induced to create the reasoning chain
using in context learning so by giving
demonstrations another case is tool use
for example you may want to evaluate an
arithmetic expression and the model has
access to a tool like a calculator which
can do operations on two operands at a
time and it has to generate the sequence
of tool applications until eventually
coming up with a final
answer and various other forms of
constraint generation also can be
formulated as intractable inference like
sampling and all the ones I described
before so what do we do we can fine-tune
the language model which X to Z and Z to
Y as a gonet so using jonet objectives
to sample from this um posterior
distribution so if we're infilling
sampling Zed given X and Y we give the
language model a reward which is the
language model the base language model's
probability of x z y in that
order um and this policy is just a fine
tun inv verion of that same language
model that allows us to allows the model
to at initialization still generate
reasonable text reasonable text that
continues X um now we can condition that
policy on both X and Y or just on X and
in the reasoning for Chain of Thought
situation we condition it just an X
because there's expected to be only one
output y for every X and we expect it to
be generated by first sampling Zed and
then
y
so once this model has been trained to
sample Z condition on X we can use it to
generate reasoning change Zed for new
unseen in training context X and thus
we've learned to perform this kind of
reasoning generation of Zed in a
demonstration free way so we didn't
fine-tune to maximize likelihood of
example said and we didn't give examples
in context that we can use at inference
time the model has been forced to
explore to discover what Z make the
right y likely so we learn to generate
the
explanations by by self self trining by
exploration RL
style now once this um policy or jlet
has been trained it can be used to
sample reasoning chains for new X and
then we can generate the answers why
using those reasoning chain set just as
an example here's a little book review
uh this book is one of ranken's greatest
achievements this is a famous crime
writer measured by International sales
now we can sample different the model
might sample different set for the sex
for example the review has greatest
which suest this personal opinion this
is emotional language and that said is
likely to make y equals subjective
likely another one is the review quotes
factual information the international
sales and that's likely to make
objective likely so we can perform this
sort of basin model averaging by taking
many samples from the Basin posterior
over said that we've learned to sample
and model the uncertainty in The Final
Answer um as an upgrade to this we can
also do variational Em which you heard
about on Monday where we also update the
language model itself we find tun it to
predict the answer from X the question
and the reasoning
chain show you a couple of results U on
the subjectivity classification task
which I've been showing as an example do
doing this uh it leads to much better
performance with a small number of
training samples than uh usual methods
of supervised fine-tuning and in context
learning while on the problem of
arithmetic with tool use like the little
addition problems I was showing before
the same thing happens with especially
with improvements over standard RL
algorithms like Po which aim to model a
single mode over Z with notable
improvements in outof distribution
performance when we train on three or
four oper ends and then
test
five um beyond the setting of
infilling infilling conditioning only on
X for reasoning we also applied this to
other inference problems with language
for instance here we do infilling on a
data set of stories in this data set
there are stories of five sentences and
you see the first three and the last one
and you to guess the fourth
sentence so here's a story David is
worried about his health because he eat
too much fast food and then at the end
he starts to feel better so what
happened in between and all the all the
stories
are of this of this sort to teach uh
social skills to kindergarteners is
probably the main aim of this data
set so the correct answer is he stopped
going to burger places and started
vegetarian diet but of course there are
many results you can that can go here if
you find him with a reinforcement
learning algorithm um you get answers
like this like he still didn't stop his
unhealthy habits which doesn't really
make sense in this context um when we
find tune within shiet objective we get
the three infilling candidates which you
see in the bottom row all of which are
possible
here so we we show that we get a high
diversity of infilling results and
also candidates which are on average
more similar to the ground truth one
that's shown here in
green so in this case we condition on
both X the past context and why the
future
context another situation where we can
apply this is for just continuation so I
mentioned earlier the problem of
sampling from a tempered distribution
over the next sentence which is
generally
attractable and when we fine-tune a
language model as a gonet with reward
which is the base model likelihood
raised to a power we get both higher
likelihood sentences and more diverse
sentences at the same time than if we
apply the usual tricks of tempering um
token by token or doing beam search with
diversifying tricks that are sometimes
used in that used in that
situation um but of course this approach
has its
limitations so the first uh maybe the
hardest to overcome is that all of this
assumes that the base language model is
good enough so if the based language
model assigns a high likelihood to
things that it shouldn't then nothing we
can do about
that um for example you sometimes see
things like this where it see where 1us
9 minus 8 it tries to do minus 8 and
then plus eight because for some reason
it thinks that things like minus a plus
a equals Zer are likely and for small
models this incorrect reasoning chain
actually has a higher likelihood than
the correct one and this is a limitation
of the base language model itself and we
don't address that with the fine tuning
all we address is intractable
marginalization or an intractable
sampling another one is that so far
we've been able only to experiment with
language models that aren't huge only
six billion
parameters tiny by tiny by most
standards um and even then we have to
use a lot of tricks to enable fine
tuning um
but the models that store the most
knowledge and have the most
um promise for what we can extract from
them are much larger than
that um then in addition because we have
to search for the right explanations
although sometimes we can initialize a
replay buffer with them the whole
procedure is much slower and less
efficient than supervised fine tuning so
we do this very slow search and slow
fine tuning to an exploration to find
the good latent variables as opposed to
the much simpler procedure of just
maximizing likelihood of something
you're
given and finally so far we've only s
focused on task specific uh models task
specific jets for generating reasoning
chains for a particular classification
data set or infilling on particular data
set of stories and so on but it would be
much more interesting to create a kind
of um cross task or Universal reasoning
model maybe conditioned on instructions
that would be able to sample the
posterior over latent reasoning chains
given the question but this is all for
future work
um now to conclude I want to give a
outlook on what's possible to extend
this direction of
thinking so the first the first
Direction I have in mind is using a
gonet fine-tuning approach for
reinforcement learning with human
feedback or rather for settings where
feedback is typically applied so the
idea in rhf is that you train a proxy
model which gives you a score for a text
and is trained on human annotations and
then you use that proxy model as a as a
reward to fine-tune a pretrained
language
model now the proxy model is imperfect
so sometimes it gives a high score to
something that actually as a human would
not find good now we can always of
course address that by getting new
annotations but this there's a high cost
to always asking for new annotations and
there's always the problem of over
optimization where if the language model
fits the reward too well
it'll find the places where the reward
is huge which are usually not the places
that the human would find the the
samples that the human would find best
on the other hand sampling from in
proportion to a distribution given by
the proxy model would be less prone to
this kind of over
optimization and this is why I think
that gonet style fine tuning instead of
RL style fine tuning can help with a
problem of language model
misalignment and then second I'm very
interested in generalizing this to more
structured latent variables than just
sequences of tokens um for other domains
for example program synthesis and proof
synthesis where the mathematical
formalism associated with this thinks of
um deriving a theorem from the premises
as a sequence of sequence of operations
which which transform a state gradually
from premises to
conclusion gener generating the sequence
of derivation steps or rewriting
rewriting rules conditioned on the
premises and the conclusion can be seen
as a posterior inference problem just
like the ones I talked about
before um I will end here here is the
paper and an archive and we have code
available for for all the experiments at
this GitHub
page hello thank you for the great talk
I had one one quick question in the
slide where you had the trained Q policy
and the network yes the next one um the
next one have you so like a lot of
prompts have shown to be very
transferable so I was wondering if you
had um tested on having the language
model in Q policy be different from the
language model in PLM so for instance
say you find tune a smaller language
model with f g flet um but then you test
if the prompts or the Z sample Z still
works on larger ones for instance oh
yeah that's a good question so we tried
Sometimes using two different models one
for sampling the reasoning chain and one
for actually giving the reward and the
language mod like gives the reward
should probably be the same one that
computes answer from x and z because
that's the distribution you want to
sample from in the end um so one case
where this is important is for the
arithmetic with tool use setting because
you need a very big model to do
arithmetic well but you only need a
small one to figure out what the
sequence of operations is and copy it
and feed it to
calculator so you guys tested this and
this works I don't think this but the
paper but we definitely tested that okay
thank you and maybe Mo has something to
add
okay all
right any more
questions okay thank you you
yeah all right so I'm next we're running
a little
bit late so I will try to be
brief
don't see
it uh just the whole screen
for the tab
instead IO it
that that's fine
no all
right okay so I'm going to quickly talk
about uh Crystal gonets which is a Chet
version to sample Crystal structures and
this is work with uh a bunch of people
actually you can see the
there so maybe first of all uh I guess
not everybody in the audience will will
know what uh I will be talking about if
I say crystal structures so these are
materials and if you go to the
Wikipedia uh to search for crystals you
will see that Crystal or crystalline
solids Crystal structures are solid
materials whose
constituents um that can be actually
atoms or molecules depending ions uh but
the key property of crystals is that
they are arranged in a in in a highly
ordered fashion and also that they
repeat in all in all directions so these
are periodic structures with uh with a
lot of uh Symmetry and structures you
know the amount of symmetry can can
change but the idea is that they repeat
in all
directions uh for the purpose of of this
talk and the the the scope of this work
is about inorganic crystals there's also
molecular crystals where the the
constituents are are molecules and not
just single
atoms um it is important to Define uh
the the concept of the unit cell which
is the
smallest uh set of atoms in this case
that will be repeated right so we
can fully Define the the crystal
structure if we Define the uh the
arrangement of the atoms in this unit
cell so if you look on the on the right
that that would be a unit cell but the
actual material will extend in all three
directions of the of the 3D Space by
repeating that unit unit cell multip
times and why do we care about this uh
well they are actually like Crystal
structures are actually in a lot of
different things that we
use uh in you know in our daily lives
and in industrial applications and me in
particular I I care about the climate
crisis and if you go to the ipcc report
to the latest ipcc report you will see
that you know it's
discovering new Crystal structures is
not going to be the the solution for for
everything but there's actually a
multiple ways in which uh the discovery
of new new materials can uh reduce
greenhouse gas emissions improve the
efficiency of for example energy storage
renewable energy storage
Etc I will not get into the details in
the interest of time but you can see the
slides later if you're interested for
some of the of these numbers they are
not not super small
however there is a big challenge when it
comes to discovering new materials which
is first of all there's very very little
data compared to the to the vastness of
the search space so there is about
200,000 known inorganic materials and
some people say that there might be like
10 to the 180 possible stable
materials just the amount of conceivable
materials is just infinite because
there's a like a
continuous values in their you know in
the
representation and then from this
Infinite Space of conceivable materials
very few of them will be stable and very
very few of them of those stable
materials would actually be interesting
so this is a very complicated problem
and after three days attending this
worksh you might already think oh this
okay this could be something we can
tackle with gonets and this is what we
Tred to give an idea what people have
been doing in this domain this is just a
a figure from a from a paper that has
actually U made a this paper made an
important contribution to the field
using uh diffusion models and I won't
get into the details this is just to
illustrate that this was a a bit
complicated system with multiple
branches different optimization modules
and it gets uh decent
results um but of course there's a lot
of a lot more work to do and you know
they for the evaluation of the of the
model they have to check for example if
the geometry of the materials the model
samples is is respected if the
constraints are
satisfied if the charge uh of the
crystal is neutral things like this uh
pointing at the need of uh to me at the
need of incorporating more of these uh
constraints in the generation
process so the way we fa this problem
was by taking a bit of inspiration from
uh theoretical crystallography and this
I I need to thank uh Yasmin who is
sitting here for for teaching me all all
this um so if you if you if you go to to
the you know the literature on crystals
Crystal structures you see that uh the
people in in this field w't Define the
materials as you know let's take all the
3D coordinates of all the of all the
atoms which is the type of
representation used by by the previous
model I I mentioned but instead they use
all the information that describes the
geometry of the of the structure so for
example if you go to the to the
Wikipedia again actually has good good
stuff um you can see here in this table
I won't give you the det I won't discuss
all the details but what this table
tells us essentially is that you can
classify all the you know all the many
structures that crystals can form you
can classify them in in different
classes there's a lot of uh you know
topologies is is uh big so you you have
Crystal families Crystal systems ltis
systems there's the space groups that
describes the the Symmetry operations
that that can be applied to a structure
and these space groups can be divided
into into subclasses and the sub classes
into other classes Etc so there's really
a lot of literature that goes back
um many years like 100 something years
on the both in geometry and
crystallography and the idea is to to
leverage all this domain knowledge
into um the generation process of the
gnet so if there is one bit of like one
takeaway I would like you to take from
from from this presentation is that with
the gfet framework it is actually
relatively straight forward to
incorporate a lot of domain knowledge
into the into the
problem
so more specifically if we want to to
define the or describe the structure of
a crystal we can do it by apart from the
composition so which elements and which
atoms are in the
composition um it is important to to
determine what is the the space group
and there's 230 space groups in three in
three dimensions that's all there's
infinite infinitely many uh structures
in uh in you know in a conceivable
structures but all of them could be
classified into one of these
230 groups space groups and
then all of them in 3D will have six
parameters that determine the the shape
the the size of the of this cell and the
and the orientation so ABC are the the
lengths of each of the dimensions of the
three dimensions and Alpha Beta gamma
are the the angles of the of the of the
planes all right so I've mentioned it
already but the advantages I see of of
the G for approach is that um we can
incorporate this these constraints as I
will mention in the next uh slide and
that this representation with even even
without including all the the atom
positions of each of the components of
the crystal there's been literature
before that shows us that this is
actually predictive of of interesting
properties so it's a much lower
dimensional representation but still
predictive
of uh the things we want we care about
and one hypothesis here is that perhaps
this searching in this lower dimensional
space might be more efficient than
searching in the in the huge space of uh
atom
coordinates all right so this is already
a bit of the description of the of the
specific algorithm we we have proposed
so we have divided the generation of
Crystal structures in three three three
main components or sub spes one is the
composition that hopefully will be easy
to to to understand it's just selecting
which elements and how many atoms of
each element will be in the in this uh
in this Crystal
okay that's a discrete
Subspace and then once the composition
has been selected we select the the
space Group which like I said before is
a a choice between one of the
230 possible options in 3D and in order
to incorporate more more structure more
uh patterns in in and in this selection
of the space group we divide we Leverage
The you know the domain knowledge of the
of theoretical crystallography to
decompose the space group into into
several steps and in particular here we
we let the differ select the crystal
system the ltis system and the point
symmetry I don't have time to Define
each of the each of these categories but
the point is that we can we can sub
divide the the generation
process and finally once we have both
the composition and the and the space
group we can we can have different
sample laage parameters this ABC Alpha
Beta gamma and these are
continuous uh parameters so as you can
see we are mixing here already discrete
and continuous sub spaces which again it
is something that we can do more or less
easily with gfet a lot of coding but
it's possible uh and this is really not
not easy to do with other generative
methods
unfortunately and I would like to to
spend a a moment talking about
constraints like I said this is for me
the main takeaway of of this
so if we do this naively we we have
already well we have already
Incorporated domain knowledge by by this
de composition of the space if we do
nothing else it's going to be a a hard
problem to search in this in this huge
space however we can introduce a lot of
we can introduce a lot more domain
knowledge so some examples are the
following one is that we know that the
composition has to have neutral charge
for it to be to be stable in nature so
we can do this simply by preventing the
generation process in the giet to to
continue if the charge is not neutral so
this is one hard constraint we introduce
then the space Group which is again like
the the Symmetry operations that are
valid in
the uh in a in a
structure is highly connected to the
composition in other words not every
composition is compatible with every
space group and not every space group
will be compatible with the composition
so this is also something we enforce in
the generation process and this is of
course a bit convoluted when it comes to
coding it but it's just possible and we
and it took us some time but we just did
it and the g framework allows us to do
this uh easy
uh I mentioned the hierarchical
structure of the space group and then
finally once we have selected the space
group this imposes hard constraints on
the on the latis parameters for example
there is a number of space groups which
correspond which belong to the to the
cubic Crystal system or ltis system or
Crystal familiar actually all coincide
so the crystal will be a cube and then
if we have a cube then we don't we don't
we shouldn't select different a b c
alpab beta gamma because alpha beta and
gamma are going the three of them going
to be equal to 90° and then aals b
equals c so this is something we can
directly enforce as well in the in the
Generation all right I hope that makes
sense I will just show one slide with
with results so we can take a validation
set from from one of the crystals
databases and we plot um the formation
energy which is a is the energy of the
crystal uh it's a bit of a proxy for the
stability so we want to sample crystals
with low formation energy so this is
what we use as the reward
function by training a separate model
for uh for predicting this this
formation energy so if we plot the
distribution of this formation energy in
the validation set this is what we get
and we see that the majority has
negative formation energy which means
good now if we build a crystal alet and
we sample from it without training it we
get the following we get a distribution
that is shifted to the to the right that
means it's a lot worse these are random
random samples random crystals with
positive formation energy which means
completely
unstable now after we train the giet to
sample proportionally to the to the
formation energy we get a distribution
which has been shifted towards the
left getting a a majority of of of
crystals with low formation energy or
negative formation energy as predicted
by by the model we had trained this
doesn't mean that we have discovered
here the the materials that will
revolutionize climate change this is
because this is just IL silico and and
there will be many things that that need
to be improved but this is a promising
result telling us that it is possible to
to tackle this this very challenging
problem with a method like this this
took like 12 hours of training in on a
CPU for the gonet so we're working on
this and hoping to to make more
contributions in the future so just to
conclude I mentioned that discovering
new Crystal structures with good
properties can help us mitigate the
climate crisis that this is a very
challenging problem because there's
infinitely many structures and only a
few of them are stable and only a few of
the stable materials will have nice
properties and with gonet we can easily
incorporate uh
domain constraints like you know by
collaborating with with uh with the
experts and we train G foret with this
constraints and we got promising results
that we can sample diverse high-scoring
samples with the hard constraints
guaranteed it will just mention that the
the the code is open source you can find
on line and I would like to acknowledge
a big team of people both at Mila and
Beyond who have contributed Al together
to this project thank you very
much it's a bit late probably you're
tired so maybe let's take the break if
you have questions come to me and I'll
be happy to to discuss and you know you
you will also find many other the people
involved you cannot see anymore but
there are more people in the room so we
are happy to to answer your
questions
um just it's worded to 12 should we
continue at
o'l
Manuel cannot see you it's good all
right
thank
you all right thank you everybody I hope
you enjoyed the
break we are going to
continue the well uh I'll see but I
think it's going to be a very
interesting and at this is an important
topic which is the uh the evaluation of
gonets uh it's something we haven't
covered yet and it's very important if
you if you get to to use the difference
okay is it working is not working is
this better than other things so we're
going to have a Manu who has a lot of
experience on this to tell us about how
to evaluate different methods
thanks um yeah so I struggle a lot
making these slides because there's
simultaneously a lot of things to take
talk about but
also um it's not something that I guess
we're doing right so
happy to get questions and thoughts from
everyone um so there's lots of ways to
kind of look at your G flet is it
training correctly is learning the right
things uh I'll try to go over a bunch
and uh hopefully do that relatively fast
so we can all go to
lunch um so of course you know gonets
are designed to fit some uh reward
function energy function so of course
you can kind of just measure that um in
some cases you can actually compute
exactly what the probability of some
point is given you parameters uh but in
the general case you can't really
um nonetheless when you're developing
your code base or trying a new thing you
probably definitely want to like do the
minimal setup like if you're generating
a graph generate two nodes then you can
measure this exactly and and there's
several metrics you can use then so one
is obviously the correlation between the
predicted reward uh the predicted
probability and the actual reward um and
then
typical um divergences on probabilities
so the two classic we've been using is
just Divergence and then this L1
distance between the log probabilities
it's Al pretty interesting because it
also tells you like on the on the lower
tale of things how your model is is
performing uh I've seen some paper
reporting things like total variation
sort um and it's it's fairly easy to
code
um depends on of course what exactly
you're doing but typically you kind of
want to generate the for for a single
point uh generated a graph of ancestors
that it has and then kind of ask your
model what's the policy uh and then for
those uh policies at every states of all
the ancestors get the log probabilities
of the actions that go from state to
state and then you kind of just do
dynamic programming and and recover uh
things by adding
together log adding things together
until you reach the uh zero State at
zero the very important thing of course
here is to go in the topological order
otherwise you're going to have a bad
time and and then at the end the the L
probity of' computed
zero and not at a zero sorry the final
state is is the right one um of course
when you're training something you're
going to stare at a loss it's avoidable
um typically you get kind of this
expected curve of like at the beginning
the model is just kind of finding things
out and then pretty rapidly plos and
keeps decaying um fairly standard site
but of course that's not always the case
um and loss can be misleading because
you are always generating your own data
um for local loss like uh flow matching
or DB L theil balance loss uh that
actually can be kind of arbitrarily
misleading because you're bootstrapping
off of the model's own estimates uh
there can be a real a really big
mismatch between the kind of losses that
you see and how well the model is
actually performing uh this is something
that has been studied in RL uh but that
I'm convinced transfers to gonets um and
then even for trajectory losses that
don't have this locality problem um
they're going to be cover dependent and
what do I mean by that um as your state
distribution changes as the model learns
um what your training loss tells you is
only how good your model is on your kind
of training data or training
distribution uh it sometimes happen that
like as the model is discovering new
things you not only get spikes but like
uh kind of entire swings of the loss
that go back up
um so an interesting thing about G of
course is that the flows encode some
pretty interesting information um in
particular the the terminal flows right
so the flow between like the some State
and the terminating State U should
converge to the ward um so this is a
plot I think yes from the original jant
paper we're looking at the edge flow of
the stop action basically um and it kind
of correlates somewhat well um with the
reward but it's never perfect and
another way to to get this if you're
doing detail balance uh even subb where
you have the the flow par Flow State
flow parameterization is to just
multiply these two things together um
you should get similar results if your
model is learning
well um you might want to stare at the
intermediate flows as well of your
model um particular because because the
St state is a dag um
typically although this
is some caveats but typically as you go
down the trajectory and get further away
from a zero the flow should get smaller
because there's just like less
accessible stuff um it's not always true
but most cases it's a useful diagnostic
if you look at the predicted flow along
a trajectory and it varies wildly your
model might not be learning very well um
flows can also be interesting right
recall that uh Zed is the sum of all
rewards in your mdp in theory um so
something like interesting way to debug
your code is to give reward one
everywhere and to see if the model is
capturing accurately the total size of
the state
space um then of course if you're doing
trajectory losses uh you may want to
check if those are locally consistent
right just recalling here the detail
balance but this also works for for flow
matching um and and vice versa if you're
training a model with detail balance you
may want to check that the trajectory
balance loss is still
consistent
um in a lot of uh cases uh looking at
the loget value is actually somewhat
interesting
um typically you'd want all your models
to convert the same value uh because
they're all Theory learning same problem
uh
and if there not there might be some
issues um and somewhat surprisingly
actually I did this spot just for this
presentation uh I was surprised by the
regularity of like the relationship
between the average reward that uh the
model is producing and the predicted log
value um but you know
somewhat consistent with what I've
experienced um so yeah something also
useful to look at uh another big you
know thing selling point that we're
trying to give with gonet is that um the
the are a diverse model that can sample
from lots of places so of course you're
going to want to measure that um most
modalities have some notion of distance
or similarity between things you should
definitely always be looking at that um
you know for molecules we
have Notions from chemistry but for
Strings you have edit distance uh these
kinds of things um it's really important
to sometimes debug your model and kind
of make sure that they're not collapsing
to some very small set of modes um or
that um they're not on the contrary kind
of refusing to uh learn High reward
things because there's like too many
things that it wants to to look at
um it's
typically uh what you'll see is actually
that initially maybe the model will will
learn to sample the diverse things but
actually as training carries on um and
the model gets better at sampling as say
hward things of course you're going to
see that the the diversity decreases or
the similarity increases um because
typically there's less High reward
objects than low reward objects they'll
tend to be somewhat more
similar um and then another uh typical w
been looking at diversity is counting
modes
um sometimes
expensive uh because you end up doing
lots of uh actually it should be in s
you end up doing lots of parway things
um and then some caveat is that uh you
need to be very careful about how you
kind of Define what a mode is it's not
always trivial uh many domains and
typically that involves some kind of
choice of threshold
um the the typical way we've been
reporting that is either kind of the
historical measure or at convergence
measure right so the historical one is
you just look at all the samples in
order that your model has sampled during
training um kind of stare at that uh the
conversion version is you train your
model you throw away all the data you
had um sample new Mini batch of n
examples and then look at the number of
modes in that um and typically you'll
have these two thresholds um what is the
kind of minimal reward that's relevant
to consider something to be a mode uh
and then what's the kind of similarity
threshold between two things to be
considered different enough uh to be to
different
modes um and I'll note here that uh
there's a very closely related metric
that you'll see reported in many gonet
papers which is is what we call diverse
STK
um so you're searching a space and
typically you want to kind of report the
best things you found um
but uh you also want to include in that
some notion of how diverse your agent
was um and the way we've been doing it
is by saying okay we're gonna look at
all the modes and only pick the kind of
argmax locally within that mode uh and
Report those those K AR Maxes uh average
reward as the the diverse topk scaler
and the way to do that is is fairly
straightforward um you just kind of sort
the X's um by the reward the
sending um and then you apply the same
logic of thresholding the reward and
similarity and Report the average reward
of of those particular
objects um this has some issues um so
this is somewhat cartoon plot but uh
happens in real life so here I'm I'm
kind of showing on the left what
happens uh I forgot to label my acces
we're going to
make but um so here the the y axis is
the number of modes and the x-axis is
the training progress so here the agent
is just visiting more and more things
and as it is visiting more things uh it
is finding more modes so here I'm
showing what happens to two different
models
um if I change the similarity threshold
on the left and you'll notice that as
the similarity threshold becomes smaller
there's just less new modes because it
becomes way harder you have to go way
further in a state space to count
something as new um and you'll also
notice that depending on that choice the
order between the the blue curve here
and the orange curve might actually swap
um so you know what this suggests is
that the the blue model is like more
diverse um in the orange model because
it's able to kind of get things that are
really far away
um but uh finds kind of less of these
things in an absolute number U similarly
if you kind of have a reward between
zero and one in this example um
depending on where you set the threshold
uh you might find that your ranking
between models differs right so for
example here um once again the
the the blue model is a bit more diverse
right so if you set the reward threshold
relatively low um it has found lots of
things with rewards
point2 more than the orange model um but
if you set the the reward thres really
high and you really look at only the
very few best examples uh because the
the orange model is a bit more greedy
then for those hward objects it might
have found more of them so something to
be mindful of when looking at these
things I mentioned diverse. k
um I guess I'm repeating myself a bit
but this is just kind of plots from from
papers
um typically you'd want to report like
multiple case uh I think that's uh
pretty good practice because again that
might change the ranking that might
change like the the information that
you're presenting
um and you might also want to report
both the kind of historical view like as
training progresses we require more data
here's how this progresses but also once
you've changed the model here's how good
it
is
um yeah something I've actually started
doing somewhat recently is uh to monitor
the entropy of the policy uh it can be a
pretty interesting indicator
um sometimes things go wrong and the
entropy is fine and sometimes things go
wrong and the entropy is not fine and it
can be a somewhat specific symptom uh
particular this is like n equals one in
some sense but like too much creating
clipping too big a learning rate your
model is learning too fast and it's
becoming really really
opinionated um in either PF or PB
um and pb1 is actually very
interesting uh I think it's been
discussed many times but I think it it
Bears repeating that like the choice of
the backward policy kind of influences
the choice of where the flow is
allocated in in your flow Network um and
there's a few experiments in scattered
left and right in paper suggesting that
it does have a pretty important
influence on how fast and how well your
model is going to learn um and there's a
delicate balance between some kind of
Maximum
entropy uh flow that pushes the model to
kind of allocate flow everywhere and be
very curious um at the expense of of it
being harder to learn and something
that's maybe lower entropy where the
flows are more focused
um uh which you know you can use that to
infuse some interesting priors
actually yeah it's they'll C rid of that
I think we don't fully understand very
well yet um so I you know Jets seem to
be pretty robust in general and and
diverse and you'll rarely see that the
forward policy in that sense collapses
but it do happen uh
especially uh I think you've heard about
conditional model and temperature
conditional models a bunch um one
changing temperature to be too low one
common kind of side effect is that
suddenly your model says oh all the
reward is there and everything has zero
reward um so I'm just going to become
super greedy um and this is due to like
weird learning Dynamics uh and does
happen is sometimes hard to kind of deal
with um and of course if you work with
extremely uh sparse domains where
exploration is hard or the reward is
kind of poorly normalized then you can
also get uh these collapse problems um
and this is when I think going back back
to Jared's talk you really want to pay
attention to exploration methods and and
try a lot of
things
um something that I guess we don't talk
about l in jonet is test sets um you
probably want to be using a test set but
then it's not obvious what to do with it
and it's not obvious how to create it um
if all you're given is a reward uh and
then some kind of mdp uh
um it's not obvious how you should be
choosing uh your kind of test set and
that will depend on your problem um so
the the kind of easiest is to sample
States uniformly and call that your test
set um and by the way when I say test
Set
uh it is the the best practice of course
is to kind of check whenever you're
training on something that it's not in
test set and if so kind of multiply the
loss by zero
but that can be non-trivial in a lot of
domains in graphs for example you have
to do some kind of uh W test to make
sure that the graphs are different that
can be expensive uh but it might be
worth it especially if
you're uh training your last Model that
you're going to report in the paper uh
you probably want to be doing
that yes so sampling uniformly is kind
of easy but in a hard enough problem
where the rewards are sparse enough
you'll have a very very
uninteresting
um test set
um one line that's actually missing here
is you sample uniformally a lot and then
you bin your rewards bin your states by
reward and you pick equal numbers of
States from each bin and then you kind
of have a uniform is distribution over
rewards at least of these states the
problem if you do that is that typically
you will have to kind of repeat hward
States because you won't have found lots
of
them
um yeah uh another classic way to do
this is you train a bunch of model and
you take their samples basically to form
a new test set for the future um that's
usually more interesting because you end
up with more diverse higher quality
higher reward data uh but then you might
miss the the the mode collapse or kind
of lack of exploration that your models
are doing
um and in some cases uh you do have
actually a test set right so in a lot of
molecular domains let's say you're
training your reward uh on some data set
of predictions your reward predictor
might have some test Set uh you're
totally allowed to also use that test
set for your G model to see how it
performs there um and in particular in
in molecular domains for example um
there's some pretty interesting Notions
of uh let's say scaffold splitting where
you're carefully crafting modes that are
left out in your test set and they make
for a very interesting out of
distribution uh domain um so okay you
have a test set what do you do with it
um you probably want to measure the fit
somewhat so earlier I was discussing
well I think my first slide if you have
some model you can measure P of X
exactly
that's very interesting you should
definitely be doing that on your test
set but that's only possible if the
number of ancestors of a particular
point is reasonable um if it's not well
you might
wait years to kind of compute BX exactly
what you can do instead is approximate
it um but then the approximations tend
to be really hard uh and also
computationally intensive uh so for the
the the classical approximation of
course is like important sampling so
here what you would do is take your X's
from test Set uh sample trajectories
backward from let's say your backward
policy or any policy really um and then
measure the probability that your
forward policy assigns to that
trajectory do a bunch of these
measurements to take a Monte Carlo
sample of that that expectation and
report that as
pfx
um the problem of course is that here
you're dividing by some potentially
extremely small number so you might have
a bad numerical time um there are bounds
of course that do this on a log scale so
it's more numerically stable um but in
my experience they're rarely very
accurate um so I think it's still kind
of an open problem of at scale how do we
measure the galets kind of really learn
the distribution
after
um yes and then of course um
there's there's other things you can
measure
U measuring the loss on your test set is
not a bad idea actually um typically uh
I think in my experience it's been a
good sign of
either end of learning or collapse or
like uh model is unable to learn more
when the
the kind of training loss plateaus at
some particular value and and then the
that same loss as the trajectory balance
applied on your test set also plate but
much higher values um seems a good
indicator of your training is done um of
course you can apply the other losses as
was mentioning earlier to see if they're
consistent can look at things like
terminal flows uh and then of course
depending on your application you
probably want to be using all the
metrics from the domain um in images and
and and chemistry there's fret scores
that are pretty valuable uh and should
probably be uh really taken into
account um think I have one more slide
oh
yeah I've heard this myth that there are
drunk gonets out there
um and I thought why not try to explore
this just for this talk so this is a
very typical picture if you're mode
counting um gilet will kind of just keep
going keep discovering new things if
your state space is large enough and
compute is limited enough
um and so the question is like you know
this this top line here has discovered
lots of modes um that's a bit suspicious
is it still capable of sampling the
modes that uh you saw earlier um so you
know as you find forget modes I tried
some experiments I don't know if it's
worth going into the details given the
time and the lunch but basically uh open
question I think is going to depend on
the domain in the application um what
I'm showing here on the left plot is
kind of uh if you take the example
sample here uh this time during training
progress uh what is the kind of odds
that it's going to be resample in the
future seems pretty stable but with some
variance um similarly here I you know
take some X here and I ask okay when
when is the next time that the x is
Revisited seems to be somewhat
consistent and stable although for a
fair proportion of them so what I'm
plotting in Orange here they're just
simply never Revisited so maybe a bit
suspicious uh I think it's worth
investigating worth keeping in mind if
your uh problem is complex enough so I
will stop here theck questions and thank
you
that was great thank you Manuel very
instructive um do we have questions from
the
audience uh so it's not a question it's
a comment about using the test set and
uh a measure of fit so something that we
found uh especially when when it comes
to using important sampling to estimate
this PF of the trajectory um something
that we we found useful is to bootstrap
this value using beam search because
what we want is to find trajectories
that like trajectories that have a very
high PF that are the ones that are going
to contribute the most to the metric so
bootstrapping with that like let's say
1,000 trajectories that have the highest
like it's still your using beam search
that's when you have a trained PB yeah
yeah once once you have trained
everything and is it have you checked
the entropy of that
PB I think well I I haven't done
anything but one thing I want to do is
like if you minimize the entropy of PB
that might be a better metric because
then yeah
absolutely I
agree reporting at the end
once true okay
thanks I have one question myself if
there's no other questions I was
intrigued by
the uh at the beginning of your
presentation you had this metric or
potential metric of the you know the if
s the flow of S Prime should be smaller
than the flow of uh of s I had never
thought of that I've never computed this
so how it makes a lot of sense I um how
do you actually use this if you have
used it and what what you know is it
useful for what things yeah I think I
used it more of as a sanity check as I'm
developing something new I don't know if
it's really like worth reporting in a
paper but um it made me found some weird
bugs so worth considering is it
something that is satisfied in general
it improves over training yeah I'm very
curious we can talk uh improves over
training yes yeah yes satisfied in
general I don't know I
think uh not necessarily does it go to
did you do it over over
a over the training trajectories over
training trajectories
yeah I haven't explored this pry deeply
but I found this to be useful when
debugging yeah cool I definitely learned
something any other questions before we
go for
lunch I see your brain saying lunch
lunch lunch okay let's do it thank you
Emanuel you continue at 2
yeah y
okay
hello check check
check check
check all right so I hope you all had a
great
lunch we are going to
restart in a couple of
minutes yeah you can get your coffee or
tea or water and get
comfortable
good oh I need to join
[Music]
the
what
it's it's all
right but me perhaps from your side the
the recording thing that that needs to
be
there
yeah I'm gonna wait like a minute or so
to give people time to to come back to
the T and we'll start in a
moment
okay I
think it's a good time to get started
welcome back for the last uh afternoon
of the
workshop I hope you had a chance this
morning to see uh some of the projects
we have been working on here at Mila
using gonets the idea when we prepared
this this day was to give you the chance
to to see different things uh I guess
not everything you saw was super
relevant to you but the hope is that at
least you saw something that is
sufficiently close to to what you are
interested in and give you some
inspiration help
you uh
motivates get some motivation to perhaps
use
gonet and
then in in this session the goal is to
actually see how to use it and I
thought that a good way to do that would
be to to actually you know do the kind
of thing you would have to do if you
decide to to go home and then give it a
try which is you know get a get some
code and and and code your own your own
thing uh it's a little bit of a a
challenge it's a bit wild I have never
done this so bear with me I hope it goes
well but the idea is to do a you know to
code a
gate environment we'll see what an
environment is from scratch or almost
from scratch and and do it
together all
right so the I thought you know we could
do like materials or molecules or
something like that but the chances are
that would be uh far from the domain of
of many of you so I thought that
something um more intuitive
and and and you know easy to code easy
to understand for all of us would be a
something inspired by the Scrabble game
that probably most people know if not
doesn't matter I will explain quickly so
this Scrabble is this game where you
have like tiles with with letters and
you usually play with multiple players
and you have to cross letters on a board
and so on here we are not Crossing words
the the idea is simply to form English
words with up to seven letters which is
the number of letters you usually get on
on your on your scrubble
thingy and then we could come up with a
with a reward like a score function
which would be essentially the the
scrable score right so the sum of the of
the scores in each in each
letter um it's a
pretty easy looking environment but
actually if you think of it it's a very
very hard task okay so and I think think
it's more or less well suited for for
giet for the following reasons I'll try
not to extend myself too much here
otherwise I won't have time to to call
the whole thing but yeah if you think a
little bit of the of the um you know the
the difficulty of the task the number of
combinations you can make would be like
26 to the seven with up to seven letters
26 to the 7even plus 26 to the 6 Plus 26
to the five and so on so that's about 10
to the power of
10 that's a big number it's not as big
as you know like the materials or
molecules that we have discussed in the
morning but it's it's it's pretty
big
um I downloaded a vocabulary of English
words that actually Kia recommended so
thanks Kia for that and if I remove all
the letters of the words that have more
than seven letters I end up with a bit
less than 100,000 words and this is very
very inclusive like it has very weird
words that you know don't make much
sense but you know they are there so why
I didn't spend time like triming that so
similar task to what we have in for
example talked about crystals or
molecules like vast
space and only a small size of it is
relevant and only a small size of this
relevant like words in the vocabulary
will have high score okay so in this
regard it's a similar it's a similar
environment you know some words for
example just to illust for illustration
purposes um so free here the word free I
don't know if you can see it but it has
like F four points R1 E1 E1 so it's like
five six seven points and the other one
hope the better rewards seven eight nine
okay cool we'll see if the word is not
in the dictionary we'll just give it a
zero in the in the vocabulary
all right so a little bit of of what the
this environment would look
like we're going to do it so you've seen
this many times so I stole it from
Emanuel shamelessly like many other
people yeah in general the gonet graph
is a is a direct graph the way we're
going to do it today is actually not a
not a dag it's going to be just a tree
because it will be Auto
regressive the the states
space will be all the possible
combinations of tiles from zero which is
the The Source State we start from zero
up to seven letters and we're going to
add one by one so that would be our our
action space the actions are going to be
which
letter I'm going to to add to my
sequence and we're going to do it in a
way that is like sampling with
replacement kind of thing you know you
can repeat letters so the most simple
thing and there will be a from the
letters you see here there will be a
special action which will be stop so it
is possible to construct words with less
than than seven letters does that make
sense to everybody otherwise uh please
ask questions because nothing would make
sense anymore all good perfect so with a
little bit of code what we can do is uh
represent letters usually when we won't
use the the the strings when working
with text to make our our life a little
bit easier so what I what I'm going to
do here is to just give an index to each
of the 26 uh letters in in English so
for example if our dictionary if our not
our dictionary like our letter sets is
just a e i l m and
O we have you know the indices from one
to six and then we'll have a special
token the underscore just arbitrary for
to part to part the the words and we'll
give it index
zero could be different this is just a
choice I've
made so if we want to represent the word
Mila um it would just be the list of
indices of uh of of each of the letters
53 41 hopefully I didn't make a mistake
and it's consistent with what I wrote
above and the actions
actually yeah um the actions would just
be like Tes in the in the code I will
use with the index of the letter single
element tle with the index of the
letter okay and there will be a special
action which we call EOS end of sequence
for the stop action and that's it we
don't need
anymore does that make sense as well
perfect
so I'm going to use this uh G
implementation you have the link
there um just 30 second advertisement of
this is that a key design principle in
in this code is that it's actually easy
to extend to code new environments uh
and it already includes a bunch of them
like hyper grid hyper Cube peros Tes
crystals molecules
DNA both discrete continuous
hybrid and it's based on uh it used is
Hydra configuration for those who are
familiar with this and it supports 1db
to you know to see the results and
Etc and it's been used by a bunch of of
papers and developed by uh now a good
number of of people at Mila many of of
them here in in this
room um so what we're going to do relies
a lot on on this implementation of giet
obviously so we're going to abstract
away from a lot of the complexity to to
make the Gite agent and so on but the is
if you if you want to do something for
for yourselves you would start with with
just writing a different
environment and a different environment
itself is you can think of it as a you
know if it's if are familiar with
reinforcement learning it would be the
the set of things action space that
allows you to make to move in this in
this graph implicit graph of the gonet
and the implementation has has like a
parent based class of the environment
and then if we create a new one because
we will inherit in Python terms from
from this base environment the methods
that we need to to change are just a a
few of them so we'll have to to write an
init method okay here we will Define the
attributes of the environment what is
the end of sequence action what is the
source State and a few other things then
we have
to to write a method that defines the
action space this is for for discrete
environments but this is just a list of
all the possible actions we've mentioned
that
before and we need a step method given
an action update the the current state
of the of the
environment there's another method that
retrieves the the parents of a of a
state and the actions from those parents
towards the the
state there's a method with a long name
that I should uh rename something
shorter but currently get mask invalid
actions forward it determines even state
it determines the invalid action invalid
actions from uh from the state this will
be key
for uh adding the constraints I talked
in the in the talk uh I give this
morning in the little presentation about
Crystal
gonets and then there's a bunch of um
helper method meths that allows us to
convert into different formats of the of
the states proxy to policy to something
human readable and
back that's
it any
questions no then let's
code my very briefly my objectives for
this will be the following so
demonstrate that it's not so hard and
timec consuming to to get started with
different for for a new problem you know
given of course the availability of of
the different libraries we've been
building at Mila and then for this
session uh if you want to code along
you're very welcome but I've designed it
in a way that you know you can just
watch see what what what I'm going to do
uh try and try to understand rather than
code yourself and maybe Miss some of the
details so and uh that said like feel
free to ask any questions that would be
the the key like if something doesn't
make sense you know or just raise your
hand or or go to mic and and ask the
focus for me will be on on what we have
to do and why we do it rather than the
specific implementation because the how
you know there's different ways of of
coding
things all right
okay
so the first thing if you if you use
this like this
repository the first thing you would do
would be to go to that and clone it
right so I'm going to do it even like
that from
scratch almost from
scratch so I don't know if this is big
enough probably
not so I will just clone
this call it
gfn life okay why
not
all
right go to gfm live and here as
well this is just a shell with t-o if
it's not big enough let me
know
um here we have a bunch of things but
what we care about is the directory
where we put the environments and I
have um there would be M
here and I have
created oh wait we need
to prepar a branch with some stuff so
it's almost from scratch so I will just
check out this this Branch gfn minus
Workshop minus
demo and now we should have have a
scrubble so we go what I've done here is
like the skeleton of what we need to to
code I already have some some dock
strings to help us the Imports this
simple list of like double of with the
letters um and then the class Imports
gonet M the parent class and then I have
the the methods that we need to to code
with the you know already with the
arguments and the the dog string but
they they're going to be empty or almost
empty we just wrote a pass there okay so
we're GNA go together this thing I would
you know cheat a little bit like printed
the solution but this is for you to make
it less
uh less uh wild all right so um first
thing I think it would make sense to to
code the the init method I we have I've
already written the arguments here
letters max length and P token so we
could just add them here letters um it's
going to be a an iterable with the
tokens and we're going to make it known
by
default then we have max length in case
we want to change this will be an
integer and by default is seven like in
the game so we SK
there and the pading token which can be
uh this should be string because the
letters are string
so and we will use zero but could be
could be anything as
well all right that's the arguments now
we have
to just you know initialize the
initialize the main attributes
so it would be
self letters equal to the
letters
uh max
length will be max
length there's a lot of boring Parts but
this is the you know this is a drawback
of uh of doing this life but we'll do it
together if there's something that that
doesn't make sense or you know you would
do differently like let me
know um I would do something like if
letters is known by the way just a
question but is everybody more or less
comfortable with with
python any anybody is like no first time
I'm watching I'm looking at python code
okay perfect I should have asked this
before but so if letters is known then
we'll make Sol letters equal to what the
thing that was uh you know up
here um this
thing
and else we take the you know we take
the attribute the the argument from the
from the
method and then we need to define a
couple of other things that will be
useful later uh one thing will be
the you know the the the number we will
use for the end of sequence action
um what can just
be minus one just to make it different
to to the to the
letters and we will also
need an index for the padding token
which will be
zero this arbitrary can be
anything okay then we're going to
create um a couple of dictionaries that
will be useful to to convert between the
the token which is string the letter and
and the index so the first one will
be like index to
token yeah and this will be a
dictionary and because the letter start
from one so it will be the index Plus
[Music]
One will be equal to the token and then
we trade over the
tokens we get the index and the token
for in the
letters but we
should enumerate to get the index looks
good think so that will be just the the
dictionary with the with the letters we
will add now
the
the uh the padding
token so we have already self P
idx equal to self token we're just
adding the the
token all right and now
the inverse which will be from token
to
index uh this would be we can
itate yeah should be easy
idx
or index
token that should give us the key and
the value of the other dictionary to
build the inverse and that's
it make sense so far all right now
something that is important in the
environments and we you know in this
Library we do it in the in the init
method is to define the The Source
state so we on WE it's just self.
source and because we're going to start
from an
empty um empty State like an empty
sequence of of letters it will just be
the index of the
padding uh just the ma length
okay so state is going to be the like a
a list of seven indices
integers that would be
self and there's just one more thing
which is the end of sequence
action which we said it will be tles so
self yes
idx that's
it I think we're done with the need
we've initialized the the attributes and
then couple of dictionaries that will be
useful for for the rest of the of the of
the class and then Define the Define the
source and Define the Define the end of
sequence
action
questions no so now get action space it
was one of
the yeah
turn off the lights
yes yeah I
guess better okay perfect uh so one of
the methods we had after it is get
action space so let's do that one this
is just a list with all the actions as
simple as simple as that so a list with
all the actions will just
be
um so we have the dictionary we need to
iterate about
that so will be a
tole and it will be the
indices so it's token to
index we pass the
token we
iterate over the
tokens in Charing the
letters this is
wrong that looks
better so that's that's a list with the
indices of the letter letters with the
doues with the indices of the letters
and we will add the one for the end of
sequence
action this is just
that actually we don't we don't
need that should be it I
believe and yeah we just return this
thing I think that's correct we'll see
later if it's correct I'm not I'm you
know I'm looking at my notes but I
cannot do like a like a matching thing
yeah you want to do it on the microphone
so we can hear you thank
you just just a question about your init
method in the P token what did you put
why did you put zero instead of the
underscore as in your slides you put the
underscore when there was a letter
like oh you're right yeah yeah you're
right just because I think initially I
had done it with yeah we can do that
that's fine yeah thank you that's just
our
choice okay now we have the the step
method this receives sorry this receives
an
action
um and we just need to apply this action
to to the state and by the way we
haven't do done it explicitly but the
environment will have a self do state so
there in
the in the base environment you that's
where you would see these things what is
available and what not of course this is
a bit more complex but there is
a a reset method that is called at the
beginning and this defines
the the state at the beginning it just
at the beginning it just copies the the
source
okay so we need to update the the state
given the given the the the action as an
argument I kept this three lines or four
lines of code that are generic for for
all environments so this is just you
would never have to to change this in
discrete environments unless you do
weird things sometimes you know you can
do weird things but in general this will
be like just like that and now What's
um
what we need is me this I'm going to
check my notes just to not make mistakes
because going to be a bit tied with time
I
guess
um so after these
lines uh essentially if we go beyond
past these lines it means that the the
action will be performed otherwise uh do
step will be uh
false and then it returns so if it's if
we if we pass that point the first thing
is
to um to say that valid will be
true because we have to by the way we
have to return it's it's written here
but we have the this method will return
self State the updated State the action
that was passed and whether it's valid
or not this is useful for for some
things and one thing that the step
method does is
incrementing this attribute of the of
the environment which is
uh the number of actions that have been
performed in the trajectory so we also
need to to do
that and
now we can have two types of actions one
is if if it's the end of
sequence in that case it's it will be
easy if
[Music]
action
is the end of sequence sequence actions
action we're going to do something which
is there's another special so I'm
explaining things on the F but there's a
special uh another special attribute of
the classes which is we call it here
done this is true if the trajectory is
finished and false otherwise so if if
the action is end of sequence we're just
going to set this to to true that's
it and then we have to return state
action and
valid so we don't need to modify the the
state because it's just the same the
only thing that changes is done the
action as it
came and valid which is
true now if it is
not um if it is not this the end of
sequence action we need to update the
the
state this we're going to do so we will
have to what we need what we need to do
here is get the
position the first position in the list
that doesn't have a a padding Index
right and update that one with the index
of the of the
action I could do it directly here but I
because it's something I use a couple of
times I created this helper method get
sequence length is just the the
effective sequence you know the number
of letters that have been added to the
sequence um so I'm going to code this
quickly it's just a couple of
lines so this
one it can have two cases one
is um if there is still padding so I
will just check at the the last item in
the list if this is equal to the pading
index the last item in
the if it's equal to the Ping
index we can return we just need to get
the index of
the okay I'll write it and then
explain I think that's
fine yeah so this will give me now I'm
I'm taking the index in the list of
the
first item that has the self.
idx does that make
sense
simple if it happens you know if this if
is is not uh it's not true then we just
need to return the length of the that
means that the the sequence is
full and we just need to return the
length of the of the state that's
it okay we go back to the step and now
that now that we have the this helper
method it's easy to to update because we
know that state now we can call get
sequence
length this will will be updating the
first index with the pading and this
will be equal
[Music]
to the item in the in the action I think
that's
it
yeah that would be
it return
everything I no wait we need to self
State yeah we have to do it on the on
the attribute of the class we just
return
that action and
valid
close this
thing all right I don't know if it was a
bit quick maybe the opposite is
everybody
following yeah
questions what happens if this get
sequence length returns you the the
length of the full state so what if the
state is already full yeah we could we
could catch that but the thing is it
will be caught already by this piece of
code Sorry by this one if that if if the
state is full then the only possible
action will be the end of
sequence and it will never reach this
this part we could be super uh careful
about it and catch that possibility but
because we rely on other things
working um it's
safe yeah if if get sequence length is
equal to the length of the of the list
the only possible action will be EOS and
it will return here that's why I'm not
doing it explicitly but you know you
could do it it's just more code but yeah
you're right it's something at the
beginning when I was coding this and the
code the repository was less uh robust I
had a lot of these things to make sure
then now it's in state worth things are
robust and also you have to make sure to
code things properly
yeah that's a good point okay the next
method is there any other questions
about about step yeah oh yeah yeah
sorry I didn't understand why the
actions are two P with a single element
what what's the point in having this or
not just the
integer just because in other in other
environments the the actions can be more
complex oh so they have to be two P
because of the types is right because
you know just because in the repository
it was decided that that they're
represented by topples and the reason
for being topples and they can't have
multiple multiple elements is just
because for
example
uh imagine we code this differently this
scrubble thing and instead of just Auto
regressively adding tokens the action
could be the token and the position in
the sequence then we need we need two
numbers and that would be a tle with two
numbers okay great so this gives us the
flexibility of uh of doing more
complicated things okay great thanks
yeah good
question well good so you see so far
nothing this is not rocket science this
just a little bit of simple
python um so now we have get
parents um we have to get the parent of
the of the state that is passed as a as
an argument or it can also be you know
there's a lot of pieces of code that is
if it is known then the self state is
taken you know I'm skipping this details
but this is handled by by this couple of
lines get state if it state is known it
takes self State that's
it so this method sometimes can be a
little complicated because you have to
make sure to catch all the possible
parents of a of the
state um you could skip this actually if
you just train with trajectory balance
because you don't need to get the
parents um but we're going to code it
just for
the for the fun of
it see if I find it to my CH
she um
yeah so you you said for trajectory
balance you don't need to code it but
don't you need it also also for
Pb when
you oh you're right you're right no it's
for I did something wrong it's for
continuous environments that we don't
code this thing but maybe for trajectory
balance no probably you do need it yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah I was I take that
back thank You Tristan for fact
checking live fact checking okay so
there's different cases for the parents
that we're going to catch one is if if
the trajectory is done so that's
probably the easiest if the TR if the
trajectory is done then the only parents
the only parent is the the state itself
and and this method returns a list of
parents and a list of actions okay so I
will just do this one easily this will
return not self state but State because
we have we take it from
there
and and the action will be just the
index sorry the
your action so that's that's the easiest
case if it's done just one parent which
is the state itself and the only
possible action the the action of that
transition is end of sequence we have
another special case which is if
the if the state is the source state so
let's catch
that we have a
special method in the in the parent
class which is
equal uh actually I mean for here we can
I'll do it like that I don't know I
could just
do okay that would do the trick but
there's this
method yeah anyway I think that's fine
if the if if the state is the The Source
State what would be the what we have to
return if the state is the
source what are the parents of the s
State
anybody nothing empty lists right okay
and now the the more fun
part um this is a very simple
environment so we have a sequence with
say uh you know I think maybe you can
use the slides
we have a you know that that sequence
Mila the parent of that is just five
three four and then zeros right so we
just need to we just need to code
this and we can use again this method
that uh that we coded before to get the
that the position of
the of the first padding SE um letter
token so we can call this
post last
letter and
then we subtract one this will give us
the position of the of the last
letter and then the
parent so first we copy the state don't
we don't want to change that python
things and the
parent we need to modify that of the
last
letter uh we need to put the Ping
index I'm getting it
right okay on the
action would be
just the
state the index of the state that we've
just removed in the in the parent
this just needs needs to be a tole to
make things work but that would be it
and because there's just one parent on
one action from that
parent um we just
return
that and that's
it again this is probably one of the
methods that is
most complicated or more you know
requires thinking about how to
efficiently uh get all the parents and
all the actions but in this case it's
really
easy okay we're almost
there 17 minutes okay I'll try to do it
there is this um there's this method get
mask inv valid actions
forward um could even skip this I'm not
sure if things would work but it's I
recommend to do it but this is really
what enables the the code the gonet
framework to to impose these constraints
that I was talking about
before here for an initial
implementation close this little
thing we will just do some something
pretty basic which
is uh that all all the actions are valid
always except is the if the if the
sequence is full it it's at maximum
length but just uh the only valid action
would be EOS so this is what the the
question before Sasha was saying oh what
if so if we implement it here then we're
good we're just hard constraining
the uh the uh the
transitions see if I can find my cheat
sheet okay again I'll try to speed up a
little bit we have a couple of cases so
if it is
done we just
okay maybe I need to say that this is a
list with Boolean values and it's a
Boolean value true or false for each for
each action in the action space okay so
if it is done all the actions are
invalid so we just need to return
true and we have something which
is action space
them this is the dimensionality of the
action space but we could also take
length you know it's just the length of
the action sped that we've CED
before
so that's
it um now we need to catch the
case where we're not done but the the
sequence is
full that is the case if state if the
last
item
is uh
[Music]
uh
equal no different to S
idx this is the
case going to initialize no I'm going to
do this differently
sorry if it is equal everything is fine
all actions are valid meaning are not
invalid so that means false this is a
bit confusing but it is this way because
normally you cannot be 100% sure that an
action is valid and that's why instead
of talking about valid actions we talk
about invalid actions you can be sure
that some actions are invalid and that's
that's the
reason okay that would be
it
um got lost my cheat
sheet uh but yeah otherwise if this is
not so we pass that point
then can
do through all
invalid
no space them and
then we need to
take
self action space
index the index of the end of sequence
action and we make this one
false I think that's right I'm not I
don't find my the
part but I think that would
do turn that
okay did that make sense did a little
bit quickly maybe but yeah what matters
is again like the what and the why so we
just need to constraint the actions and
if we can do a lot more things here we
are not going to do it now but um but
this is the place where you would put
your constraints maybe it's a good time
to mention so something we could do
better here so it's like incorporate
domain knowledge and what domain
knowledge would we have here so it's
something I haven't coded yet but would
like to do so I've just did this like
last week but you know we're dealing
with English words so maybe we can do
stuff like oh there in English there's
no words with the the same letter
repeating three times but we could just
prevent this if there's a letter that
that is twice in the sequence we just
remove that from the action space or we
say oh in English we don't have the
combination of I don't know X H maybe
there's something I don't know maybe
yeah I don't know you can do these sort
of things and hard coding them here in
this in this method and that will reduce
the the search space that will trim the
the the the graph right it will
accelerate the the
training uh okay that would be it in
terms of you know the core methods of
the G
movements actions environment the only
thing that remains is this boring
conversions that will help you convert
your state that now it's indices of a
list just a list with indices into
something that's good for a proxy model
something that's good for the policy
model so the the the neuron Network that
that that deals with
the with the you know with the policy
forward and backward and then these
methods I have to make the the sequences
readable in this case it would be
obvious that would be like just the
letters so because we don't have a lot
of time I will go quickly but this is
rather
boring maybe I
just kind of copy paste visually what I
have
here
uh yeah what I did
for for state to proxy so proxy is the
the the thing in the Repository that
computes Rewards or the thing that will
be the input to our reward so in that
case because we have a list of
indices and normally the proxies work
with torch we can so so far we haven't
done any torch here now we're GNA we're
going to convert this to to torch but
that's it it's just because the proxy
model I did was is in torch but it could
also deal with with the
lists um I have a helper
actually I'll just do it like this torch
dot
tensor
States okay I think that would do just
converting to
torch yeah this receives a list of lists
States is a list of list it converts it
converts an entire
batch now for policy uh you know
uh the by default thing to do would be
to to make like a one hot en coding of
the
letters so that I
will so we can
actually uh copy
paste this
one
now we have the states in
torch
[Music]
and
we I'm just going to do the one H en
coding of this using this byy
torch method that I don't know by heart
so I would
just so you give it the states and then
you give it
the number of items that you can have
and then you reshape
this
into the right
shape and make it
float and that's it I
believe okay looking good then
readable
state to
readable is just converting the
uh the um the the indices into the
letters so I have some I have a couple
of this is for just one state I coded
these methods that I didn't remove to
not because this is not very interesting
this is not different specific so I
decided to keep it but this pad I have a
method to pad and unpad the the
sequences you see it's just one line so
I will just use
that state to
readable then would
be State equals we have
to unpad the
thing and then
return this is a bit boring
sorry so convert to string and we're
going to use this Di iary that we made
at the beginning convert the index to
token we pass the
index and
we we're going to space to that and then
iterate
over the indices in the
state boom and then we
remove the space on the
last
item that would do
and this is the same thing but for you
know the
the the other way
around sorry I'm just going to do
it kind of
quickly readable is
[Music]
stream
if it's empty it will return just the
source State I've made a mistake
somewhere because this is
complaining oh
yeah
okay
sorry going to
pad here the other way around token to
index
the
token and iterate over tokens
in the readable that we split by
spaces that's not space that is
space all right close the
parenthesis think it looks
fine okay I think we're
done let's see
um okay so we're done with the with
environment hopefully I haven't made any
any mistakes now what
remains just because of this Hydra
configuration thing is we need to we
need to Simply create a a configuration
file for
the for this environment I've done that
already I'm going to show you
how um how simple this is so it's config
M and I have created Scrabble yaml it's
a yaml file it is just this it tells it
take the base configuration and it tells
Hydra where to find the the class that's
it ID SCB you know the rest is just n
nothing nothing important so that's all
you need and we can go to the to a shell
and run this
thing my fingers okay so there is a main
um it's a main file with all the stuff
that initializes things and we just
specify which environment we want to run
like this and we also have to specify
the proxy I'm going to test it just with
the uniform proxy which is the same same
reward for all like one for all
states and we also have to pass this
user because we're many people using it
yeah it's
technicality let let's
see no didn't
work and letters what is
this okay I'm going to try to debug this
quickly if not I will show you the I
will do it with the with the
solution
oh I forgot
to yeah I just forgot to add one thing
here
yeah yeah it's training cool okay so it
works more or less you see the lows
going down but in man told you before
that the loss is not super
meaningful but seems to go down well
doesn't matter um then I just have two
more minutes but I would like to show
you a couple of things this is just with
the uniform
reward is not very interesting I told
you before about the more interesting uh
scrubble thing that would
be in G flet no sorry I'm going to close
this that's the proxy right and proxies
leave in G
no proxies leave in gonet proxy and I
already coded scrubble dop so this is
another thing you would have to do I I
did it already and we are not doing here
because this is not very G it specific
but this is just a not a big class I
call it here Scrabble scorer and this
essentially has to implement the this
call methods that given us a batch of
states it returns uh a torch one
dimensional torch tensor with the
rewards for for
the for the for each item in the batch
that's
it so we
can cancel that and now we could just
replace proxy by scrubble and this w
train with uh with with an interesting
uh more interesting reward and this is
pretty slow to compute this reward so
you see uh because it has to look in the
dictionary and so on but what I'm going
to do is show
you um we could I take like five minutes
do you think it would be fine just
to you think I can take five minutes
yeah
I also have a question um is
there uh I mean the Lo that is been used
is used to train like do we make sure
that we have a valid trajectory for
instance the word that I created are
meaningful like what if I created a word
of seven letters in this case for
instance but is actually not an English
word so it's not a Val scrib word yeah
this is actually what I want to show oh
cool so if we just initialize the
environment so we just run this and we
don't do anything to train it the
trajectories is going to
sample oh
sorry um the trajector is going to to
sample are just random right so it won't
be English
words so we're going to see that quickly
if I take five minutes um sorry I forgot
to
install ipdb to put a breakpoint but I'm
just putting a breakpoint after the the
initialization of the environment and
we're going to see exactly what you were
saying so I have a breakpoint here and I
have some stuff like uh you know we can
look at this m state is just sorry you
canot see it well but
maybe you see it now the initial state
is just zeros and then we can do make a
step and I pass it an action the seven
for
example and it you know it works it does
what it's supposed to do what we have
coded we
can reset and we can do a trajectory
trajectory random so this will sample a
random trajectory just you know and we
end up this is the the state in the
end that's State and the actions and if
we sampled a batch of u a buch of states
without training the chances are they're
all going to be random so I've already
trained one model with this I didn't do
a lot of optimization but I can show you
quickly the the Dynamics of you know the
training curves for this can I take the
mic to show here so I'm sorry I'm going
a bit over time but just uh I think for
completeness so here we we have a couple
of things the
loss typic the typical loss that Manu
has shown before it goes down very
quickly
is working yeah it goes down quickly but
doesn't tell us a lot about what's going
on something that's a bit more
interesting is for example what is the
the mean reward in the b in the in the
training batch as we train and we start
from zero because it's just random
random words but as we train you see
that this increases this is good news
the mean reward in the in the bats is is
going up so it's it's finding words that
exist in the vocabulary and that have uh
you know better scores this is the max
the maximum of the reward in the in the
batch so it goes up to 16 or 17 or so
and then I have a couple of the metrics
that Manuel talked about this is the
correlation between the the
probabilities of the trajectories in a
test set that I just drew randomly and
the rewards and you can see that it
start from zero no correlation so
complete trash but as we train it it
increases so it means that it is
learning more or less correct
probabilities for the for the yeah for
the elements in the test
set just a comment that I it's working
uh forgot to slide in my thought like
about your average reward that's really
important sorry about the average reward
that's going important oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah the average reward because that's
you know that's supposed to increase uh
so it's so it can go down and you know
as it trins but in general it has to go
up so the very last thing I will do is
the
following it's just to connect to the
MAA
cluster and I
had no no no this is not correct what is
this
wait I thought I had
a
sorry I need to reconnect I lost the
terminal um I just wanted to show you uh
like loading the model what I did a
couple of minutes ago was uh putting a
breakpoint and you know drawing sampling
a random trajectory to see how the
envirment actually works now I want to
do the same but with the by after
loading the pre-trained uh the
pre-trained model to take a look at the
batch and see some some words if this
connects at some
point weird
because I thought I had
this
come
on yeah you can play with this I think
it's worth at the beginning playing a
little bit with you know what are the
see what's the action uh the action
space uh look at the The Masks Etc you
know to to see what is actually the it's
like a game you know like what are the
actions what are the valid
actions okay so yeah so here I am here I
loaded the sorry I'll do this and then
we'll go with questions I loaded the the
model and we can sample from the gonet
this is the agent gonet we have this
method which is called sample batch and
we're going to say sample 100
trajectories forward Train F so no no
random
actions just get the
BS didn't take too long
yeah hello
okay what's going
on okay this is doing very weird things
unfortunately
okay we can from this bat we can uh see
the
states which is just indices so not very
nice but before I just wrote the the for
Loop to iterate over the terminating
States and do this conversion thing
state to readable so we can actually
look at the the
words okay
so if we look at the words this is the
the 100 words sampled by gfet and not
all of them are going to be amazing but
we
see you
know lab cat Jo that I don't know mat
not there's no random these are words
that are in the dictionary actually it's
not low you know if this compare it to
we talked before
that there is uh you know 10 to the 10
combinations and only 10 to the five so
100,000 so it's actually not easy to
find words that are in the dictionary
and here we see we see many and there's
a funny thing that this dictionary
actually has a I'm just going to show
you
here
UHS
scrubble vocabulary seven letters so
these are letters that are in the
dictionary so you were looking like no
those are no words well yeah but this
dictionary has or vocabulary has weird
things too um we can the last thing I
will do is look at the the
rewards so these are the
rewards bit ugly to
see but yeah those words actually are in
the those are in the in the vocabulary
because except some here so this would
be
zero but the rest are you know one or
some with you know eight
uh 13 so those are actually words that
are in the in the vocabulary so in other
words it means that it has learned
something has learned a little bit we
could say that this different has
learned a bit the the morphology of of
English you know softening the claim a
little bit but it does okay I'll stop it
here and I hope you found it interesting
and yeah take some questions and sorry
for going over
time
um yes I had the question like at the
first time you were using a uniform
rewards and then you Chang the the
policy to scramble what's the difference
between both rewards like how does that
work what's the difference between like
you were using a uniform policy I think
or appr proxy no like for the rewards
yeah and then you change to a scramble
like what are you introducing that
what's the difference no you could
explain over there uh yeah good question
so when I when I
do proxy equal uniform it say that the
reward is going to be the same for all
samples all sequences in so in
particular is one but it could be
whatever so if you train with this it
should learn to sample combinations of
seven
letters with equal probability with
uniform probability and when I put proxy
equals scrubble it is it is a function a
reward function like the
one in uh the one I explained here and
the you know the Scrabble score the sum
of the of the score of each letter okay
okay right does it make sense okay okay
thank
you yeah thanks for the very nice
tutorial maybe you explained before but
why does the uh loss like converge while
the reward still uh increases when you
show the why the reward increases
yeah um because at the beginning when
you start training it samples random
sequences right the idea of G is to
sample proportionally to the reward
function
so sequences with higher reward should
be sampled with higher probability so as
G becomes better at this still your
policy doesn't change right if you're so
your
loss oh sorry it's not a loss I thought
this first the upper left plot
is your upper left upper left this oh
this is the bad size okay sorry sorry uh
yeah this gives me an idea of the
average length of the sequences that's
it I thought so that's why yeah then
it's normal sorry it's normal that do
everybody understands this this bit of
why the the mean reward goes up
yeah okay is there any other
question no
yeah good question is the policy MLP
yeah I was very lazy to do a Transformer
or something but I think a Transformer
would make this a lot better and easier
but yeah it's just an MLP with with one
hot en codings of the of the uh letters
which is also not the best choice so
this is like a very poor
implementation very basic there's a lot
of things that can be improved here so
just to show that even if you do like a
initial attempt you know takes a while
to train because of the reward but yeah
eventually it it
works I cannot hear you
Lena what is the bat size I think it's
10 because I didn't change 10 or
100 no it's 100 it's 100 because the bad
So when you say bat size here so the
number of trajectories in the training
bats is 100 that's why the bad size
which is the number of states here in
this plot is about 400 because on
average they have length four or
so so it's trained for 10,000
iterations and this also maybe important
to remark it's train for 10,000
iterations with a bad size of
100 so it sees one
million different here has seen one
million words seen has completed a
reward of 1 million words and it still
has learned to to sample uh words that
are in the dictionary and
have uh some
reward that was my question like because
you said this the whole Space is 10 to
the power of 10 and the good things are
only 10 to the power of five so
wondering like how much your gpnet
should explore until it finds one good
one million yeah one million here oh
wait so the whole the whole training is
just one million the number of sequences
the number of words the
different uh computers are word of for
training is 1 million oh W one million
here when at the end of
training 10,000 times
the 100 are you talking about the 100 I
had here this I just put it myself it
could
be yeah here I could sample
[Music]
and that would be the hail Halls cow
yeah rat you know cow if it finds
animals okay think I'm over time so I'll
leave it here thank you for the
attention and feel free to reach out if
you have
questions hey I'm also I'm seeing here
but I forgot what uh we have a little
break now so uh I'm over time but let's
take uh it's take 15
minutes and we come back at half past
three for the gonet clinic
okay
right
I
think it's
PR
don't know where you
are
Happ
but
the
[Music]
go
very
for
like you're always the
Yeah so
basically
still
nor
down
see a back
faway
five
Lu
have
somebody
else no
always no it's it's like you want to use
your right put in the butt
[Music]
so we're going to take like IDE
for that were submitted but
also people who are
like
on
segmentation we like to use G so okay we
take the idea okay
[Music]
what what
problems also want to
give the meth to Ru the there were
things that is like you
know
you see the previous
[Music]
one have a little
sister
yeah
no then it's
very but you don't
have
hello
hello I am again sorry to interrupt
wonderful
discussions we're going to proceed with
the
with the
clinic
okay if we can go back to
our
[Music]
speeds
I'm going to invite officially all
the
organizers uh or
gonet enthusiasts to join here on stage
if you if you want if you don't you
prefer to stay in the in the audience
that's also fine just everybody
everybody's welcome
so the it's a bit of a strange session
so I'll just say a few words
um about our idea with
this I will sit like everybody
um so the idea the idea with this
session is to
essentially um talk about what are
problems that are well suited for gonet
and what are problems that you know you
rather use something else because we're
not going to give the impression that
this is the the method to to rule them
all it will depend on on the problem and
for that as you probably know we sent at
some point last week or so an email with
a link to to collect
ideas your your the problems you work
on so we're going to go through that but
you're also welcome to to go to the mic
and and tell us your your
idea and also to interrupt I think you
know you're welcome to interrupt anytime
because this the point of this is to
make it interactive and to to to answer
your your questions and your your doubts
okay do you want
say good yeah it doesn't need to be
super specific also um we're gonna start
with the more specific stuff yeah so I
will so people we have six uh cases that
we need to analyze in the clinic uh I
just want to to ask in the room like is
anybody uncomfortable if we show the the
thing on screen you know the just the
little text boxes from the Google form
on screen no and I'll go ahead I need to
join the you can say something while I
join the zoom
call um in the
meantime uh in like 10 seconds or less
the thing you're most excited about for
the next six months
oh I'm already
there uh molecular dyamics for
antibodies uh conditional dri net with
graph neural network
policies I know but like for me it's
more because I don't know that like more
application to biology uh of the thing
that have been working
on skip
it uh
individual okay this is the first one
should I just read it out loud see if we
can make sense of
this so problem description I am
training neural networks to predict
certain properties for example stability
of RNA molecules based on their SE
quence so for a given sequence X this
model will predict the stability why we
can then use this model to design novel
sequences with desired properties so
increase stability the architecture of
this model is very simple uh Transformer
thing with smaller
stuff um I think it's a good case to to
get
started yeah can say something um I
guess Mo probably has a similar EXP
experience here but like that works
really well is methods where you use
gfet to kind of explore around your your
data set uh by doing like local edits or
by seating trajectories in a Smart Way
um then you you know you won't go far
away and then of course you can afford
ensembles or other uncertainty kind of
uh
prediction uh that's that's going to
help I don't
know uh yeah basically uh the things
that uh I talked about earlier uh in the
day around sequence design so you can in
fact design an mdp which is more suited
to local exploration where you start
with uh some natural sequences uh which
uh like which you want to uh which you
want to begin with and do lead
optimization sort of things so you
generate mutations on those sequences uh
mutations for those sequences um and uh
that can sort of that can be a good
strategy to keep you uh like closer to
Natural sequences without uh uh while
also being able to make uh edits to
maximize the properties or like achieve
the properties that you're interested in
um and apart from that there are so
instead of uh instead of just doing like
addition uh this mutation based action
space another option is also to have
some uh or sorry in addition to that you
can also do this thing we call like
backward forward I I don't know there's
a good name for it but essentially you
start with some good uh some uh again
known uh natural sequence you take K
steps using your backward policy and
then you uh take the K steps again with
your forward policy and that can be one
other strategy to uh generate
trajectories and improve training of
your gonet uh if um and so the these
would uh uh these would be some
techniques uh the other thing is if you
also want to uh uh uh maximize the
property of interest rather than just
sample proportional to it or like be
more greedy about it you can always do
the temperature conditioning sort of
tricks that uh we also discussed
yesterday and the tricks that uh Jared
mentioned so you can be more greedy
about it you can sort of have more
exploration and so on so uh but this
definitely like mentioned is like a very
nice use case where G is good fit in and
uh might be helpful uh but I should also
mention that if you would uh uh if like
uh one other thing to also try would be
some mcmc style thing like Gibbs with
gradients uh uh sort of approaches which
also tend to work well on these types of
problems sorry that was very long
good other I
would I would just say quickly like
taking a step back because we're going
to see other cases that are not so not
not like different to this so I would
just say that this is almost the
standard kind of problem we've been
doing like I we train a
model on X's to predict y you know could
put whatever you like to X and Y and
then we train different to sample
proportionate to Y so if when the
problem can be framed in this term there
is a good chance that uh you know giet
will be
a a good method to to tackle the problem
just I wanted to make that kind of
General thing because we're going to see
examples where this is not so obvious
and then G might still be suited or in
some Cas it will not but for those cases
it's uh it
fits uh maybe I want to add some
question to this discussion because I
think here the main uh the main issue is
that uh the generated sequences are far
from the natural sequences and uh yeah
the auto of the question uh hoping that
def might be useful to uh to yeah to
generate Noel sequences with Des propy
without being too dissimilar to Natural
sequences and I'm thinking that there
could be an issue when we like train
jonet with this proxy model and jonet
generates something out of distribution
on which proxy was trained on it could
be an issue with with the training
signal so yeah I'm curious what you
think about it so one uh uh sorry if
anyone
has I mean one option could be to have a
generative model like normal generative
model of sequences trained on the data
that you have which defines your
distribution in distribution and you can
incorporate that into the gonet reward
uh such that it maintains High
likelihood under this uh maximum
likelihood model trained on sequence es
that you have in your data set while
maximizing your property of Interest as
well so like a product of the two maybe
one
option uh just yeah another comment is
um how you do model selection for the
proxy itself uh you may want to kind of
carve out the validation set that has
some structure right rather than being
like a ID subsample of your whole data
set um there's there's paper on rers on
this from chemistry and sequences and
stuff and like that can make a
difference in particular what you may
want to test your model for is how good
it is at extrapolation and kind of uh
again like mode out of
distribution uh
generalization uh and and you may wish
to select your
models parameters for that for the pr
part that
lead
I would just add that I don't know if it
would be the easy or the best thing in
this particular problem with RNA
sequences but this idea of adding
constraints if it is possible what I
discussed in the crystal gonet
presentation can also help for this so
if it is possible to incorporate hard
constraints in the the MTP in the
process of you know sampling of the the
generating process that can also guide
or help help guide the search towards
more
realistic uh or natural looking objects
I would
say questions from the audience
perhaps maybe we can move to the
next
uh what happened
ah yeah yeah no name no name good
problem description okay conditional
generative transformation of samples in
a population from one distribution a
control distribution to another case
distribution but with unbalanced not
match not not matched and paired
samples and
bottlenecks what to do in the case of
these joint population sizes changes in
density due to addition subtraction of
samples growth death between
populations uh extra
details thinking of this issue in terms
of optimal transport I don't think I
know enough about differet to know there
exact limitations but looking forward to
learning during the
workshop okay son take it away so I
don't know about optimal transport by I
think that's that sounds like a good
application for that one thing that we I
hope that this Workshop has showed is
that the vanilla setting for a gonet we
we talk about it as a generative model
so people assume that it's like a
diffusion model where you you're giving
it a data set and then you you can get a
sampler that can sample from it in
gonets the things are a little bit
different because we have this reward
function which comes from a proxim mod
from an oracle uh that you can evaluate
each U each element for for that so the
let's say the basic version of gonet we
we don't necessarily start the the very
first thing that you start with is not
necessarily A a data set of samples uh
and so when you when you have uh
unpaired uh data sets of data sets of
unpaired samples uh maybe so one thing
you could do with gonets would be to
learn a proxy model for your control
control setting learn a proxy model to
for uh your I mean your experimental
setting uh and then train a gonet for
both cases uh but the thing is it's it's
going to be only as good as your proxy
model as we we we talked before um so in
I think we we should also like say that
gon is not used for everything uh of
course you can always find a way to use
gonets in your workflow uh but this uh
uh this could be this could be one of
those settings where uh gonets is maybe
not the most natural first thing that
you should think about yeah um cting Kia
here who's fortunately not present right
now um
but re optimal transport you can
actually use G to train stochastic
Bridges between two distributions or two
modalities uh it's not too complex
basically just a modifcation of
trajectory balance between two
modalities so definitely something that
can be done
here
questions
I just wanted to know if you could just
elaborate more on that difference
between the diffusion and the gone
x uh yeah so um so in defusion models
again I'm not an expert in diffusion
model but uh in generative model
generative AI whatever you want to call
it usually you start from let's say a a
data set of images you train your
generative model and then you you expect
it to sample from it sample new images
sample new text when it comes to llms um
so this is more something that like
starts with a data set and then gets you
a sampler in gonet the very basic uh
jlet that we we've been talking many of
these presentations have been talking
about we start from a reward function
and how to structure your your state
space but the the basic block is how to
uh for each possible object that you can
uh create so for example for each
molecule you would be able to give uh to
give it a reward so how good this uh
this specific molecule is going to be
and then you train your gonet you obtain
the sampler at the end but these the the
thing that you start with is going to be
different when it comes to standard
generative model I'm I'm uh I'm uh uh
focusing on diffusion models but we like
think about like Gans or something like
that it's it is the same thing starting
from a data set to a generative to a
sampler here we're starting from uh
reward function and getting a sampler I
should also emphasize that this is
really I'm just talking about the
vanilla version of gonet we also have uh
some work in uh at Mila in yashua's
group in particular uh where people have
been using gonets in addition to um
using a data set of observations in
order to train uh the reward function as
part like along with the the gfet itself
um so these are the kind of things that
you you can do definitely do uh but yeah
for me this these are the two different
like the main difference between these
two
things uh yeah I wanted to uh maybe uh
comment one thing on this thing
uh uh this so I'm not an expert on this
again as Emanuel mentioned Kia if he was
here he would have elaborate a bit more
on this but uh there is this other class
of generative uh models called flow
matching models so a bit it's a bit
confusing because we have flow matching
in G flets as well but uh those are like
the flow matching models I'm referring
to are essentially continuous time
normalizing flows which are sort of
designed for this sort of thing
uh which uh which might be more
applicable here than the G flow flow
matching uh so those are the that might
be one
thing anything else about this one
no more questions okay let's move to the
next
one all right I try to predict the level
of expression of a gene in a cancerous
cell line from the expression of 1,000
genes in another cell line the levels of
expression have been recorded for
various experimental conditions
treatments um so I've been trying
different architectures I would like to
know if another kind of model could
potentially perform
better
um yeah I mean
uh this sounds like a regression problem
rather an enchant of problem but that
being said um I think you know this is
the kind of data that there a lot of
structure and maybe you could speak more
to that but you can certainly use gonets
to learn interesting
latents from which you might want to do
regression on or even caal models there
so don't know yeah so this this this
seems like a good a good test case for
for causal model where you want to
understand how genes interact with one
another and actually which Gene is
causing the expression of another Gene
and so you can apply some of these uh um
some some of these models that Mizu
presented for example today on how to
use gonets for uh for finding causal
models the advantage of having a a gonet
in general is to to get a distribution
but when it comes specifically to to
these kinds of applications where we we
don't really know it's it's really all
about scientific discovery uh the nice
thing is that we can the the gonet can
give us um different theories uh about
how genes are uh related are um causing
the expression of some other genes and
so then we can go back to the wet lab
testing this these theories and then
feedback this this data into the gonet
in order to like pinpoint exactly what
what would be uh some uh some of these
genes that are uh that are causing the
expression of some some other Gene that
we are interested
in maybe I can add one small thing so uh
it's related to this gen regulatory
Network so uh with another students we
were working on just 300 genes and we
had a similar data sets but it was like
we had Interventional data we knew what
Gene we would knock out and we had the
expression level of all of the other
genes and that was a nice to example to
try to infer the gene regulatory
Network um so yeah but I'm not sure if
here there is a really Interventional
data but yeah it's definitely some
things that are
try
um maybe one thing to uh so I I'm no I'm
not an expert in the intersection of uh
machine learning and and uh uh and the
applications of uh to genes but one
thing in particular in this field to to
look out for is that the the kind of
data that we're working with uh is Count
data and so this is way different from
the standard kinds of data that we are
used to in in machine learning and so
some of these uh modeling assumptions
that were usually making in machine
learning they may not transfer to these
cases for gene expression so sometimes
you have to think more about looking at
the data I think well I don't need to
tell you that like you need to look at
the data see what it looks like and pick
the models that are making more sense uh
especially for these these kinds of data
in a large majority of the of the cells
that you're going to
observe some of these genes will not be
expressed at all so you end up with
having some distribution which has a lot
of zeros everywhere and so this is not
your standard normal distribution that
you can use so you have to think a
little bit deeper into how to how to uh
model those and luckily now we we do
have some uh some uh methods based on G
netw for C Discovery in particular where
we have the chance to we have this
flexibility about the model modeling
choices that we can we can make so we
can use some of these non-standard
models all right yeah we just add that
uh I highlighted here I try to predict
because you know whenever our goal if if
it's just predicting it's Pro and not
gen you know as opposed to generating or
learning a distribution sampling those
are the the keywords where we think of
difference immediately like sampling
generating uh you
know uh if it's just predicting
something the
standard supervised machine learning
methods are probably a a good first step
and then you can enrich the the problem
with g
okay the next
one is rather brief generation of large
molecules that optimize multiple
properties sounds like a good fit in
principle Uh current bottlenecks are the
size of molecules in accurate reward
function multiple objectives continuous
3D coordinates yeah yeah we know we know
those size of the molecule is in the the
100 atom range only a small data set a
lot of like
challenges um 1,000 molecules only the
reward isn't great there are multiple
objectives um structure of the molecules
involves a lot of Cycles you can deal
with
that
okay I
have
uh yes so it sounds like a good task for
the
defet and yeah as you may seen in in the
previous days we um data papers on
multiobjective gonet so it's something
which can be used in this case uh what
else uh about an accurate reward
function if you can measure somehow the
the like accuracy of the reward maybe
you can uh use the approaches which
developing the multifidelity
work um continues to the 3D coordinates
is also something like you can use
continuous defet for that so yeah you
can combine multiple papers which you
seen during this workshop and come up
with something interesting uh and for
the size of the molecules uh yeah maybe
I can add that you can try to use these
intrinsic coordinates instead of the um
3D
themselves it will reduce a lot the
dimensionality of the problem if you
focus only on the T
angles um yeah that's that's some my
thoughts yeah um definitely you might
have also like memory issues if you try
to generate whole sequences so like
subtv will be your friends detailed
balance um it's going to be very useful
and also so the way you're going to
sample training data will matter um
again I think we talked about this
earlier but like local kind of
exploration uh methods where you you
start around your training data you're
going to be very effective in this uh
this domain this kind of problem uh
especially with large graphs
um one other thing I wanted to
say yeah right
some trick that I think is even in like
my initial spinal face notebook um you
can do gradient accumulation if like
your batch size uh you want to make it
bigger but it doesn't fit on your GPU
and depends on the problem but typically
having a larger batch size May stabilize
learning especially if you have a very
big space very large graph that you're
generating that may be one thing you
want to
implement
uh I I have a short comment but just to
temper
expectations uh like a 100 atom graph is
quite challenging even for a discret
chronet uh it's like it can be very
tricky to train and uh I maybe Emanuel
can correct me but I don't think we have
done 100 atom generation on
any big in like complicated enough
reward
function I mean I maybe not 100 but I've
done like eight objective gonet on like
60 to 80 atoms okay it's doable but it
only really works with this local search
kind of trick where I think what usually
work the best is like again going
backwards 10 20 steps then going forward
that many
steps but yeah It's
Tricky your method do you add atom by
atom or
because maybe one idea could be like to
reduce the trajectory length by having
bigger fragments and you know it's
not probably is not the the end goal or
the the best way to go about it but if
you have the Restriction of a of a small
molecules and you can afford that and it
make sense in the in your problem maybe
that's a way to to simplify
the uh the
trajectories
okay so I have two questions one is
quite General um so what are the
applications or scenarios where gonet
can be helpful for
RL
um I think I already kind of like
discussed briefly with Emanuel but I
just want to hear everyone's opinion on
like what um you know like maybe yeah
just like what type of task or uh what
like for example we have seen one talk
on the first day that you know gonet can
help exploration um but can jonet help
sample efficiency let's say in AR and
also the second question is that so
we've seen that um you know Max Sorel
and
gonet um you know structure can be
equivalent in the sense that they might
both recover the same optimal policy but
how does the trajectory is different in
Max and RL versus gonet and um also do
we know how um efficient gonet is versus
max
an
I me I already give you my opinion but I
can repeat it
um so there is some experiments not for
me from Kena and Albert mainly um
showing that you can kind of train an RL
policy using G objectives and what you
end up with is uh especially if you
course like a uniform backward policy
something some some agent that will kind
of uh try to take all the trajectories
say to a goal deal probability and that
helps with robustness um
and uh in some cases I think there's
some sample efficiency but where it
really shined in their experiments was
when you're transferring to a different
domain this is all like BBI kind of
grids and rooms and all that um and then
the the the fine chaining or the
adaptation P adaptation there was much
faster with with those really diverse
policies um so that that's one thing
where we know it kind of works
um a lot of people have asked me this
week about options
um you
know I think it's not unreasonable to to
think about G Nets being good
at
proposing
say better policy over options that
might be a bit more uh diverse and as
greedy and in that sense kind
of uh force or or help with the options
not all collapsing to the same
policy but that's just intuition um and
then of course you know RL is
uh has interesting structure in terms of
the state space and I think it would be
an interesting application of learning
latent variables in particular because
we have a really nice prior that time is
is going on like there's some mdp to
recover in some sense or some
abstraction of the MVP um I think there
is something there in terms of like
applying G to
our and
yeah you mean we can discover the safe
space and the action space for
gyet
so I don't I also want to mention so for
this connection with RL uh there has
been a few and I can think of two papers
where gonets and especially continuous
gonets have been applied to uh
continuous control problems uh and so uh
the uh I think the conclusion in
particular in the our continuous gonet
paper from n uh our conclusion was that
it was helping in terms of uh in terms
of exploration so we do have evidence on
on some arguably toy uh continuous uh
continuous control problems um when it
comes to discrete uh discrete action
spaces which is more what you would see
for discre G fromet I don't think there
is evidence beyond that
but and when it comes to the relation to
Max and RL so in the original paper uh
by Emanuel and mo uh the there was this
sort there was this connection between
maxent and gonet uh for uh trees that P
was was talking about the first day um
and it's also it also shows the result
when it's not a tree anymore and how
these things are biased so it's biased
with by the number of trajectories that
are leading to a certain object and I
should also point out that there is a a
recent work there is uh not coming from
Ila uh that is studying this connection
more closely between Max centel and and
gonets uh especially how to tweak Max
cental a little bit uh to solve the same
kind of problems that we've been doing
with
ches yeah there's also another paper
from soan one of Y student where showing
you can literally just learn to count
bths use that to modify your reward as
well kind of works uh uh but I should
highlight one thing that uh in the paper
which uh proposes the modifications to
the mdp to make Max and RL equivalent to
gonets even in the D case uh they still
have the assumption that PB is uniform
uh but if you have a learn PB that sort
of changes the Dynamics quite a bit more
uh so that equivalence does not hold um
although there could be ways to bridge
that Gap as well uh but I also wanted to
highlight just one point on on the
connection to Max and RL is there is
also a lot of uh things uh that can go
the other way so like now we're talking
about gonets and how it can help RL but
a lot of RL ideas can also be imported
into gonets I think uh Ela and em have
done a lot of work on uh uh exploring
some of these ideas but there's
definitely a lot more which has been
done in RL which can be also used in
gonets and to go back to the previous
question of what can gonet do for RM uh
one option uh one sort of somewhat
different application could be uh for
World models so we Emanuel talked about
like using later variable models in the
context of RL uh so in model based RL I
guess these days uh dreamer dreamer
style models uh specifically dreamer V3
which has this uh dqv as its World model
uh uh has seen a lot of success very
sample efficient works on a lot of tasks
um uh and uh uh so the thing is uh the
representations vqv learn are very good
and it's easy to trade and so on uh but
uh there is always a case which can be
made that if you have better
representations more
uh structured representations you can
potentially get even more sample
efficient learning so uh some of the
things which we unfortunately didn't get
uh to discuss uh throughout the workshop
uh but one of the things is you can use
G Flores uh to learn lat variable models
with more interesting structured latents
so uh for instance uh you can think of
uh given a in given an image you can
sort of infer a seene graph of the image
and that can be a lot more helpful for a
control policy than just let's say a vqv
related which is not of the Shelf
interpretable as
such M comes to
you um I'm wondering whether we can use
gonet for imitate learning as well like
learning the path of experts in the
environment and
yeah
ER depends on the setting I you can
definitely train G Nets with like expert
data and that actually is usually a good
trick
um I guess if you consider like the EB
gfn kind of case then
can end up learning a similar
distribution to your data set that can
be data set of
trajectories then I guess it's fair to
call that imitation learning but I don't
know you like a more specific
environment or class of environments in
mind I think that's the theme uh of many
of our answers but there is things that
we uh where chipet can be used for
imitation running but I also feel like
can also we can also uh take inspiration
from the from the imitation learning
literature so right now the bgf in paper
we can like kind of see it as being
Behavior cloning but maybe there's some
better options that we can like that we
can use for example D dagger style uh in
gonet I don't think that we we have that
so far but maybe that's an interesting
Avenue someone did dagger
so someone did did it already so that's
perfect good okay let's move to the next
um patient or
candidate
um okay in the context of basan meta Fus
shot
learning uh I don't know what that
is I am thinking of applying gonet to
sample task dependent latent given few
shots and I want the representation to
be an entire sequence of latent
variables instead of last one question I
want to ask is can G
train to match a joint Target
distribution of both intermediate and
terminating States or it has to be the
target distribution of the dermina
state I mean I'm not trying to
understand the question but for the last
sentence
definitely um if you want to learn a
joint distribution then you can just
make
like a join instiution to you can just
make an both part of the state
description and then you do end up
learning a joint um even if A's could be
consider intermediary States maybe an
example of this is um synthetic
chemistry so you are generating let's
say a synthetic ra for a particular
molecule um and that's a bunch of
chemical reaction steps what you want to
train the gonet on is the whole
synthetic route right so current state
is a partially constructed not just like
whatever the current molecule you're at
is um so yeah but
uh so I don't I don't really know I
shouldn't know about application to p
and meta F short learning
uh but uh I I don't have any any further
Insight something I I want to also
highlight is maybe related to that if
you and it was not really like was
briefly mentioned that in some of the
talks is if you have information about
some of your intermediate States you
should definitely use it and so we we do
have for example the forward-looking uh
objectives uh that uh are using this
information about intermediate rewards
so that the flows that you will learn
for example in detailed balance when you
have to learn a state flow you will not
have to learn the part which you already
know about the the actual intermediate
reward so this eases the uh the training
uh so definitely make use of this this
kind of information if you if you have
that okay well
maybe can move to the last one which is
tricky
um don't
now
okay it's long but try to read
it does it make any sense to use gonets
for nonepisodic control tasks for
example developing the model of System
Dynamics for controllers for buildings
for example for either battery charge
discharge or stage of a heating system
where the task is to optimize a
nonlinear system for non-episodic
control tasks based on limited data
actions take place on the order of once
per minute or faster and the model takes
into account the probabilistic nature of
the system systems Dynamics as well as
the noise in the measurements and in the
environment um yeah so bottleneck every
single building has unique Dynamics and
disturbances there is a need to design
controllers that are good enough with
limited building specific real
data one side of this challenge is
generating training data so hard to get
training data
diversity yeah and there's a bunch of
challenges here you want to add
something feel free to you know add more
more context if you want but
uh when I say something already like I'm
starting a lot
but while you're still reading I can say
a few words um
I I don't know that I would use infonet
for non-tic control I don't think they
handle like long discounted Horizons
very well it's not so far um what I
would definitely use it though is to
generate uh like the initial training
trajectories for your bigger model or
even just
like um in an active learning kind
of framework
um try to figure out what are the right
experiments to optimally you know as few
days as possible fine what the building
Dynamics look like I think that's very
reasonable place to apply gness because
we kind of generating a short Horizon of
uh
controls
um than that
yeah so some something I I would suggest
is to it's the taking the
quote unquote basan perspective it's to
not model the the data directly using
the gonet so in those in this case if
you were to use the data to inside the
gonet already you would have this
nonepisodic uh setting but what I would
do is maybe try to build a model of your
like let's say nonlinear system of
equation and then you can use a gonet to
build this model maybe there is some
structure that you can leverage and then
you can the way that you evaluate your
uh the final model the final set of
equations that you you end up with you
can use the data that you already have
you you see how well this these
equations are fitting the data that you
have and then you can train the gonet to
sample possible models that could
explain this data and then you can also
also add a prior on top of it to say
Okay I want to have models that are
simpler than others maybe you have some
prior knowledge that you want to
incorporate in this as well uh and then
you can do a lot of very nice things
when it come when when you have a bean
perspective um so that that would be my
suggestion but I don't know how enough
about the the details of the of the the
problem to to see if it's easy or
not yeah I would just uh
kind of building upon what uh Emanuel
said I I don't I'm not sure I understand
the all the details but for this aspect
of lack of training
data definitely the active learning
approach and would probably help and if
so if you have a way to
evaluate uh so you have a reward for a
trajectory to evaluate whether it is
reasonable um yeah I I like I I like the
the background but you could I guess you
could use different to to generate the
training data provided you have access
to a to a reward that you know you can
you can use to evaluate if the TR that
trajectory that that state of the system
is uh is good or
not and then that in an active learning
Loop to
acquire you know retrain Etc retrain the
the reward
Clon I just wanted to ask a followup um
about what you were proposing uh is it
something like use a g flet to sample an
equation that describes the nonlinear
Dynamics and then the reward is like how
well that explains some observations
yeah exactly so that that's that would
be my my regression something like that
yeah
any followup questions no
um right um well that was the last uh
patient um so we have we have oh sorry
oh sorry sorry yeah I was going to say
that we have more time for discussion 10
minutes or so so yeah so this is kind of
I guess a general class of problems but
I'll give an example just to like make
it maybe more concrete but say I have
some joint distribution that I want to
sample from let's split it into like py
and P like pyx whatever um but I have
access to a really good prior on PX for
instance um so maybe an example to kind
of examplify this is I want to predict
or sample from Crystal structures for
inorganic for for organic molecules oh
jez um so I might have really good
access to like the confirmation about
the kind of molecules so like I have the
C smile and I have really good access to
like PX so the confirmations about this
molecule but now I want to sample its
crystal structure um so a the
confirmation so P like X might change in
the sampling as well as well as needing
to sample all of these lus parameters so
just to kind of get
pyx and I was wondering is this the kind
of thing where you could use gonets
because they have this ability to kind
of do um some constraints Etc um so yeah
that's kind of it's quite a general
class of problems I guess but maybe the
organic crystal structure prediction
helps explain
it yeah uh yeah I also need to think
more but uh
in principle yeah it sounds like a like
a good problem for G for the reasons I
think you you've answered your your your
question like uh the fact that you can
incorporate constraints and you have
access
to to already okay but like how as in so
like I can just sample like a
confirmation but then I don't have a
consistent initial state so it's not
like and it's not entirely clear to me
how to go about this yeah so I I guess
would be first of all a conditional
gonet so you would condition on on a
molecule okay right so you have the
molecule and you want to get the crystal
structure yeah and I might have access
to really good confirmations about this
molecule about this molecule yeah so I
mean I I I I wanted to say that it seems
suitable but it's also I think it's also
hard there's a lot of uh potential
problems there or challenges more than
problems but uh yeah I think it would be
a conditional gonet where you would have
to do something similar so a combination
of what what I presented this morning
about inorganic Crystal structures where
you can Leverage The Domain knowledge
about the you know about the geometry
crystallography and so on and at the
same
time uh the molecular
confirmation approach where you know you
say you have access to good confirmation
well you can leverage that as as data
uh you know to to
learn the distribution and you have it's
like you have good good samples from the
distribution so you can incorporate
those but it might also I guess I'm not
an expert on this but I suppose the
confirmations that you have for
individual
molecules can also change when when it
crystallizes right so I think you would
also need to learn that problem
jointly so yeah I think it's challenging
but but
possible yeah that's my two
sense uh I'm curious you said you have
access to PX you mean you can sample
from PX or you have access to the like
value of the density function itself uh
I would say you probably just have
access to samples to like confirmations
but some for instance some confirmations
might you know be very close to the
confirmation inside a crystal and some
of them might not because you need to
like create a regular pattern from a
very complex structure in this kind of
organic Crystal
problem okay and do you have uh I'm just
thinking what would be reward in in this
in this task so okay you have access to
samples from P of X do and you want to
sample from from which distribution P of
Y given X you want to SLE problem P of Y
and X so the best idea I could come up
with on how to train a
with this and feel afraid to point out
how wrong this is is to kind
of you your P of X is basically giving
you an intermediate state from which to
then try to complete the to a terminal
state right because the the molecule
peration on itself is not a
full um like a false crystal structure
so it's like being able to sample from
intermediate states that have I guess
high flow or I'm not entirely sure this
is where three planets are very to me
and then you can do something with these
sub trajectories because there was some
mentioning of like some interpolation
between detailed balance and um
trajectory balance so that's kind of
where my head went at from what I've
heard of over the past three days but
yeah and do you have something to
evaluate how good the sampled crystal
structure
is can use as reward what you it there
is like this is a really important
problem to
pharmacology um
and so like there's lots of databases on
samples for like organic
crystals okay yeah but this is not a
reward function well reward function is
like I give you sample you give me some
quantity which tells how good this
structure is you can probably I mean you
can get a very expensive like reward
function for sure um you can probably
have I I don't remember exactly I worked
on this about two years ago now but um
you could probably get had a decent
estimate as to whether it's reasonable
like you know that certain um Crystal
laes for instance are incredibly
unlikely I mean I would do something to
similar to what we did for the atomic
crystal so if you have a database of of
molecular crystals
then at least the first step would could
be to train a model to predict uh like
the energy I guess of the of the
crystals if that is what matters and I
apologize if that is not what matters
that's kind of my my lack of
understanding of the domain and then use
that as a as the reward for the
molecular Crystal the the entire Crystal
but what I would like I said this seems
challenging and we've been thinking a
little bit about it as well so maybe we
can discuss I would I would start with a
simplified problem like for example
assuming uh like the molecule is rigid
in in the Crystal and that's much much
simpler and it becomes even closer to
the to the crystal flet for inorganic
cases and then from that you know make
it harder and harder by allowing the
molecule to to find other confirmations
Etc yeah yeah I agree with Alex I think
it like if you already have this sampler
from P ofx maybe you do not need jonet
to sample the molecules themselves so
you just start with the molecule from
this p p ofx sample is just a crystal
structure conditioned on this molecule
okay another patient yeah yeah so I
didn't know enough about jonet to be
able to add to the little questionnaire
when you posted it but not that I talked
to different people and during the two Q
days so the problem is uh building
regulation networks of proteins or genes
for process of Interest meaning that our
um set um of action would be like adding
genes or adding proteins or fragment of
already known networks with the
rewarding like it can exist from like
data of protein protein interactions or
Gene Gene interaction that we know and
the fact that those proteins or those
genes carry annotation of Interest so my
question is um first of all most of the
data is not completely annotated meaning
that we have an incomplete reward
function uh is there any way to deal
with
this my immediate answer would be active
learning okay um I'm biased as well
because I've worked on that a lot and
but you know seems suitable so you say
oh my reward function is not good
because I I don't have sufficient data
to cover entire
distribution then you
can Accel you can find
uh strategies to annotate the data
efficiently so find the the data points
that will help you learn a good reward
function a good model predictive model
by with active learning which is
um Mo talked about that this morning so
you use gonet as a sampler this provides
uh diversity in the
exploration and you can combine this
with the Bas optimization acquisition
functions um and you know in general
terms the output of that Active Learning
model is uh candidates to to be
annotated and then if you have access to
a to the Oracle that we will that will
um annotate the new samples you can you
know increase the the extend your data
set retrain and so on yeah that sorry I
was it was a bit poorly explained a list
of questions yeah yeah but no that helps
uh and then another question is like
most networks in biology are H cyclic
networks with feedback loops how do you
networ like most of the biological
networks have feedback loops so it's a
cyclic network uh and another thing is
that this network like the interaction
can be either activating or inhibiting
uh is that something that could be added
to to the design so definitely if you if
you have psychics so the The Talk this
morning on causal Discovery by misu it
was very specifically targeted towards
as graph but you can also apply these
like same things to cycle graph so in
particular Lazar worked on this paper
called D gfn where uh in particular for
application to uh Gene regulatory
networks um and so the idea is is very
similar to what we've been discussing so
far where you're you're building your
graph one Edge at a time but can still
allow it to be uh to you can allow it to
be cyclic and when when it comes to
having different types of edges
like inhibiting or
excite activating activating yeah
activating and inhibiting this is the
kind of things that you can also encode
into into your jlon that you can say uh
when I'm adding an edge is it inhibiting
or activating um so these These are the
kind of things that you can uh you can
choose when you design the structure of
your
gonet um but yeah I would definitely uh
recommend to to check out the D gfn
paper for that okay and and another
question is like how how wide can our
action space be meaning like here I just
said okay let's add a gene or let's add
a protein but for instance if we are
looking at the protein space we can have
like have a protein with modification in
a certain space of the cell with a
physical context so how how much
information can we put into this action
space and how like how varied can we
choose that
from um I think it's uh like the The
Wider your action spaces or the larger
your action spaces the harder it gets to
train the GED because that basically
increases the amount of exploration you
need to actually understand what each
action is doing uh and in this case I
think um so uh like if uh in some case
cases where you can actually make the
action space hierarchical instead of
making it flat so for instance you can
have like protein families or some
protein locations and instead of
selecting the entire thing all at once
we can it can be sort of decomposed into
multiple actions where you start from
the highest level of abstraction that
you can get so some like super family of
proteins and then you go to the sub
family and so on uh that is uh probably
one easy one strategy to sort of handle
very large action spaces but in general
even like in reinforcement learning and
similarly in G that's very large action
spaces can make learning much harder so
it's there's no like one bullet which
can sort of solve it for all cases but
hierarchical like in in this particular
case maybe hierarchical uh action spaces
might be a a more appropriate uh thing
which can help alleviate this issue a
bit and I'm just going to have like one
last question and then I'm done uh so
most networks in biology are dynamics uh
from what I understand we could do this
by having conditional networks with the
condition being a specific like time
snapshots as if like it we build a gfl
net for each time T um and then by
comining all those gfl Nets we get
something Dynamic is is that doable you
can just have t be an input to the T can
be an input to the model can be an input
that's the condition yeah you condition
your jlet at a given time and then you
have to build all those jlet to create
like a movie of what's going on well
it's the same model you're just it again
conditioning with different
ke's okay great exellent but I just want
to add something also um in some RL
papers where you have like a very large
ashin space what you can do is actually
embed your ACC
uh and
then use action embeddings right so
instead of having your model output uh
10,000 or 100,000 actions um you output
like an embedding and then you do
something like cosine similarity or
there's fancier things if you have like
extremely large library of of actions
um and you you learn the embeding at the
same time and that kind of helps scale
in in some
settings thanks a
lot
time um so yes thanks everyone in the
panel and especially thanks everybody
for your questions if you have more we
don't have more time right now but feel
free to to reach out
and I guess we
are um more asess available by email or
in person if you're here so yeah thanks
a lot
um what remains today is the closing
remarks by Professor yoshu Benjo and we
have a few minutes of a break before
before that so yeah
just in eight minutes we'll be back for
the closing
remarks
hello all right
yeah okay uh we're
going back to the
TRU
okay thank you everybody like we said
before we're goingon to have the the
closing remarks by Professor Yos Benjo
about perspectives closing remarks it's
a
talk but it's a closing talk and remarks
but yeah how much time do I have uh
officially 45 minutes okay okay that's
that's what I thought yeah just to say
that this is the closing session we
won't have closing remarks after this so
these are the closing room yeah it's
closing it's
closing um I want to say something
before I start we have plenty of
time um I'm going to talk about several
things that are connected but you know
feel free to raise your hand anytime in
the middle ask a question
disagree also it's
good
um all right
so I'm gonna start with some of the
challenges I see on my rer screen as
really
worth deserving uh
attention um to improve um her ability
to have impact in the world using gfl
Nets and derivatives that I'm thinking
about so as you know if you've played
with gflow Nets in fact if you play with
RL in
general that we can uh train these
systems these generative
policies when the objects that we are
constructing the number of steps that
are involved um is small enough like
100ish number of steps more or less is
what we can do reasonably well if we
multiply by
10 yeah credit assignment becomes a
problem or something else that's our
guess CR assignment is a
problem um and I'll I'll talk about
later of applications where I'd like to
use G flets in a way similar to
uh what Trista I assume talked about
regarding uh you know
generating theories of the world like
causal graphs and causal parameters
where the theory is just way too big for
the current algorithms that we have it's
not going to be something we can
generate in one
shot and so to expand the scope of
application of these methods I think
it's really worth first understanding is
it really credit assignment issue and
maybe we can learn from what people in
RL have been
doing um or is it something
else um there's another practical reason
why having more than a few hundred steps
is not great because each step is
running anural net you know producing an
output
so for most reasonable tasks you you
want to limit that uh if it's you know
um so it's just computational time um
now there's there's a path which I'm not
sure if this has been covered in the
workshop sorry I wasn't there all the
time I guess uh maybe in the continuous
um things there's there's a way to
generate a big
object which is not like the uh molecule
generation one little bit at a time
given the previous ones or like o
aggressive llms and so on but generate
everything in one
shot badly and then modify it and then
modify it and then modify it like an
mcmc for
example and in principle you could
generate much bigger
objects in this
way um so by the way there's a
computational reason for doing it this
way so imagine you want to generate a
parameter Vector like if you're basian
and you you
got 100 million parameters you don't
want to do 100 million feet forward
steps on your net right it's not even
besides the the credit assignment
problem it's just not
reasonable um but you can certainly
generate a vector of size 100
million I think that's something
computers today can do um and
then modified a 100 times right so now
that becomes something because gpus is
paralyze we can have a lot of
outputs but we can't really run
sequentially 100 times or a thousand or
a million times that's going to be too
much so there is some ongoing work
that's like that it's the same style of
computation you find in diffusion dosing
and things things like that and
mcmc um I think we need to push that
boundary and see how far we can go with
that and really try to scale it up
um there's
another less clear thread that we'll
come back in another slide um something
that's been explored a lot in
reinforcement learning which maybe you
can also we can also learn from that's
called haral reinforcement
learning um so okay we can't generate a
huge
object easily so now it's back to the
credit assignment um but maybe we can
like break down the problem into smaller
problems kind divide and conquer so
people inal arel think about options and
skills and you know a high level plan so
we decompose the problem into re
reusable pieces um so I I think this is
this is really worth thinking about and
I'll come back to that um the other big
area which I think
uh is worth spending more time on is
training
efficiency
and the tricks we're currently using
now we kind of figured out pretty
quickly in the first few months of
playing with G flet and there's been a
lot of work trying to improve on that
and I
think we only made marginal
improvements so
so there there may be several aspects to
this but one that I find particularly
mind bugling is also something that we
can take inspiration from the work in uh
reinforcement learning
exploration so you know in RL we're
asking where should the agent go in
order to collect useful information
given that it can't go everywhere
information that will help it later to
um to get high
rewards and so in the case of gfl Nets
we have this freedom of choosing the uh
training distribution the behavior
distribution the
uh the behavior
policy how do we pick those training
trajectories so we you know we we have
tricks we um we can use some data we can
use greedy uh exploration tempering
prioritize replay maybe others I didn't
think of um but but I think there's a
lot of potential
there or maybe it's like very hard and I
don't know but but it could really help
to scale up
uh because sometimes if you've played
gonets we think we have a well-defined
problem we you know turn the
crank and
huh the optimization doesn't work like
we're we're stuck in suboptimal
Solutions we don't find the high reward
configurations trajectories and so on so
so it's an optimization problem and it's
an optimization problem in the case of
which we can think of as an exploration
problem um so when we think about it as
an exploration problem
my
geometric uh intuition is
that uh a lot of it is about
generalization so if you think about
what we're trying to do is guess where
potentially uh good modes like high
reward regions would be without having
to try everything it's the exploration
problem right right where is there high
reward in a very high dimensional
space
and it's hopeless if you just do like
some local search I mean we should do it
and there's some nice recent work um
combining mcmc local search with gonets
for example but it doesn't solve like
the bigger
problem um and so maybe the solution
isn't going to be
with the autol loop or the you know
tricks generic tricks maybe the solution
is going to be as usual in machine
learning how do we get better
generalization inductive
biases right so we kind of do
something magical with the architecture
we invent attention and
suddenly you got a revolution on your
hand um so that's one one thing that I
think is worth uh pushing maybe maybe
exploiting the particulars of the
task or fairly General ideas like I was
talking about you
know Notions of abstraction and uh and
and reusable components and things like
that so which which is all about
generalization like how do we we're
trying
to um guess modes from a few modes so
it's a difficult
so the other source of information which
uhu I think
Jared um who talked yesterday uh
explored but we we
haven't we haven't find found yet a
satisfying solution I think he has a
paper but it it's
exploiting the
uncertainty about what the new net has
learned so if you know we're trying to
get the loss low
everywhere
and
um there are there may be regions where
the ne net can generalize with
confidence that okay this should be low
reward place or this should be a high
reward
place um mostly we need to explore in
regions of low certainty where in other
words like if you were Bean you would
like to go so you we may want to think
about the training problem
in gflow Nets like an active learning
problem because we we are able to query
the reward function it's not like a
usual learning problem with a fixed data
set and we're trying to minimize the
loss on those points it's very different
it's much more like an active learning
problem and maybe we should be thinking
about training methods for gfl Nets that
are inspired by the ideas in active
learning and and one of the central
ideas maybe Mar presented is um
estimating uncertainty and then direct
your attention to the places of high
uncertainty so how to do
that isn't trivial like simple things
we've
tried was it's not that easy and then
one reason why it's not trivial is
that
um the uncertainty that the new net has
about some particular
configuration is going to
change the moment you update it with
some
example right so you can't have like a
separate process that estimates
uncertainty um we tried things like this
with salm and others U last
year um it's going to be something built
in your g-l net that it both estimates
flows policies and their uncertainty so
that
you know you don't need you don't have
this like non-stationary issue that um
otherwise you would
get
okay any question up to now because I'm
going to kind of change um sort of mood
a little
bit you sure there's a so you're talking
about the uncertainty in the policy
right sorry you're talking about the
uncertainty in the policies right yes
the insy in the policy or the flows or
whatever your parameterization is yeah
because you could also leverage the
uncertainty in the reward or are you
assuming the reward is perfect no I'm
assuming the reward is
known if so this is a different question
like if you're also learning the reward
function and that's the
usual um Active Learning B optimization
you know g flet style
thing um but now I'm talking about a
different thing where we want to improve
training of the G flet and we want
uncertainty about what the gonet has
learned so I have a question about the
generalization you get closer to the
microphone or speak louder yeah uh so I
have a question about the generalization
part do you think it's related to
picking the training trajectories or
it's more related to choosing the state
space and action space of your gonet
that will help you generalize because
maybe there is some yeah and the
architecture so in the G FL Community we
tend to think oh okay so we of all of
this g-l machinery and plug in your
architecture and don't worry about it
but I'm saying well maybe it does
matter I mean not only the architecture
but even the state space yeah yeah the
state space the action space all of
this is you know involves choices that
could have a huge effect on how easy or
hard it's going to be to optimize our
objective yeah by the way it's the
normal thing in machine learning
I was just going to comment about the
uncertainty estimation that somehow the
information we have about the forward
trajectories and the forward policy and
the backward policy and how inconsistent
they are with each other that's already
some kind of
built-in uh to estimate uncertainties so
yeah wondering but they could be
consistent and
uncertain true then you go yeah so yeah
I think I think what you're saying is
like an extra clue but it's not
sufficient yeah yeah no no it's
to okay so let me move
on um I'm gonna now talk about beian
stuff before I talk about beijan stuff
I'm going to talk about the problem with
not being
beian
um
by way before G flet came into like my
mental landscape I used to think that
ban machine learning was nice in theory
but impossible in practice and I've
changed my
mind and so much so that now people
think I'm a beian I've always been it's
just I thought oh this is like oh nice
thank you but
um yeah I didn't see how we could mesh
that with NE Nets and and what you
know but but but now I see and we we
have several papers going in that
direction so so yeah what's the problem
with maximum L cute um in practice we we
know with LMS for example we get
hallucinations we
get our our trained models to be
confidently wrong and that's bad really
bad
and potentially really
dangerous um and when we
consider
uh a model that is then being used as
like a reward function or um in
reinforcement learning as a world model
and then we going to optimize some
policy on that then things get even
worse because the policy is going to
optimize over that confidently wrong
model and it's going to be sure that it
has found a way to make a lot of
money but it's going to be a
fantasy and yeah when it's too good to
be true don't trust
it so so what can we do about this I'm
going to try to argue that we can be
beian and that g
style methods going to help us
um deal with that and then later I'll
talk about some of the challenges which
are related to what I already
introduced okay so
again why being um beian is important
and I'm going to highlight the safety
aspect of
it and you know
safety introduces the aspect that some
of the actions that your AI system can
take can have catastrophic
outcomes how do you avoid that so you
have to be conservative in some way and
if you're going to be conservative you
need to have a notion of what can go
wrong even if you're not
sure okay so let's consider this like
really simple scenario you got an
AI it's in front of two doors left door
right door you have to choose go left go
right
binary and it's seen data based on that
data there are two theories that are
compatible with the data that it could
choose and if it's going to do maximum
like you is basically going to pick one
of them completely arbitrarily so if you
think about neural Nets depending on how
you initialize
it or the particular biases that exist
in in a model but us you know um you
might find one Theory or the other
Theory
but way one way of being basian in a
cheap way is to train multiple neuron
Nets with different initial weights and
and then that that giv you a sort of
cheap beijan solution but but but you
know let's uh let's see here our our
robot um can go left or right and the
first Theory so you know in the bubbles
there um the theory on the left says if
you go left you die that's the
catastrophic outcome if you go right you
get some cake
the other Theory says if you go left you
get some cake if you go right nothing
good nothing
bad okay so what happens if you pick the
you know one of the theories maximum
lude um we don't know which one is
correct so let's say it's
50% and um if you're not lucky you pick
the wrong one so that's
25% um so let's say that
uh the correct one is the one where you
die if you go
left and you pick the wrong
one well you die because you think you
get cake and you're gonna die so not
good
um if you're basian the idea of being
basian you know all this math sounds
complicated but really it's super
simple it's just keep track of all the
theories and act accordingly in a
rational way
so keep track of the theories you just
byy inspection you can say oh I don't
want to go left just in case right go
right so so that's it and you don't die
you get 50% cake 50% nothing pretty
good all right so that's easy when you
have only two theories but what if you
got an exponential number of theories
and how do you do that you know in a
non-toy
setting um
so so if I say that a theory is a new
net it sounds like it's not feasible
unless there's just 10
theories but if if there's an
exponential number of theories because
there are many combinations of things
that could be you know right and
wrong um maintaining a billion y Nets is
not going to cut it
practically so how could you do that um
in the past people have been handling
the
beijan machine learning
question um
making abusive assumptions that which in
the end mean that those systems didn't
scale to complicated tasks so making
very strong assumptions about the
underlying distribution that make it
possible
to do the basian calculations these
there's going to be like sums and
integrals that are intractable in
general but sometimes you can do it
analytically and like linear regression
for example um but of course then things
are not linear and you know then your
model doesn't work
um right
so so here's an important
message even though the exact ban
posterior is generally
intractable in principle we could use on
your net to represent present the
distribution over those
theories right so so instead of
maintaining a billion theories let's say
you've got onee
net that is not representing a theory
but it's a generative model that if you
sample from it gives you a
theory okay so you don't actually
enumerate theories you just have a
machine that can sample one of the
theories um and I'm going to try to
explain that if you had a G Net that
would do that
that um you can basically solve the
problem but there's something
um interesting
here if you've kept track
of all the excitement in AI in the last
uh few months and
years um we can train really really
large NE Nets and they can learn really
really complicated distributions right
this the whole point about the llms and
and Frontier
systems and in fact if you look at the
gonet
objectives with enough comput like a
large enough neur net and training long
enough you can get arbitrarily close to
a objective value of
zero I mean earlier I said it's hard to
train and so on but but it's just a
matter of how much compute it's not
about generalization I mean
generalization will allow you to train
faster but but in principle it's just a
matter of
compute um and so you know maybe there's
a way that we can actually approximate
these posteriors that are interactable
in fact every day we use NE Nets many
applications to compute distributions
that are otherwise you know intractable
we we approximate them right so it's
just seeing the same thing um okay so
how would you do
that
[Music]
um right so remember that the G flets
learn a generative model over some
objects so here the objects would be the
theories that the agent has in its mind
and it could sample one of those
theories one at a time
and and the objective functions and you
know the training objectives we have
many but bottom line they all have the
property that if you minimize them then
the gfl that will sample proportionately
to the reward function so how could we
use that to get a bean posterior well
it's very very simple and easy it's just
one line in the
bottom so let's say we want to get what
is the Bion posterior we want we want we
want two things but the main one is p of
theory given
data so theory is
like a hypothesis about how the world
works or some something you know the the
a model uh whatever could be parameters
but it doesn't have to be could be a
program that's the way I like to think
about
it so so we got we would like to have a
new net that samples a program that's a
theory that that explains your data and
we'd like to pick the theory that is the
most likely no we don't want that we
want to sample a theory proportionally
to its posterior okay so that's what we
would like and if you remember base rule
which hopefully you do
um in order to get a sample from that
posterior we can use as a reward
function the thing on the left which is
the prior P of theta times the lude P of
data given
Theory and the reward is actually
something that we can compute so the
prior might be something
like two to the minus length of the of
the
theory we can choose prior in many ways
but that's just one that's has a lot of
nice theoretical properties anyway it's
easy to
compute the likud is like your normal
like maximum likud objective right you
would have log likud usually so it's
something we can compute and we can even
easily show that you can get away with
using a mini batch of data rather than
looking at the whole data set because
data here is the whole data set if your
data set has a billion things well you
know
um you you you don't want to have to do
a pass for each update of your gonet you
don't want to have to do a billion
computation you know or at least a you
know a billion examples but it turns out
it's fairly easy to get a stochastic
version of the
reward um using a mini batch detail but
point is in principle we can train gfl
Nets so that they will sample over these
theories if the theories are small
enough right because remember what I
said at the
beginning um now actually what you want
is a little bit more than that but it
turns out ginet can do that for you we
want two things we want a sample over
theories so that's P of theory given
data here data is D
sorry um but like what do I do with a
theory you actually what you want in
practice for many problems is is
answering a question also known as
inference
so let's say think about an llm like X
is the question and Y is the
answer so what you want is p of you want
another new
net that learns to simple answers y
given questions X and given the data
set that's the thing you want that you
know you've got a data set somebody asks
you a question and you want the answer
that's like the Ral question that you
really are
after and you see that you can write it
as the you know marginalization where
you sum over all the theories well
that's where the other guy that samples
theories becomes
useful now if I had to run you know to
estimate that sum by Monte Carlo by
sampling from the other network that
generates theories and then cranking it
wouldn't really work I mean it would be
very
expensive because at runtime you would
have to call
this um and it would be it would be a
pain so there is another
way which is we jointly learn to sample
and to marginalize so we can like train
one g-l Nets that does two things at the
same time and if you followed my little
uh presentation yesterday morning I
showed how you can do that like like the
if you think about the initial State
flow or the which is the Z or the
partition function it
is an intractable sum just like
this um and so you know we train the G
we get both the the marginalization
function and we get the simpler of
theta so so in terms of like the
mathematical principles we know how to
do that both of these
operations the only little problem is
Theta is way too big for any like for
most problems of Interest
uh okay now sorry yeah yeah yeah go
ahead so for your for your second line
for marginalization your P of theta not
only depends on D but it depends on your
new inputs does that mean you need to
train a gonet for every input that you
for every new input that you want to he
no no you can condition on it you can
condition on so I I didn't do all the
details but instead of the one so think
of d as
a a set of XY pairs actually what you
need is you condition on that plus an
extra
X um and you can you can get it there's
like a simple way to get both that okay
yeah don't worry about
it all
right so as some of you know I've been
worried
about um misuse of AI and loss of
control of AI this
year and I've been thinking a lot about
from a technical AI point of view what
can we
do
and I've come to the conclusion that
what would be really great
to make sure we can build AI that are
not
dangerous
is if we could
train an AI that understands the world
and human psychology well
enough but also understands its own
limitations of knowledge epistemic
uncertainty so in other words it's
basan and anytime a machine like an AI
another AI or maybe um um proposes to
perform an action we would call this
which I call AI scientists because it's
basically a world model so it it it
has
sorry what's going on you know it can do
these marginalizations so it can answer
questions about harm that may follow
given a particular action in particular
State and
so yeah if we if we were able to train
such um a specialized AI
well you know in general it wouldn't be
specialized it would be knowing a lot of
stuff in order to be able to answer
these questions we could use it to
reject actions that are not
safe um and by the way that's very
different from the way people are
thinking about safety these
days um and and and
more reassuring because I'm not
reassured by the way people are doing it
right now they're like spot checking
okay let's try this let's see the if the
AI you know gives a recipe for building
a bomb to bad
guys all right but there's so many ways
you could query these systems it's hard
to be sure that nothing bad will happen
and in fact as soon as these llms are
put out somebody finds a way to destroy
all the safety
protections but if we had this Dean
thing we could
get
quantitative probabilistic safety
guarantees which I think would be a lot
safer the day when we
reach machines that are smarter than us
I you know there's I wouldn't trust just
some kind of oh let's try it and see if
it works I would rather have some sort
of guarantees that it's not going to
turn against
people okay so now let me go back to
this question of training an AI
scientist as I said in principle we have
the math for it we just don't have the
algorithms to scale at that level of
understanding of the world uh comparable
to what you find in chat GPT and things
like this so what what um what could we
do well I want to go back to this
question of breaking the
task of um of training and understand
and building an understanding of the
world into smaller pieces like this
divide and
concur um so I've always had huge
inspiration in my career from Human
intelligence it's been an amazing
success how do humans manage very
complicated theories of how the world
Works do we like spit out in our mind a
theory of
everything
no we have like little pieces that are
relevant to the current situation or
some imagine
contexts and somehow it's like a
patchwork of how the world works that is
more or less consistent
but if we think a lot about all of these
things we manage
to so think about all the papers that
scientists write they're like each of
them is talking about a little piece of
reality theories about things and
evidence that it might be a good theory
a piece of theory right
um so yeah so I think this is this is
this is a direction I'd like to
explore
um there's another analogy that I find
inspiring which is how we do programming
and how we do mathematics and there are
a lot of connections here so programming
mathematics scientific theories
presumably you know we can have done all
of three here people in this
room they all have this
Patchwork kind of property but also they
all also have this notion that we can
Define little
pieces like a definition of a function
in
programming or a LMA in
mathematics that can be reused in many
ways in order to come up if we were to
unfold it completely with a
theory that's fairly small but explains
a lot of thing which is remember oams
razor and like machine learning
101 so um yeah I think that solving this
problem might give us answers to
building AI for science for mathematics
for programming they're all connected in
a deep
way right I don't want
to yeah so the last bit I want to
mention about
safety uh if we were to apply these
ideas I mean if we were to come up with
algorithms that would do all these
things
um so going back to the safety
question
current approaches to building Frontier
ey systems rely on reinforcement
learning and there's a fundamental like
issue that I mentioned you know too good
to be true and we're optimizing these
systems so that they might find fantasy
answers and in fact there's a lot of
analysis suggesting that as we make as
we increase the compute
power as we make these neural Nets
bigger as we train them longer we get
less and less safety so that's why a lot
of people right now trying
to figure out you know do they know how
to do X because if they do then that's
may be
dangerous and even there are methods
called unlearning where Okay so we've
got we've trained an llm but it it knows
how to make boms can we like remove that
from its knowledge so all sorts of
like um way to uh address the safety
problem but it would be nice if
instead uh we were in a scenario where
the more uh compute we put in our neural
net the more the longer we train it the
bigger we make it the safer we get and
and I have this conjecture that you know
under some
hypothesis um the sort of approach that
I've talked about if we can find
efficient algorithms that can scale um
would have exactly this probability
because the more we would train our our
neural net maybe G Net style the more it
would approach the beig and posterior
and the Bion posterior would be sort of
safe by construction uh because when it
doesn't know if something could be
harmful you know it would basically not
do that action it would it would say
well you know there's a chance this
could be harmful so let's not do
it
um
yeah I think I'll stop
here yes
sure um so this is this is not well
phrased but I want to discuss um the um
non-stationarity of that distribution of
human preferences oh yeah Oh you mean in
time yeah I mean we yeah yeah yeah it's
it's a big goal right um we can start
start with trying to understand a single
human But ultimately for an AI to be
safe it has
to build a model possibly very uncertain
where it knows UNC its own uncertainty
about all humans or at least all humans
that could be you know benefiting or
harmed by its actions so it's a tall
order but in a way we are doing it right
so I I don't know what most of you think
but I I have some general idea and
including some uncertainty because I
know that there are variations between
people and when I get to know a person I
know what their preferences are and when
we're not sure because we don't know
that person we behave accordingly right
this is what we would expect from a
basian AI yeah this is actually the the
connection to the second thought which
is we're going to have also to decide
how much detail we want to give that uh
AI like if it's going to have to have an
impact on on me as an individual then
I guess as you just said you're GNA have
to provide information if you want about
yourself but if you're going to have if
this is going to be a if the action of
the agent that's wearing the scientist
is going to be more Global then you have
to have a representation of that Society
or that group yeah yeah the only way
eventually you know when we we reach AI
that are deployed in the world um is
that they they have a pretty good
understanding of society psychology and
all the diversity of cultures and people
yes there's no other way
around I'm also curious about this
question of building the like beijan
posterior of human
preferences and it seems to me that in
general in beijan when we do ban
inference we treat data points kind of
similarly uh but when I think that's a
choice we can make yeah okay but yeah
I'm curious in this specific situation
because maybe for some questions in
General um like you may need some expert
knowledge to estimate their harm let's
say of some action yes and very few
maybe people in the world can give you
precise answer and general population
would not know so I'm curious how are
we're going to treat these situations
okay so one thing I didn't talk about
is in order for the kind of approach I I
mentioned to
work
and to provide any kind of guarantee it
it will need to have figured
out pretty much all the ways that humans
theorize about themselves and about how
the world works and um and you know
moral
questions
um
so yeah I'm not saying this is something
we can build tomorrow but if if you
think right now we're trying to figure
out the algorithms that would could lead
us there and we could start small but
yeah ultimately if we want to build the
I systems that are very powerful and
maybe smarter than humans we want to
really make sure that they're going to
behave in a way
that is uh is consistent with uh all of
the information available to the human
and by the way if it it doesn't know but
it thinks Some Humans might have useful
answers then it could go and ask them in
fact one of the original
Works um coming up with similar ideas is
in St Russell's book 2019 human
compatible and there the focus he puts
in a Europe's paper that had in 2016 on
this is the relationship between the
human and the AI so when the AI doesn't
know because it's it's basian it has
uncertainty it can ask the
human uh you know what do you think
about this or you know would you
consider this uh
bad thank you so the uncertainty is also
useful from an active learning
perspective for the AI if it doesn't
know if something is harmful then it
might try to acquire that information in
a safe way right we don't want it to
start dissecting humans just to see
what's
inside yeah maybe small P up what do you
do in the situation of conflict when
some people think it is good other
people think it is sorry sorry can you
speak louder yeah so uh small follow up
what do you do what this system will do
in the situation of conflict when some
people think that this is harmful you
mean disagreement yeah disagreement
between between people what AI agent
would do well so disagreement in aan
framework is the norm it's not the
exception we've got many theories and
they're not compatible everywhere so
there there's some questions on which I
think we should go left and you think
you should go right and the like
rational way of dealing with this is to
consider all the theories weighted by
how much they are compatible with the
data so basically we just keep the
theories that are consistent with
everything we
know that prunes out a lot of garbage
but there's still a lot of theories and
then we just average out their answers
if we want to take a decision we can
also
if you want do something like measure
their variance like and that's going to
tell us something about
uncertainty
so that's exactly what Bean is good for
dealing with disagreement because we
don't know what is the right answer and
we have to have what called epistemic
humility but but what we do like in the
end it's like what does you know what's
democracy I mean ideal democracy is
somehow we come
to the the agreement that most people
agree with I mean that that the decision
that most people agree with or something
of that kind this the same
idea Asian machine learning you know is
to like social decision- making like
democracy makes sense thank
you
yeah that made me think but I actually
had a question about the the part about
partial theories so I fully agree with
you know the the idea that brains or
humans do not instantiate like a theory
of everything and yeah but I still don't
fully grasp um yeah what you mean
exactly by partial Theory and especially
you had think about a paper yeah yeah so
I I get the idea but for example you say
we need to be able to evaluate way it's
a partial theories I think you have this
so what what exactly you mean by this by
how do we what what is what we need that
we don't yet theories so again think
about scientific papers what do we need
to evaluate a paper we don't need to
look at all the data collected by All
Humans since the beginning of time we
just need to look at some particular
experimental data that
helps you know uh answer questions about
what what what what the hypothesis are
being tested in that paper or something
right so we somehow have ways to uh
Focus
the um the match between Theory and data
to a very small part of the data space
in terms of which variables we look at
and and what we do with that
um and I can come up with euristic to do
this but I'd like to have a a
mathematical framework that naturally
does that that
will
um yeah that will that will
select just the data and maybe even a
random subset of it because you probably
can't check everything so think about a
theory like you know theory of
gravitation well you're not going to
collect every single thing where gravity
comes about you want to just collect
enough to get statistical
confidence so I think we can really take
a lot of inspiration from how humans
solve the science Discovery problem in
order to uh Inspire our algorithms but I
I don't know how to do it yeah yeah I I
get that so still if I may follow up I
guess mathematically like a partial
Theory would be like a subset of
variables from the right so I have
struggled seeing how we how can we come
up with a general way of valuating
arbitrary subsets of of theories the
combination
of you know the combinations of partial
theories the diversity of partial
theories that we can could have is is
huge right so the way I like to think of
building blocks for
theories is similar to the building
blocks for programs and for
mathematics it's I call them statements
so you've got a short
statement and these statements are not
independent of each other they might
refer to the same objects the same
entities same
definitions and each statement can be
true or
false and a partial theory is just going
to be a collection of these statements
which help
you explain
particular aspects of
uh some particular data points so Theory
partial theory is only helping us
understand some projection of the data
in some Direction that we care about so
a theory usually in
science is about some some learned
projection of the data like some
functions of the data let's say I get an
image but really what I care about are
okay where are the objects where they
are maybe I care only about position and
not velocity whatever right so we we
project the high-dimensional raw data
into some particular variables that are
relevant to the theory and then the
theory is checking whether it's
consistent with the values that these
variables
took uh
yeah um so could you elaborate on how
gonet might help with learning a word
Model A World model yeah yes would you
see that more um at the level of one
gonet where each sample might represent
you know um one piece of the word model
or would you see it at the like level of
multiple gfet that are you know train to
to learn parts of this word model like
okay so maybe one way to think about
this um did you guys see the forward
looking gflow net no
okay no I don't have it in my
slides but but
um so in a normal gonet you have to go
to the end of generating the whole
Theory before you get a reward and
that's not going to fly right that's
what I've been talking about and we've
motivated by this notion of partial
Theory and so on in fact for more than a
year I've been thinking about this we
explored a few things one of the things
was can we train a
gonet uh even if we don't get to a
terminal state so it's just one G flet
but it's going to initially pick some
aspects some variables to say that what
the Gund does it picks a bunch of
statements so let's say a theory is a
bunch of statements that are
true the full theory is generating all
the true statements that are sufficient
to explain the data you have but that's
going to take too much time so we the
gonet might only evaluate a sub
trajectory that considers a small number
of statements and maybe something
different from the G it's more like
exploratory policy chooses
which statements are relev
to some data we're seeing so if I see
something I might invoke just a little
partial Theory that's relevant to that
for example in the real life that's what
happens right we see a movie and you
know things come in our mind that are
relevant to what we're
seeing but so that requires to have some
sort of feedback in the uh you know
middle States and not necessarily at
determin right so in the forward-looking
thing we assume that the reward function
isn't like like a a black hole isn't a u
a sort of homogeneous thing but it can
be broken down into smaller pieces and
that's a standard assumption in
graphical models that
the um so if you remember the reward
that I had it had like fit to the data
and if you look at one piece of it which
is one data point there's going to be
[Music]
some joint
probability that involves that data and
some lat variables and we can break it
down like in graphical models into
smaller pieces corresponding to the
statistical dependencies or causal
dependencies that exist between
variables so so that's the sort of thing
we can
exploit uh so that we don't actually
need to compute the full reward but we
can get a partial reward
for
um you know some of the statements
actually are consistent with some of the
pieces of data and then you can get a
bit of reward and a bit of
reward thank you uh uh so um when the
agent considers different hypothesis to
test how does it go get data to test
which hypothesis is true or which one is
false well that's the standard Active
Learning problem right it wants to
choose experiments that will provide it
with the most information and that
information in a information Theory
sense can be estimated using the model
itself because it's just some you know
some marginalization of log
probabilities that come from the model
itself so we could have another NE net
that estimates how many bits of
information we could we would get by
doing an experiment and it's very close
to the way we're doing now Active
Learning with
gonets and then um that would drive
which experiment would be
conducted
like it would be a reward for deciding
what to
do um and then the G the gonet would
sample experiments that have a high
Information
Gain also like to what extent do you see
like methods from goal conditional
reinforcement learning from what goal
condition reinforcement learning goal
condition right right right help in
acquiring this data
actively
um
yeah so it it's
um it's a good question
um um I think that
um there are many cases where if we want
to do this divide and conquer idea that
I was talking about we we want to do
something like goal
conditioning
um think about how you prove a theorem
right we you might not want to generate
directly fullprof but you first create
some sub goals which are like lemas that
are easier to prove right
um so so I think I think the goal
conditioning literature from RL could be
a useful thing and in our toolbox for
sure also one broad question like uh in
the plan that you presented overall I
did not see a lot ofl like why is it so
no I I repeated it many times that I
think we can take inspiration from a lot
of
existing RL right but we're not trying
to solve the standard RL
problems we're trying to solve a
different problem which would be good
for scientific discovery would be good
for
safety um
um and yeah uh it's not trying to
maximize reward it's trying to
understand how the world works and I use
that in in a way that takes uncertainty
into account
yeah I was more thinking along the lines
of whether the agents that you presented
have agency in them or is it just like
so I the the AI scientist doesn't have
agency but it needs to model agency
because if it's modeling the effective
actions of some
agent uh I mean it needs to be able to
to do that in order to predict what's
going to happen if something bad is
going to happen or what so you do
need that AI scientist to understand
agents but it doesn't need itself to be
an
agent yeah frontal cortex right thank
youhua Emanuel maybe last question uh un
fortunately I'm just hijacking the mic
the mic um oh okay yeah thank you uh
thanks to all the speakers thanks to all
the organizers it was uh took a long
time to organize all of this and it was
very fun so also thanks everyone for
coming